COMMITTEE WILL NOW COME TO
ORDER. GOOD MORNING- IN
RESPONSE TO THE COPA NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN HERE
SOCIAL DISTANCINGAND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF PUBLIC TO
TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW ONE WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE LINE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON SCREEN
AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW.
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
877-692-8953 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SEVEN ZERO FIVE SIX
NINE OH NINE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO TELL IF
THE TELECONFERENCES DIM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO SENATOR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WE MOVED
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY MODERATOR TODAY ONE
ZERO FOR YOUR SUPPORT- AND
OPPOSITION PRESS THIS ONE ONE
AND ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. WHICH
CAN BE A SHORT WEEK ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATE YOUR CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
ON YOU DID AND YOU ARE NOW
READY TO ADDRESS THE- I. WILL
BE ALLOWING. MINUTES FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT FOR BOTH SUPPORT
OPPOSITION ON EACH BILL TO HEAR
AS MANY PEOPLE AS TIME PERMITS
WE ASK YOU PLEASE SIMPLY TO
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION.
AND YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID TO STICK FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE- MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THIS HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE.
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
SREAMLINE HEARING PROCESSING
CONDUCTOR HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE
TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE.
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. WE HAVE
TWELVE BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA
AND THREE OF THOSE BILLS ARE ON
PROPOSED CONSENT. THOSE BILLS-
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY NINE. FIVE
EIGHT AM ELEVEN AB TWELVE
NINETY EIGHT AND FOUR ELEVEN
TWELVE. EIGHTY FOURTEEN THIRTY
ONE. I ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT
SENATOR GROVE WILL NOT BE
ATTENDING TODAY- SO WE DO NOT
HAVE A QUORUM PRESENT YET WE
WILL START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE AT
THIS POINT- AND WE WILL. ALLOW
AUTHORS TO PRESENT TO THE SUB
COMMITTEE SO IT'S C. AS A
MEMBER WOULD. EUROPE FIRST I
THINK FOLLOWED HIM TO. IF YOU
WANT TO COME UP AV EIGHT
SEVENTEEN MEMBERS. WELCOME TO
SOME AMERICAN. INDIANS AND
SENATORS- PROUD TO PRESENT AV
EIGHT SEVENTEEN. THIS BILL
SHOULD LOOK FAMILIAR TO YOU AS
WE ARE PICKING UP THE TORCH
FROM A NUMBER OF MEMBERS AND
SENATORS WHO WORKED ON THIS
ISSUES IN THE PAST. SENATORS IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY THERE WERE
ROUGHLY TWO AND A HALF MILLION.
SPORT FISHING LICENSE ISSUED.
SINCE THAT TIME WE'VE
EXPERIENCED. A STEADY DECREASE
IN LICENSE SALES. IN ORDER TO
ADD THIS FOR TREND DEPART
OFFICIAL. IN A RECRUITMENT
RETENTION AND REACTIVATION OR
R. THREE ACTION PLAN. THIS
PROCESS BROUGHT INTO CROSS
SECTIONS- INTO A BROADER CROSS
SECTION OF STAKEHOLDERS TO THE
TABLE TO IDENTIFY OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO TURN THIS
TREND AROUND. EIGHTY EIGHT
SEVENTEEN PROPOSES TO AUTHORIZE
THE DEPARTMENT. TO IMPLEMENT
SEVERAL RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
FROM THE ACTION PLAN INCLUDING.
A THREE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE AND
DAY ANNUAL FISHING LICENSE AND
ELECTRONIC SPORT FISHING
LICENSES. THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL ON THE
LINE. TO SPEAK UP FOR THEM TO
FAVOR THE BILL IS WAYNE KO TAU-
WITH THE CAO CAO CCA. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU SOME AMBER-
WILL TURNED INTO THE LINE FOR
LEAD SUPPORT MR COOK TO. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS WAYNE CONNELL CALLING
ON BEHALF OF COASTAL
CONSERVATION ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE PLEASED TO
BE THE FATHER OF THE BABY EIGHT
SEVENTEEN. EIGHTY EIGHT
SEVENTEEN THE TRANSITION
CALIFORNIA CALENDAR BASS
FISHING LICENSE. TO ONE THAT IS
VALID FOR THREE AND SIXTY FIVE
DAYS FROM THE DATE OF PURCHASE.
OCTOBER FOURTH NATIONAL
MOVEMENT TOWARDS ADOPTION OF A
THREE SIXTY FIVE MODEL. ONE
COMPONENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE. R. THREE PROGRAM IF
THEY CALL THE PROCESS THAT HAS
BEEN APPROVED BY THE FISH AND
GAME COMMISSION. TRA I WAS
REFLECTED IN THE REPORT BY THE
GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATURE ON
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
ANGLERS IN THE STATE. OF THE
RECREATION CALIFORNIA IS BIG
BUSINESS AND TAX REVENUE FOR
THOUSANDS OF SMALL BUSINESSES
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. AND THINKING
ABOUT THE- CALIFORNIA ANGLERS
SPENT THREE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY. IN RELATED
INDUSTRIES HERE GUYS BOTH
TACKLE. THE ABOVE YOU IS A
MAJOR RECIPIENT OF REVENUE.
FROM THE SALE OF FISHING
LICENSES. AND SPECIAL
VALIDATIONS. WHICH ARE
NECESSARY POSITION NEARLY
EVERYWHERE. IN THE STATE WITH A
FEW LIMITED EXCEPTIONS. I
THOUGHT BEEN THE CASE IN STATES-
MARKET INDUSTRIES FIVE DAYS
COMPLETED. THE STATE STANDARD.
FROM NEW LIFE RAIL. IT'S
PROBABLY THAT CAN BE USED TO
FUND. BOB MY AND- PROGRAM. AT
THE STATE POLICE VOICE CORRECT
AND IN THE QUEUE. OF AND- THAT
SUPPORT THEM WE ARE PLEASED TO
SPONSOR EIGHTY EIGHT SEVENTEEN
SOME MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I AM INTERESTED IN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR. MOON TURN A- THE
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
SENIOR LEAD WITNESS IS ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM THAT WAS
JUST TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF A.
B. EIGHT SEVENTEEN SEEING NONE.
NEAR ZERO NINE. PRETTY WENT
TURNED TO THE LINES IF ANYONE
WISHES TO TRANSPORT. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
B. EIGHT SEVENTEEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBERS THIRTY NINE THAT'S
THREE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE THIRTY NINE WE CHECK
YOURSELF FOR SELF MUTE WE ARE
NOT HEARING ANY AUDIO. AND
APPEARS TO HAVE NOW REMOVED
THEMSELVES FROM THE QUEUE WILL
MOVE ON TO LINE NUMBER THIRTY
SEVEN THAT'S THREE SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MORNING MR CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS NAMES
GERRY BROWN AND I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY WILDLIFE FEDERATION-
REPRESENT ABOUT TWENTY THOUSAND
SPORTSMEN IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
MY ONLY SUPPORT AV EIGHT
SEVENTEEN. I THINK IT'S A GREAT
DEAL THAT WE SHOULD ACTUALLY.
GETTING BACK UP TO WHERE
EVERYBODY ELSE IS IN THE NATION
AND- AND HAVE A THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE DAYS SPORTING
FISHING LICENSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OKAY THANKS A LOT EIGHT
FOLKS WE'RE JUST GONNA SAY NAME
AND POSITION ON THE LEGISLATION
AND IF YOUR PHILLY WITH AN
ORGANIZATION SHE T. INPUT BUT
HIS NAME. AND WITH THE SUPPORT
THE BILL NEXT. WE HAVE ONE
MORNING Q. THAT'S ONE NUMBER
FORTY SIX THAT'S FOUR SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MORNING JURY
MEMBERS JERRY DESMOND ON BEHALF
OF RECREATIONAL BOATERS OF
CALIFORNIA THE FIFTY YEAR OLD
NONPROFIT ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
THE VOTING PUBLIC IN SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE OF ALL THE REASONS
STATED PREVIOUSLY. THANK YOU.
OKAY THANKS SO MUCH- NO OTHERS
IN SUPPORT WILL NOW TURN TO ANY
OPPOSITION WE DON'T HAVE ANY
LISTED ON FILE BUT- THERE'S AN
ILLUSION HAS DRAWN OPPOSITION
HEARING ROOM SEEING NONE. OF
THE OTHER ROOM. SEEING NONE
ANYONE ALIGNS WISHING TESTIFIED
IN OPPOSITION. IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
EIGHT ONE SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MISTER CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE
SHOWING UP AT THIS TIME. OKAY
VERY GOOD WE WILL COME BACK TO
THE DIES THEN I JUST TO CLARIFY
YOUR YOU'RE ACCEPTING THEM IN
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ABSOLUTELY
OKAY GREAT- QUESTIONS CENTERED
I JUST HAVE A QUICK QUESTION
FROM. THE CURB THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL- I'M GONNA
BE PLEASED TO SUPPORT MY ONE
QUESTION IS THIS SORT OF
CHANGES- THE PERIOD. FOR A
LICENSE FROM A CALENDAR YEAR TO
A YEAR FROM THE TIME THAT DAY
OUR ISSUED THE LICENSE. IS THAT
RIGHT RIGHT ARM. D. WHAT ISSUES
DO YOU THINK THAT RAISES ANY
NEW ISSUES TO ADDRESS THAT COME
UP IN THE DEBATE THAT THERE
MIGHT BE AN ISSUE WITH THAT AND
SOME MORE- YOU KNOW THIS BILL
HAS BEEN PRESENTED HAS BEEN HAS
BEEN TRIED MULTIPLE MULTIPLE
TIMES I THINK THERE'S ALWAYS
BEEN A CONCERN THAT. THAT
MAYBE- THERE MIGHT BE
CHALLENGES WITH REVENUE I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT ACTUALLY- I THINK
THAT YOU KNOW LIKE YOUR COSTCO
CARD OR YOUR TRIPLE A OR A
NUMBER OF THINGS. WHEN YOU PAY
FOR SOMETHING THAT SHOULD LAST
FOR A YEAR YOU ARE GOING TO GET
IT FOR A YEAR AND- AND THAT'S
REALLY REALLY JUST TRY TO
CREATE SOME. I'M SORRY THE WORD
COMMONSENSE AROUND THIS- AND
MAKE IT AND ACTUALLY MAKE IT
USER FRIENDLY FOR FOLKS SO-
THAT'S REALLY ALL WE'RE TRYING
TO DO WELL. THERE WAS ZERO-
STRATEGIC CARE PROBABLY. I'VE
BEEN TOLD THAT NOW SO THANK YOU
I'LL BE READY TO MOVE THE BILL
WHEN IT'S THE RIGHT TIME OKAY
WE'LL WE'LL TREAT THAT AS A
MOTION ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS YES
CENTER JONES. I JUST WANTED TO-
I'M I'M SUPPORT OF THE BILL
ALSO AT THIS COMMITTEE PASSED A
SIMILAR BILL THAT I'M WORKING
ON THAT- COMBINES THE HUNTING
AND FISHING LICENSE FOR THOSE
ON BOTH LICENSES INTO ONE AND
MAKE IT A THREE UNDER SIXTY
FIVE. DAVE A LICENSE ALSO SO
THAT I THINK IS A GOOD IDEA I
THINK THE ISSUES IT COULD COME
UP REGARDING REVENUE IN THOSE
THINGS WILL WORK THEMSELVES OUT
I KNOW THAT THE HUNTERS AND
ANGLERS ARE LOOKING REALLY
LOOKING FORWARD TO THIS TYPE OF
LICENSE SO- THANK YOU DR WAIT
FOR. SPRING FOR. OKAY WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR LAYERED-
ANY OTHER FURTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SEEING NONE WHICH
LOOKED CLOSE. IT FELT- NO WE
HAVE NOT YET WE'VE NOT YET
ESTABLISHED QUORUM JUST
CHECKING YEP NO I'M JUST GONNA
LET HIM CLOSE AND THEN WE WILL
ESTABLISH THAT FORM SO DOCTOR
WOULD THANK YOU MR THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN VERSE I'VE ALSO NOTE
THAT THIS WILL ALSO ALLOW FOR
THE DEVELOPMENT OF A OF A- A
DIGITAL LICENSE SO MOST OF US
HAVE SMART PHONES NOW I JUST
WENT FISHING THIS WEEKEND AND-
HAVING TO CARRY AROUND THAT
PIECE OF PAPER- IS SOMETHING
GETS LOST BUT ADDITIONAL RECORD
BE RIGHT THERE FOR YOU AND I
THINK THAT'S A REAL VALUABLE
PIECE OF THIS PUZZLE. AND YOU
DON'T THINK THAT- SOMEBODY WILL
BE FISHING ALL DAY AND WILL RUN
OUT OF JUICE ON THE PHONE. TO
BE AN ISSUE. I'M HOPEFUL THAT
IF THERE'S A RANGER THEY HAVE A
BATTERY THAT'LL HELP PLUG IT IN
SO THEY CAN RECHARGE. THAT
WOULD BE FULL SERVICE. SOUNDS
ARE COMMANDED TO ME. I'M SORRY
IT'S AWFUL NO IT'S GOOD WITH
TURNED OFF ON A BRIGHT NOTE-
THANK YOU FOR THE CLOSE. LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND THEN WE
WILL CALL THE ROLL UP PLEASE-
KEEP CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLE STERN HERE EARN HERE JONES
JONES HERE ALLEN. ALLEN HERE
EDMUND HERE EVEN HERE GROVE
HERS BERG VOICE SO LAYERED-
LAYERED HERE LET ALONE. OKAY A
QUORUM IS ESTABLISHED- ANOTHER
WE'RE FULL COMMITTEE CAN WE-
CALL THE ROLL WE HAVE A MOTION.
FROM CENTER WHERE DO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST NDED
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. IT FOLLOWED HIM
TO A. B. EIGHT ONE SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS STERN. HI ALL
RIGHT JONES JONES HI ALLEN.
ALLEN I ATE WHEN. ALL RIGHT
GROOVE HERZBERG WAY SO LAYERED.
HI THERE ALL RIGHT LET ALONE.
OKAY THE MID MEASURES FIVE
VOTES WILL LEAVE IT ON COFFEE
HAVE SOME MEMBERS THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR YES
THREE ITEMS ON CONSENT AND
WHILE WE HAVE A QUORUM HERE I
WOULD MOVE THOSE SIDE SURE
THAT'S A MOTION FOR CENTER
LATER ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
COMMITTEE CHIEF CONSOLE CAN YOU
CALL THE WRONG THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THE CONSENT CALENDAR
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY NINE
FINALIZED IN LEVIN AB TWELVE.
NINE EIGHT AND VIOLENT AND
TWELVE AB FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE.
STERN HI. ALL RIGHT JONES.
JONES ALL RIGHT ALLEN. ALLEN HI
AIKMAN. IGMAN ONLINE GROWTH.
HURTS BERG. VOICE SO. LAYERED.
HI LAYERED I LIVE ALONE. OKAY
THAT MEASURES FIVE VOTES WE
WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS IN TURN NEXT TO
THE NEXT ITEM ON OUR AGENDA.
CENTERS IN REVERSE I BELIEVE
FILE IN THREE A. B. TWO FIVE
TWO. HE ALMOST BEAT HIM. GET
SHIPPED TO MEASURES BEFORE US
HERE TODAY INVESTORS- VERY GOOD
VERSUS TWO FIVE TWO MR YES SIR
PLEASE PROCEED WELL GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING SENATOR
SCRIPTS EVERYBODY AND YEAH I
LIKE THAT THE START BY THANKING
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
ENGAGEMENT IN AND WORK ON THIS
LEGISLATION AND THIS IS A BILL
THAT PROPOSES GREAT NEW
PROGRAM- BUT PROGRAM TO
REPURPOSE IRRIGATED
AGRICULTURAL LAND HAS BEEN
TAKEN OUT OF PRODUCTION DUE TO
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT ACT OTHERWISE KNOWN
AS SIGMA'S. AS GROUNDWATER
BECOMES LESS AVAILABLE A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF IRRIGATED
LAND INCLUDING A. HALF A
MILLION ACRES IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY ALONE WILL HAVE
TO COME OUT ABOUT CULTURAL-
SOME PRODUCTION AND
UNFORTUNATELY IT SEEMS
INEVITABLE AT THIS POINT. AND
SO WITHOUT A PLAN OR A
STRATEGIC APPROACH TO ADDRESS
THIS SIGNAL RELATED REDUCTIONS
IN AGRICULTURAL WATER USE AND
SUBSEQUENT FOLLOWING OF A
FARMLAND IT'S CERTAINLY GOING
TO BECOME AN ENVIRONMENTAL
LIABILITY RESULTING HOT SPOTS
OF DUST AND WEEDS AND INVASIVE
PESTS THAT WILL IN TURN DRAG
DOWN OUR AGRICULTURAL
ECONOMIES. AND IMPACT AIR
QUALITY AND- BOB FIVE SOME BOOK
BUT THE HUSKIES ME THE PILOT
WOULD. THAT BIO THE- THIS
LEGISLATION WILL INSTEAD. IT
SURE THAT WE'RE APPROACHING
THIS ISSUE MORE STRATEGICALLY-
BY WORKING TO REPURPOSE IDLE
THERE FOLLOWED LAND. IN WAYS
THAT- THAT WILL BENEFIT OUR
ECONOMY AND ENVIRONMENT. FOR
PURPOSES LIKE HABITAT
RESTORATION GROUNDWATER
RECHARGE OR CATTLE GRAZING. NO
THIS BILL ENJOYS BROAD SUPPORT
FROM BY MY GROUPS FROM ITS
BUSINESSES IN WATER AGENCIES
AND OTHERS- IT IN AND YOU KNOW
AND MANY OTHERS. I HAS NO KNOWN
OPPOSITION RESPECT US FOREIGN I
VOTE- WITH ME HERE TO PROVIDE
SOME TESTIMONY. IS AND HAYDEN
WHO IS A SENIOR DIRECTOR FOR
WESTERN WATER IN RESILIENT
LANDSCAPES AT THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND. SHE'S ALSO HERE
TO ANSWER ANY ARMS- SOME
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE VERY GOOD THEY GIVE
US A CHECK YEAHTHANK YOU
SUMMER- LET'S TURN TO THE
NEARLY SUPPORT WITH THIS MISS
HAYDEN. WELCOME GOOD MORNING
YEAH GOOD MORNING I AM IN
HAYDEN WITH UNBEARABLE DEFENSE
FUND THE SPONSORED EIGHTY TWO
FIFTY TWO OUR STATE IS FACING
AN UNPRECEDENTED DROUGHT
EMERGENCY WATER SUPPLIES FOR
COMMUNITIES AGRICULTURE AND
WILDLIFE ARE DWINDLING AT AN
ALARMING RATE AND WE HAVEN'T
EVEN FULLY RECOVERED THE LAST
DROUGHT JUST FIVE YEARS AGO AND
JUST LAST WEEK THE GOVERNOR
EXTENDED THE DROUGHT EMERGENCY
TWO NINE MARK JOHNNY. DURING
OUR LAST DROUGHT THE
LEGISLATURE CHECK IMPORTANT
ACTION BY PASSING THE
SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT ACT OR STIGMA. TO
DRESS DECADE THE GROUNDWATER
OVER PUMPING WHICH CAUSED LAND
THANKS DAMAGED INFRASTRUCTURE
AND DRIED UP COMMUNITY DRINKING
WHILE. STATEMENT AS ONE OF
SEVERAL IMPORTANT STRATEGIES
NEEDED TO BUILD LONG TERM WATER
RESILIENT AS WE FACE THE IMPACT
OF CLIMATE CHANGE MORE QUICKLY.
AND INTENSELY THAN PREVIOUSLY
EXPECTED SURE ONE UNFORTUNATE
REALITY OF THIS TRANSITION TO
LONG TERM SUSTAINABLE WATER
SUPPLIES IS THAT A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF AGRICULTURAL LAND.
POTENTIALLY THE SIZE OF YOUR
FAMILY WILL NEED TO BE TAKEN
OUT OF PRODUCTION OVER THE NEXT
COUPLE DECADES. AND THIS SUMMER
WE'VE ALREADY SEEN SOME FARMERS
CARRYING OUT ORCHARD VALLEY
FIELD BECAUSE THERE SIMPLY
ISN'T ENOUGH. WATER TO GO
AROUND. CLEARLY ADDED POINT
WITH CHANGE AND WE WERE NOW
WILL SHAPE THE FUTURE OF OUR
STATE AND OUR AGRICULTURAL
ECONOMY. WITHOUT THE RIGHT
INTERVENTIONS AGRICULTURAL LAND
CAN BECOME A HAPHAZARD
PATCHWORK OF DUSTY IDLED FIELD.
WITH INVASIVE WE'D BEEN PASSED.
FURTHER IMPAIRING AIR QUALITY
WHERE IT IS ALREADY THE WORST
IN THE COUNTRY AND PUTTING MANY
FARMERS AND FARM WORKERS OUT OF
WORK. WITH MEASURES LIKE A
BEACH IS A DETAIL THE STATE
COULD TRANSFORM ITS PREVIOUSLY
IRRIGATED LAND INTO A WATER
RESILIENT AGRICULTURAL REGION
WITH A MOSAIC AND VIBRANT NEW
LAND USES LIKE HABITAT
CORRIDORS. MULTI BENEFIT
GROUNDWATER RECHARGE AREAS AND
OUTDOOR RECREATIONAL SPACES FOR
FAMILY. BY ESTABLISHING THE
MULTI BENEFIT LANDRY PURPOSELY
INCENTIVE PROGRAM EIGHTY TWO
COULD YOU TERRIBLE ENABLE
FARMERS TO RECEIVE PAYMENTS
FROM VOLUNTARILY RE PURPOSING
SOME OF THEIR LAND. IN NEW
BENEFICIAL USES THE COMMUNITY
NEEDS AND WANTS AND ULTIMATELY
THE PROGRAM WILL HELP TAKE THE
STATE DOWN A NEW PATH TOWARD A
MORE RESILIENT FUTURE FOR
PEOPLE AND WILDLIFE. WE'D LIKE
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
REAVIS ANTHOLOGY FOR THEIR
PARTERSHIP ON EIGHTY TWO FIFTY
TWO AND RESPECTFULLY. URGE AND
I ABOUT THANK YOU. THANK YOU MS
HAYDEN- WILL TURN TO OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT JUST YOUR
NAME. TITLE AND WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT THE BILL. THERE'S NO
ONE IN THE HEARING ROOM AND NO
ONE IN THE AUXILIARY ROOM. SOLET'S TURN TO THE LINES
OPERATOR. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AND RIGHT OFF
THE BAT WE HAVE SEVEN IN Q.
WILL START WITH LINE NUMBER
SEVENTEEN THAT'S ONE SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I MEAN I KNOW
WE'RE NOT ALONE COMPANY AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
BORDERLINE NUMBER TWENTY NINE
IT'S TWO NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS TIFFANY
MARK ON BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY
ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY FARMERS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GROWING
NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN THAT'S FIVE
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING NATALIE NEXT ON BEHALF
OF. EIGHTY TWO FIFTY TWO THANK
YOU. GROWING NUMBER FIFTY FIVE
THAT'S FIVE FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
AMANDA MONACO WITH LEADERSHIP
COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF A BEAT. HERE THANK
YOU. A GROWING NUMBER SIXTY
THAT SIX ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND THEY'VE TAKEN THEMSELVES
OUT OF THE QUEUE WILL MOVE ON
THE LINE NUMBER NINETEEN THAT'S
ONE NINE. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
ANDREW MUSE FISHER WITH THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. POLITE NUMBER
FORTY NINE FOUR NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ROGER
DICKINSON UP THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMISSION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANALYSTS WINNING QUEUE IS ONE
NUMBER FIFTY SIX THAT'S FIVE
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DRIVABLE
GOT- PULPIT DIRECTOR FOR
SUSTAINABLE CONSERVATION AND
PART OF THE MATTER. OKAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THAT'S ALL THE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WILL TURN
OPPOSITION WE HAVE NO LISTED ON
FILE- ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM OR IN THE ACTUAL ROOM NINE
I PRETTY MUCH CHECK THE LINE
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
OPPOSITION. SURE IF YOU LIKE
SPEAK OUT IN OPPOSITION OF A.
B. TWO FIVE TWO. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
DO HAVE ONE THAT IS JUST QUEUED
UP PLEASE ALLOW US A MOMENT OF
PRIDE IN THEIR LINE NUMBER.
WELL THE LINE NUMBER FORTY
THREE THAT'S FOUR THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CAPTAIN
FREEMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES AND ALSO THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA WHERE TWENTY- REBATE
SOME CONCERNS WITH THE AUTHOR.
AND HIS DOCTOR LATER TO SOME
PROVISIONS ARE ADDED DURING THE
SECOND HOUSE RELATED TO THE
WILLIAMSON ACT WHICH WILL BE
HEARD AND AFTER MANY WE JUST
WANT TO SAY HOW MUCH WE
APPRECIATE THE ALTERNATE STOP
FOR WORKING WITH US IN OUR
MEMBER COUNTIES TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUES WITH THIS LANGUAGE.
PRIOR TO THE NEXT COMMITTEE
HEARING AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS. OVER
THE NEXT FEW WEEKS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
AN OPPOSITION BETWEEN. SURE
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME OKAY VERY GOOD- WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE DICE THEN
I'LL JUST SAY AT THE OUTSET- WE
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK. AS A
MEMBER OF YOUR STAFF- GETTING
THIS BILL IN IN SHAPE- YOU KNOW
WE KNOW WE'VE HAD A BIT OF AN
OVERALL HERE BUT I THINK IT
STILL ALIGNS WITH YOUR PURPOSES
AND HOPEFULLY WILL FUNCTION- AS
A VERY UNIQUE ONE OF A KIND
PROGRAM WE REALLY DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING LIKE THIS RIGHT NOW IN
LAW THERE'S- THERE'S- THERE'S
VARIOUS PROVISIONS THAT THAT
HAVE OTHER INCENTIVES OR-
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE OR-
CONSERVATION EASEMENTS OR LAND
ACQUISITIONS BUT- NOTHING IT
SORT OF HAS THIS MULTI BENEFITS
APPROACH SO. I'M EXCITED ABOUT
WHERE WHERE WE LANDED HERE I
KNOW THAT THERE WERE SOME
CONCERNS RAISED BY MEMBERS AND
SOME STAKEHOLDERS- ABOUT. THE
DURABILITY OF THE BENEFITS AND
HOW TO DEAL WITH SORT OF THE
ONGOING- NATURE OF THE OF THE
OF THE USE OF THAT LAND AFTER
THE- WARDED BEEN GIVEN SO I
THINK THE TH WHAT WE TALK TO
STAFF ABOUT- AND YOUR SPONSORS-
WAS TO. ADULTS WE'RE GONNA TAKE
THE AUTHORS MOMENTS YOU PUT
FORWARD HERE BUT THEN WE'RE
GONNA WE'RE GONNA WORK TOGETHER
I WOULD COMMITTEE STAFF AND THE
STAFF A GOVERNMENT FINANCE OVER
THE SUMMER BREAK TO LOOK AT
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS AND
DEVELOP THAT ARE ACCEPTABLE TO
BOTH COMMITTEES I WANT TO MAKE
SURE I'VE GT THIS RIGHT AND
THAT YOU'RE COMFORTABLE WITH
IT- TO DEVELOP PROVISIONS
REGARDING RETIREMENT OR- OR
RESTRICTIONS ON GROUNDWATER
PUMPING FOR PROJECTS THEY
REPURPOSE IRRIGATED
AGRICULTURAL LANDS. FOR OTHER
PURPOSES UNDER THIS BILL AND
THE SECOND PIECE WOULD BE TO
AUTHORIZE PAYMENTS TO
INCENTIVISE FARMERS AND
LANDOWNERS TO RE PURPOSING
THOSE LANDS PURSUANT TO THIS
BILL- WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE COULD DO- INSTEAD.
WITHOUT CROSSING ANY GIFTING
LINES- AND WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE HAD DURABILITY BUT NOT
NECESSARILY SOMETHING SO BLUNT
AS AN ALL OUT RESTRICTIONS ON
PUMPING WRITES. SOMETHING THAT
WOULD WORK IN THE CONTEXT OF
SIGMA- SO- THOSE ARE YOU
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT THAT IS-
THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING AND YOU
KNOW AGAIN REALLY APPRECIATE
ALL YOU KNOW ALL THE WORK ON
YOU KNOW. YOUR WORKERS SHARE
THE WORK OF STAFF- REALLY
BEATING CAGE MEANT BUT YEAH MY
MOMMA IN AGREEMENT OKAY GREAT-
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OF SENATOR.
THANK YOU. AND THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FOR DECEMBER
REALLY REALLY FASCINATING I
THINK SOME OF THE STUFF WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT FOR A LONG
TIME- AND REALLY COMING UP WITH
A COMMON SENSE APPROACH TO BE
ABLE TO. AND WE CAN'T JUST
CHANGE PEOPLE'S WHOLE WAYS OF
LIFE WITHOUT PROVIDING SOME
KIND OF ALTERNATIVE RIGHT IT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE NOR DOES IT
SEEM EQUITABLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I GUESS IT'S ALL MY
QUESTIONS AROUND SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT YOU'RE ALREADY
RAISED- BUT THEN I GUESS JUST
CURIOUS AS SOMEBODY WHO'S LIVED
AND WORKED AROUND AG WHY THE
DECISION TO DO. THIS OR THAT
THE GRANT PROGRAM TO DEVELOPER
FELLOW GROUND BUT AT THE SAME
TIME THE WILLIAMSON ACT WHY DO
BOTH OF THOSE THINGS. TOGETHER
AT THE SAME TIME. AND THEN MY
OTHER QUESTIONS ARE JUST
AROUND- THE ACTUAL PURPOSES I'M
I'M SURE AT SOME POINT IT'LL BE
DELINEATED OUT- BUT FOR SOME
THINGS THAT ARE THAT CAN STILL
BE WATER INTENSIVE WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT RANGE LAND AND
CATTLE AND THINGS LIKE THAT
AND- NOT THAT I DON'T LIVE A
GOOD BURGERS MUCH AS ANYBODY
ELSE BUT- WE ALSO UNDERSTAND
THAT- THE- THE- THE WEAR AND
TEAR ON THE LAND WITH SOME OF
THE ACTIVITIES THAT. ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH HIS NON
IRRIGATED LAND. AND THEN AT THE
SAME TIME I WE STILL. WE'RE IS
IT GOING TO SOME COCONUT COURSE.
A PROGRAM THAT I. MY ARE THE
GROUND WATER BASEMENT IT NO
SIGMA AREAS. TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHATEVER NEW PROGRAMSARE
PUTTING IN. INDEED HAS A
LIGHTER FOOTPRINT AND HOW HOW
LIKE THAT FOOTPRINT IT'S GOING
TO CREATE. BUT THOSE ARE SOME
GREAT QUESTIONS AND AS THE
CHAIR MENTIONED- THESE ARE
ISSUES THAT WE CONTINUE TO WORK
THROUGH I THINK THE MONITORING
AND REPORTING IS VERY- YOU KNOW
IN A PARK CONCEPT OF THE BILL
THAT NEEDS TO BE  PART OF IT
YOU KNOW AS FAR AS- YOU KNOW-
INSURING THAT WE PRIORITIZE OUR
CRITICALLY. DRAFTED OUR BASINS
IN EMPHASIZING THIS PROGRAM.
FOR THOSE REGIONS- IS NOT THE
HEART OF THIS KIND OF THIS
BILL. AS FAR AS- THE RECENT
CHANGES WE'VE HAD- AS A RELEASE
IT WAS AN ACT I WILL HAVE TO
TURN IT OVER TO- ARE A SPONSOR-
VOTING OUT FOR THOSE QUESTIONS-
BUT- YOU KNOW AT THE SAME TIME.
REALLY APPRECIATE THE COMING TO
ME I THINK IT'S YOU KNOW
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT. THAT YOU
KNOW WE WORK TO RESOLVE- YOU
KNOW A LOT OF THESE ISSUES
BECAUSE THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT
IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT- FOR-
AGRICULTURE FOR THE INDUSTRY.
AND YOU KNOW CERTAINLY FOR MANY
REGIONS. ACROSS THE STATE THAT
ARE IMPACTED. SEVERELY BY THIS
DROUGHT- AND THE ONE THING THAT
IS DIFFERENT ABOUT THIS
DROUGHT. IS IS HAVING TO WORK
THROUGH CIGNA- AND IT'S-
CERTAINLY- INSURING- THAT-
WE'RE DOING WHAT WE CAN TO
SUPPORT. THOSE THAT ARE
IMPACTED BY THE SAME TIME HAVE
A BENEFIT. FOR THIS REGION.
WHERE THE- YOU KNOW. HUNDREDS
OF THOUSAND ACRES IN THE SALAD
AND SO IT'S SIGNIFICANCE AREN'T
AREN'T. AND HERE AND I CAN
WEIGH IN ON THE WILLIAMSON ACT
BUT HUMAN- REGARDING THE
INCLUSION OF THAT LANGUAGE-
WE'RE AIMING TO ENSURE THAT.
EXISTING LINES NOT CONTRACT OR
NOT EIGHT THAT THE CENTER OF
OUR PARTICIPATION IN THE NEW
PROGRAM SO THE GOAL IS TO.
REALLY ENSURE THAT REPRODUCING
ACTIVITIES FUNDED BY THIS
PROGRAM WOULD NOT CONFLICT WITH
LAND USE AS- AN A CONTRACT THEN
THAT. LANDOWNERS THAT CURRENTLY
HAVE TAX BENEFITS FROM THE
BLAZE MAX WOULD NOT HAVE TO PAY
INCREASED TAXES AT ST JUDE TO
REPURPOSE PLANTS AND WE'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS THAT BUT JUST
MENTIONED BY ONE OF THE- MANY-
THAT SPOKE TO. THE TOP ON THE
MIND AFTER THREE- EXPRESSED
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE
LANGUAGES THAT WE ARE COMMITTED
TO WORKING WITH THEM ON. AND.
THEN IN THE COMING DAYS AND
WEEKS. EVERYTHING YOU KNOW WE
JUST SAID NO THIS COME AND AN
OTHERS FOR GOING FOR THE STATE
HAS HAS AT NOT BEEN A TO UPHOLD
OUR RESPONSIBILITIES IN
PAYMENTS OF WILLIAMSON ACT FOR
THE LAST FEW YEARS AND
HOPEFULLY- AS WE'RE ADDING NEW
THINGS AND WE'LL FIGURE OUT A
WAY. HOPEFULLY THIS YEAR WE
HAVE FIGURED OUT A WAY BUT WILL
CONTINUE TO FIGURE OUT WAYS. TO
PAY FOR OUR OUR FAIR SHARE OF
THAT- OF THAT PROGRAM SO IT'S-
REALLY INTERESTING WORK I WILL
BE INTERESTED TO SEE HOW THIS
GOES FORWARD- AND IT WAS- I WAS
IN THE LEGISLATURE WHEN WE
PASSED A- SIGMA WHICH- EVERYONE
THOUGHT THE WORLD WAS COMING TO
AN END BUT- AS WE- LOOK BACK I
THINK WE CAN CERTAINLY SEE.
THAT WE DID IT THAT PROBABLY AT
THE LAST POSSIBLE MOMENT TO DO
IT. AND STILL BE ABLE TO GO ON
TO JUST THINK WHERE WE'D BE IF
WE HADN'T PASSED THAT. IN THIS
KIND OF DROUGHT THAT WE'RE
HEADING INTO NOW. THAT AT LEAST
WERE ABLE TO START TO MAKE
PLANS. TO REALIZE WHAT WE HAVE
DONE SO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
VERY INTERESTING AND I THINK
RIGHT THE SPACE SO WE NEED TO
BE WORKING IS. HOW DO WE
CONTINUE TO MAKE CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE WORKING AREA. GOING
FORWARD UNDER NEW CONDITIONS.
THANK YOU SENATOR AGAIN SENT
EARLIER. I'M REMINDED OF THE
LAST SCENE AND MOONSTRUCK WHERE
THE FATHER JUST GOES JUST SO
CONFUSED. BECAUSE THIS IS
MOVING SO FAST AND YOU READ THE
ANALYSIS BUT THAT AMENDMENTS
COME AND THE AMENDMENTS IN SOME
WAYS ON AMENDMENTS IT'S AN
AGREEMENT TO DO SOMETHING IN
THE FUTURE AND TRY TO WORK IT
OUT. AND THIS MIGHT BE OUR ONLY
BITE AT THIS APPLE AND SO- AND
I'M GLAD FOR THE CLARIFICATION
TO THE EXTENT IT WAS A
CLARIFICATION ON THE WILLIAMSON
ACT BECAUSE IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
THAT IS STILL AN ISSUE THAT IS
GOING TO BE AN ISSUE AND IT
MIGHT BE AN ISSUE COMING FROM
THE OTHER DIRECTION. NOT JUST
THAT SOMEBODY PAYS HIGHER TAXES
BUT THIS BILL MIGHT PROTECT
THEM AND THE WILLIAMSON ACT
MIGHT PROTECT THEM SO WHY IS
THERE A DUPLICATION OF
PROTECTION AT THE END I THINK
THAT THAT IS GOING TO HAVE TO
BE ADDRESSED IN THIS. AS WELL.
AND I WALKED INTO THIS HEARING.
NOT AWARE THAT SOME OF THE
STUFF WHAT WOULD BE TALKED
ABOUT. WITH THE CONCERN THAT I
WAS GOING TO DRILL DOWN ON.
WHICH IS THAT- IT THERE'S THE
WHOLE ISSUE OF TAKING LAND OUT
OF USED TO RE PURPOSE BUT
THERE'S NO STATEMENT IN THE
BILL AS TO WHETHER THAT'S
REQUIRED FOR HOW LONG AND IF
THERE ARE SOME BENEFITS
ACCRUING TO SOMEBODY AND THEN
NO COMMITMENT TO SORT OF DO
WHAT'S ON THE OTHER HALF OF
THAT THAT SEEMS TO BE THE OPEN
ISSUE THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED I SORT OF GATHERED
FROM THE SHIP. CHAIR'S COMMENTS.
THAT THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
YOU'RE GOING TO TRY TO ADDRESS
OVER THE NEXT MONTH. AND I
RECOGNIZE HOW FUNNY THAT IS
JUST ON THE GROUND BECAUSE
IT'S- IF THEY WISH THE
LANDOWNER WISHES TO RE PURPOSE
FOR ANOTHER REASON. IT'S LIKE
HOW DOES THAT WORK. IF THE
LANDOWNER WAS GOING TO RE
PURPOSE ANYWAY WHY SHOULD WE
SORT OF EXTEND SOMETHING TO
THEM FOR SOMETHING THEY WERE
GOING TO DO ANYWAY. IF IT TURNS
OUT THE DEAD BECAUSE OF SIGMA
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH WATER AND
THEN UNDER THE PROVISIONS OF
SIGMA ONCE YOU DO THE PLAN AND
BETWEEN NOW AND TWENTY FORTY
YOU GO WHEN YOU TRY TO FIND
ADDITIONAL SOURCES OF WATER AS
WELL AS CUTTING BACK. WHAT IF
AN ADDITIONAL SOURCE OF WATER
IS FOUND OR DEVELOPED. AND WE
HAVE PAID SOMEBODY. TO TAKE
LAND OUT OF USE AND THERE MIGHT
BE WATER TO BRING IT BACK INTO
THE USE THAT WAS THE PRE
EXISTING USE HOW DOES THAT FIT
INTO THIS WHOLE SCHEME SO I
THINK THAT THERE'S ALMOST AS
MANY UNANSWERED QUESTIONS. R.
AS ANSWERED IN THE ONE BENEFIT
BY TAKING THE CHAIRS OUR
RECOMMENDATION ADDITIONALLY. IS
THAT THE BUDGET MIGHT ACTUALLY
BE FINALIZED BY THE TIME THAT
WE DO ACTION AND THERE'S A
CHANCE THAT THERE'S SOME MONEY
IN THE BUDGET THAT ADDRESSES
THIS AND THEN YOU COULD LINE UP
THE MONEY IN THE BUDGET FOR
THIS AND HAVE A CLEAR IDEA. OF
WHAT IS DOING AND SO GIVEN THAT
GENERAL STATE OF MOVING TARGET
AND CONFUSION R. R. I WOULD
JUST SAY. THAT I HOPE THAT THE
OUTCOME OF THE WILLIAMSON ACT.
DOES IT AT BOTH BANDS. DOESN'T
SORT OF- BECOME AN INHIBITOR TO
DO THIS AND IN A WAY THAT
THAT'S PROTECTED IN A WHITE TO
ALLOWED TO DO THIS BUT IF IT'S
SORT OF A DOUBLE PROTECTION IS
THERE A WAY TO ADDRESS THAT.
AND THEN ON THE ISSUE OF THE
USE IF SOMEBODY IS GIVEN AN
INCENTIVE TO TAKE SOMETHING OUT
OF USE. WHAT'S THE ISSUE THAT
BINDS THEM IS TOO STRONG A WORD
BUT ALLOWS FOR COMMITMENT THAT
THE STATE GET SOME BENEFITS
EITHER FOR A PERIOD OF TIME OR
WHAT IT IS IN EXCHANGE FOR THE
INCENTIVE AND IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT'S THE BIG MISSING PIECE OF
THIS. AND THEN. THE SO I SORT
OF FEEL NOT UNDERSTANDING
EXACTLY HOW THIS IS MOVING AND
HOW THIS IS GOING TO END. A
NEED TO SAY THOSE ARE A COUPLE
OF CONCERNS THAT JUST NEED TO
BE ADDRESSED IN WHATEVER THIS
PROCESSES OVER THE NEXT FEW
WEEKS AND THE BREAK AND-
ETIENNE ON THE CHAIR. YOU
SHOULD CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE CHAIR EVEN IF THE BILL IS A
YANKED BACK TO COMMITTEE
BECAUSE I THINK. IF THIS BILL
PASSES OUT TODAY. IT IS ON THE
FAITH. THAT YOUR COMMITMENT TO
THE CHAIR TO ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES IS REALLY IMPORTANT FOR
THIS BILL TO WORK. AND SO. YOU
KNOW I GUESS GIVEN ALL. THE
COMMITMENTS AND THINGS SO I
WILL QUOTE FOR THIS BILL
BECAUSE I LIKED THE CONCEPT.
BUT THERE'S JUST MUCH THAT NOT
WHERE OUT YET NEEDS TO BE OUT
FOR THIS. TO HAVE A RIGHT TO GO
THE GOVERNOR'S. BESIDE JUDGES
THOSE WITH THE ISSUES IS. AS I
CAN. THAT BECAUSE IF THERE HAD
BEEN THE- I WOULD BE ASKING YOU
TO TAKE AN AMENDMENT. OR
DEVELOP AN AMENDMENT. TO
DEVELOP THE PROTECTION ON THE
OTHER SIDE FOR ANY AFTER AN
INCENTIVE IS GIVEN TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S GUARANTEED THAT'S
WHAT I WAS FOR. HER TO COME
INTO THIS HEARING AND DO TODAY
SEEMS LIKE. GOT THERE ALREADY
BUT. AND IT JUST MAKES ME
NERVOUS. THAT THIS CLOSE TO THE
END OF SESSION AND THERE'S SO
MANY OPEN ISSUES AND SO IT IS
IN THE OTHER HOUSE AND IF IT
TURNS OUT YOU CAN'T RESOLVE A
LOT OF FUN THEN. YOU KNOW WE
HAVE NEXT YEAR TO DO IT BUT BUT
THAT'S JUST WHERE WE ARE RIGHT
NOW. THANK YOU. THANKS FOR
PUTTING UP WITH ALL OUR STUFF
IS ON. AND THEN IF IT IF IT
HELPS I APPRECIATE THE FEEDBACK
AND MAKE THE COMMENTARY SAID
EARLIER IT JUST TO BE CLEAR I
MEAN THAT THE DEFAULT
SUGGESTION WAS GOING TO BE
ABOUT. THE RETIREMENT OF THAT
LAND PERMANENTLY FROM
GROUNDWATER PUMPING. THE REASON
WE HAD IT OUT A LITTLE NUANCE
AND DIDN'T JUST TRY TO SORT OF.
BLUNTLY ADD THAT IN IS THAT IN
THE CONTEXT OF SIGMA. UNDER SAY
A GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
PLAN IT SUBMITTED IN THEORY- A
DECADE FROM NOW AFTER AFTER AN
INCENTIVE WAS GIVEN TO A
PARTICULAR LANDOWNER. AND A
DECADE OR EVEN TWO FROM NOW
UNDER A UNDER GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY PLANS IN THAT
AREA IT MAY BE THAT. OTHER LAND
IS MORE APPROPRIATE FOR TAKING
OUT OF USE AND THAT LAND IS
ACTUALLY RESTORED AND THE
AQUIFER ITSELF IS IN CONDITION
WHERE. THEY MAY HAVE YOU KNOW
AN ALLOCATION THAT MAKES SENSE
SO WE DIDN'T WANT TO BE. OVERLY
RESTRICTIVE BUT YOUR POINT
ABOUT THE PROPORTIONALITY OF
THE BENEFITS AND THE DURABILITY
AND TIMING WAS REALLY ESSENTIAL
SO I THINK THAT DEFAULT ISN'T
IT JUST AN OUTRIGHT-
RETIREMENT- RESTRICTION BUT I
THINK WE- WE WANTED TO ADD THAT
NEW ONES IN THERE BECAUSE- IT
WE STILL MAY BE ABLE TO. BE
ABLE TO ACHIEVE THE BENEFITS OF
THESE INCENTIVES WITHOUT A
FOREVER. RETIREMENT SO JUST
IGNORE IT IF I MY SISTER ARE
COMMON I THINK THAT'S GREAT. I
APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH AND I
THINK THAT'S KIND OF
FLEXIBILITY AGAINST THE
ULTIMATE GOAL. OF THAT IS
NEEDED AND I'M WAS NOT IN THE
LEGISLATURE WHEN THIS WAS
ADOPTED BUT I ONCE. IN A
POSITION WHERE I WAS INVOLVED
IN IT IN THE ONE THING FOR ME
AND IT AND IT WAS MY INDIVIDUAL
VIEW. OF IT IN THE END THE
DATES WERE PUSHED OUT TO GET
THE LAST VOTES I THINK COURT TO
PROTECT THE LAST VOTED FOR ME.
THE CRISIS IS SO PROFOUND I
THOUGHT. THE DATE NEEDED TO BE
CLOSER. AND ANDREA THE
AGREEMENT WAS MADE TO PASS THE
BILL. AND THE ONLY UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE OF THE THING THAT I
DIDN'T WANT IS IT THERE MIGHT
BE TIME TO WORK THIS OUT IT IN
TERMS OF A CRUX OF THAT IN AND
OUT AND SOME OF THE OTHER
ISSUES OR THE ADDITIONAL WATER
COMING AND SO- APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS MR CHANCE. THANK YOU
FOR THAT ANY OTHER. COMMENTS
QUESTIONS CENTERED AROUND TIME
I JUST WANNA CLOSELY ASSOCIATE
MYSELF WITH THE COMMENTS THAT
CENTER LAYERED- JUST MADE. AND
I THINK IN THE END OF THE DAY-
THERE'S A LOT OF VALUE TO WHAT
YOU'RE DOING THERE'S STILL A
GREAT DEAL OF UNCERTAINTY A LOT
MORE TO BE WORKED OUT- AND I
THINK CONTINUING CONCERNS
ABOUT. ENSURING THAT WHILE
THERE IS A BENEFIT ASSOCIATED
WITH. ENCOURAGING PEOPLE NOT TO
PUMP RIGHT NOW- WHAT IS THE-
WHAT'S THE LONG TERM- AND GET
BACK FOR THE FOR THE STATE. SO
HOW MAY I BE HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY- BUT- DOING SO.
COURAGE IN YOU AND ASKING YOU-
TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH OUR
COMMITTEE AND- NO OTHER KEY
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THIS IS
ULTIMATELY ACCOUNTABLE TO THE
TAXPAYERS OF THE CITY
CALIFORNIA. YOU YOU HAVE A MY
COMMITMENT TO DO SO. SORRY
THANK YOU SOME MEMBER- ANY
OTHER STRUCTURE OKAY I
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION- AND-
WE'VE GOT SOME WORK TO DO. AND
HIS BUDGET PROCESS MOVING TO
ANOTHER GOVERNOR'S GOT A
PROPOSAL OUT THERE BUT
HOPEFULLY THIS PROVIDES THE
BONES OF A FRAMEWORK THAT WE
CAN ACTUALLY TRY TO LAND
SOMETHING HERE SO ALLOW YOU TO
CLOSE AN APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
FEEDBACK YOU KNOW- AGAIN JUST A
APPRECIATIVE COMMENTS THE
CONCERNS AND- YOU KNOW WE YOU
HAVE MY COMMITMENT THAT WE'RE
GOING TO DO. THE BEST WE CAN TO
GET DISCUSSED VERSA AND RESPECT
THAT'S PRIVATE THANK YOU SOME
MEMBER- DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
SOME OF. THE THAT'S A MOTION
FROM SENATOR ADMIN- THEN THE
MOTION. THE PATH IT'S AN
AUTHOR'S AMENDMENT OR- OKAY
CHICKEN SOMETHING MAYBE THE
MOTION AND- HE UNDERSTOOD-
CENTER AGREEMENT PERFECTLY SO
YOU CAN READ THE MARCH. SO THE
MOTION WOULD BE DO PASS TO
RULES WITH A COMMITMENT FROM
THE AUTHOR TO A MAN FOR THE
COMEDIAN ALICE'S IN THE
GOVERNMENT FINANCE COMMITTEE
UPON THEIR RECEIPT OF THE BILL.
AND TO WORK WITH COMMITTEE
STAFF AND STAFF OF GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE OVER THE SUMMER
BREAK TO DEVELOP ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS ACCEPTABLE TO BOTH
COMMITTEES TO DEVELOP
PROVISIONS REGARDING RETIREMENT
OR OTHER RESTRICTIONS ON
GROUNDWATER PUMPING FOR
PROJECTS THAT REPURPOSE
IRRIGATED LANDS FOR OTHER
PURPOSES- UNDER THIS BILL AND-
TO AUTHORIZE PAYMENTS TO
INCENTIVISE FARMERS AND
LANDOWNERS. TO REPURPOSE THEIR
LANDS PURSUANT TO THIS BILL.
VERY GOOD CHIEF CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WITH THAT
EMOTIONAL FILING ON THREE EIGHT
B. TWO FIFTY TWO TO PASS TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE STERN. STERN
ALL RIGHT JONES JONES HI ALLEN.
ALLEN HI AIKMAN. AIKMAN ALL
RIGHT GROOVE HEARD'S BIRD WAY
SO LAYERS BY LAYERED ALL RIGHT
LET ALONE. EVENTUALLY THE
MEASURES FIVE VOTES WILL LEAVE
THAT ON CALL- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DO YOU WANT TO BRING UP YOUR
NEXT BILL FILING FOR YOU B. TWO
FIVE TWO EIGHT FOUR- THIS
AGAIN- ONE. OF ONE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I LIKE TO THINK-
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR GOOD
WORK ON THIS BILL AND- AND I
LIKE TO KNOW THAT I WILL BE
ACCEPTING- THE AMENDMENTS THAT.
WERE PROPOSED AN ANALYSIS. IN
IN IN THIS LEGISLATION WOULD-
TO DIRECT THE CALIFORNIA
RESOURCES BOARD TO SET AN
OVERALL CLIMATE GOAL FOR OUR
STATE'S. NATURAL WORKING LANDS
AS PART OF NEXT YEAR'S SCOPING
PLAN PROCESS. NOW BUT EVEN IF-
OUR CARBON EMISSIONS- STOPPED
AT THIS VERY MOMENT. WE ALREADY
HAVE MORE CARBON IN OUR
ATMOSPHERE THAN SCIENTISTS AND
CLIMATE EXPERTS SAY SAFE. AND
AS WE ALL KNOW WE'RE NOT GOING
TO STOP EMITTING- THIS CARBON-
ANYTIME SOON AND SOAK
SEQUESTRATION OF CARBON IN
SOILS AND IN IN FORESTS
WETLANDS AND OTHER NATURAL AND
WORKING LANDS IS CURRENTLY THE
ONLY PROVEN WAY TO REMOVE
CARBON. FROM OUR ATMOSPHERE AT
A LARGE SCALE AND SO IN FACT
IT'S ESTIMATED THAT-
SEQUESTRATION ALONE COULD BRING
US NEARLY 20% OF THE WAY TO
MEETING OUR STATE'S CLIMATE
GOALS. AND TO CLARIFY THE A. R.
B. SCOPING PLAN IS NON BINDING-
IT'S NOT REGULATORY IN NATURE
IT IS SIMPLY A PLANNING
EXERCISE THAT IS DESIGNED TO
SET GOALS AND PROVIDE POLICY
OPTIONS. THE SCOPING PLAN
ALREADY DEALS WITH ALMOST EVERY
OTHER SECTOR OF OUR ECONOMY.
AND IT MAKES NO SENSE TO LEAVE
THIS IMPORTANT CLIMATE SOLUTION
ON THE TABLE. AND SO IS AND WE
HAVE AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK- WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS. TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS IN IN AND FIND
A REGIONAL PATH FOR THAT
EVERYONE CAN GET ON BOARD WITH
AND WITH THAT MR SHARMA SPOKE
FAST WHEN I VOTED AND WITH ME
HERE TO PROVIDE THE TESTIMONY
ANSWER SOME TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
IS MISSILE. THE SHOP SEVEN. OF
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY AND
GINNY MERYL THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE AND AGRICULTURAL
NETWORK THANK YOU. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU SEPTEMBER- HIS
PASTORAL AND- MISS BERYL YOU ON
THE LINE. YES AT. THANK YOU-
UNDERSELL CASTRO GOOD MORNING
DIRECTED THIS CRIME OCCURRED
ANYTHING URGENTLY AND I COULD
TAKE THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR THE OCT YOU SPEAK
AND OFTEN FAMILY MEMBER FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON IMPORTANT ISSUES
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF PUBLISHED
SCIENTIFIC ANNOUNCES THAT
INDICATE ACTIONS LIKE URBAN
FORESTRY FOREST RESTORATION
FIRE RISK REDUCTIONS LAND
CONSERVATION. RIDING LAND
MANAGEMENT ACTIVITIES CAN
SIGNIFICANTLY CONTRIBUTE TO OUR
LONG TERM AND THE CALL OF DUTY
CARBON IN THE ATMOSPHERE AND
OFFER PROTECTION YOU NEED FROM
A CRIME IMPACT LIKE FIRE STREAM
HE WILL ARISE AND FLOODS- THAT
ARE ETHNIC THERE OVER FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION METRIC TONS
THAT REDUCTION CAN BE. ACHIEVED
IF WE ACT NOW. EACH BY TWENTY
FIFTH. FOR THE PAST THERE'S
BEEN. WORK IN THE STATE ON THE-
BUT SPITE OF THIS CLEAR
CLINICAL AND COORDINATED.
TRANSACTION MIKE WE HAVE IN
OTHER SECTORS OF THE LISTING.
AND IF BUILDING PORTENT
CATALYST YOU GOT THESE ISSUES.
AS A SPONSOR WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL AND- DRIVER.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THOMAS
MERRILL. THANK YOU KAREN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JEANNIE
MERYL. I AM THAT POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE AND AGRICULTURE NETWORK
OR A COALITION OF FORMER
LEADERS IN SUSTAINABLE
AGRICULTURE GROUPS WORKING TO
ADVANCE AGRICULTURAL SOLUTIONS
TO THE CLIMATE CRISIS. WE ARE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT EIGHTY TWO
EIGHTY FOUR WHICH RECOGNIZES
THE NEED FOR CALIFORNIA TO
BOUNCE THE CLINICAL AND RELATED
STRATEGIES FOR VAST AND
IMPORTANT NATURAL WORKING
LANDS. WELL WE AGREE WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES IN AGRICULTURE THAT
WE MUST FIND CLIMATE SOLUTIONS
THAT IMPROVE THE ECONOMIC
VIABILITY AND RESILIENCE OF OUR
AGRICULTURAL LANDS. EIGHTY TWO
EIGHTY FOUR EMBRACES THESE
MULTIPLE BENEFITS AND DEVELOP
THE NECESSARY BIG PICTURE ROAD
MAP WE MOST DESPERATELY NEED TO
BRING WORKING LAND POLLUTION
SCALE IN WAYS THAT WORK WITH
FARMERS. AND COMMUNITY IS NOT
THE ANSWER WHEN OUR FARMERS ARE
ON THE FRONT LINES OF EXTREME
WEATHER EVENTS. LAST YEAR
DURING THE PANDEMIC WE HAD MORE
FARMERS THAN EVER BEFORE
SIGNING UP FOR THE STATE
CLIMATE SMART AGRICULTURE
PROGRAMS LIKE THE OXFORD NOR
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM AND HEALTHY
SOILS PROGRAM. EIGHTY TWO
EIGHTY FOUR WILL ALLOW THE
STATE TO UNDERSTAND THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO SCALE UP ITS
WORK IN MEANINGFUL WAYS. AND
FARMERS ARE DEMONSTRATING TODAY
EVEN DURING THESE UNCERTAIN
TIMES THAT THEY WANT THE
STATE'S CLIMATE EFFORTS TO
CONTINUE. RESPECTFULLY URGE AND
I GO. THANK YOU SO. HONNOLD TO.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- ANYONE IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM WISHING
TESTIFIED SEEING NONE AUXILIARY
ROOM NONE. WILL TURN TO THE
LINES OPERATOR. THANK YOU FOR
YOU LIKE TO PLACE YOURSELF IN
THE QUEUE TO MAKE YOUR VOICE
HEARD IN SUPPORT OF A. B. TWO
A. FOR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE DO
HAVE AT LEAST TEN THAT HAVE
ALREADY QUEUED UP WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND START WITH LINE
NUMBER SEVENTEEN THAT'S ONE
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. RIGHT
ONE OF THE OTHER WITHOUT AMONG
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU A LINE NUMBER FIFTY
NINE FIVE NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MARK FENSTER MAKER
REGISTERING SUPPORT FOR SEVERAL
CLIENTS THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICT THE
PENCIL OPEN SPACE TRUST.
PRESENT A CLEAR VALLEY OPEN
SPACE ABOARD THANK YOU THANK
YOU. A GROWING NUMBER FIFTY
SEVEN FIVE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING NATALIE BACK
ON BEHALF OF MIDLAND REGIONAL
OPEN SPACE PROJECT CALIFORNIA
HABITAT CONSERVATION PLANNING
COLLECTION AND THE LAND TRUST
OF SANTA CRUZ COUNTY ALL OF THE
COURT. THANK YOU. THE LINE
NUMBER SEVENTY THAT SEVEN ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND MISTER
CHAIR MY NAME IS BILL MURPHY
OTHERS CLIMATE ACTIONS NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. BUT A LINE NUMBER
SEVENTY THREE THAT SEVEN THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS NIKITA
KARATE BUT THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GROWING NUMBER FIFTEEN THAT'S
ONE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING SHARON MEMBERSHIP
AKA MARKETS VOICING SUPPORT FOR
EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY FOUR FROM THE
FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS
AMERICAN FARMLAND TRUST CARBON
CYCLE INSTITUTE CALIFORNIA
CERTIFIED ORGANIC FARMERS THE
CLIMATE CENTER AND WORK TO
CHANGE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GROWING NUMBER FORTY FIVE
THAT'S FOUR FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS IS A
LEASE CONTRACT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT
OF THE DELL. THANK YOU. TEXAS
MY NUMBER FIFTY THAT'S FIVE
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS ALEXIS
CHAVEZ THE CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
WASTE AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. BUT A LINE
NUMBER SIXTY NINE THAT'S SIX
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS
CATHERINE DIED WITH THE
ALLIANCE THE NURSES FOR HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENTS AND WE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. BY NUMBER FORTY TWO
FOR TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S
STEVEN ROSENBLUM REPRESENT THE
THREE FIFTY SILICON VALLEY IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. TWO EIGHTY
FOUR. THANK YOU. BY NUMBER
SEVENTY FOUR SEVEN FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. TINA GALLAGHER
FOR THREE FIFTY SACRAMENTO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND FINALLY
INTO HEADLINE NUMBER FORTY FOUR
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND
THEY REMOVE THEMSELVES FROM THE
QUEUE WE HAVE DEPLETED THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. OKAY
THANKS- SEVEN SEEING NO OTHERS
IN SUPPORT WILL TURN OUT TO
OPPOSITION. I THINK OUR LEAD
OPPOSITION IS TAYLOR OCEAN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA FARM YOU'RE ON
THE LINE AND THEN I THINK WE'VE
LEAVE SILVERTHORNE HERE AT CAL
CHAMBER IN PERSON- SO LET'S GO
TO LINES FIRST AND THEN. WE'LL
COME TO IN PERSON. THIS
ACTUALLY I'M GONNA GO FOR HOPE
SORRY AS YOU WISH MISS
SILVERTHORNE PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AS A MEMORY VESSEL YES
OVER THERE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. WE DO
APPRECIATE THE INTENT OF THE
AUTHOR TO MOVE FOR THIS
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION OF THE
RULE CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURAL
NATURAL AND WORKING LANDS
SECTOR CAN PLAY IN ADDRESSING
CLIMATE CRISIS. CALCHAMBER
DOESN FORTUNATELY REMAIN IT
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION.
WE ARE CONCERNED THAT THE BILL
SEEKS TO IMPOSE CARBON GOALS ON
ONE ECONOMIC SECTOR BEFORE AT
CLOCK CARBON NEUTRALITY ANOTHER
POST TWENTY THIRTY GOALS ARE
EVALUATED BY THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD. THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE
SEEK ARE THOSE THAT WILL HELP
TO ENSURE REGULATIONS CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED IN A MANNER THAT
DOESN'T DISRUPT. THE
AGRICULTURAL SECTOR IMPORTANTLY
THE BUILD IS NOT SIMPLY SAY
CARGO EVALUATE A GOAL TO MEET
CLIMATE NEUTRALITY INSTEAD THE
BILL SAYS QUOTE IDENTIFY AT
TWENTY FORTY FIVE CLIMATE GOAL
WITH INTERIM MILESTONES. FOR
THE STATE'S NATURAL WORKING
LANDS TO SEQUESTER CARBON TO
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
AND AT THE END OF THE QUOTE.
THAT GOAL IN TURN HAS TO
FURTHERBUT IS NOT CONSTRAINED
BY ANY CLIMATE NEUTRALITY OTHER
EXISTING CLIMATE CARBON GOALS.
ALTHOUGH IT IS DIRECTED TO BE
DONE IN THE CONTEXT OF THE NEXT
COPING PLANNED THIS LANGUAGE IS
UNCONSTRAINED AND CAN BE
INTERPRETED AS GIVING A R. B.
BROAD AUTHORITY TO IMPOSE
EMISSIONS CAPS ON THE
AGRICULTURAL SECTOR. INCLUDING
POTENTIALLY PULLING THE NATURAL
WORKING IN SECTORS INSIDE THE
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM OR
CREATING A DIRECT EMISSIONS
REDUCTION REQUIREMENT WITHOUT
THE CAP AND TRADE PROTECTIONS.
BECAUSE OF THE CONCERNS
REGARDING THIS BROAD
INTERPRETATION THE AMENDMENTS
THAT MY COLLEAGUE AT THE FARM
BUREAU OUTLINE. ARE NECESSARY
TO ALLEVIATE THE VAGUENESS IN
THE BILL ENSURE NO ALTERATION
OF CARDS AT THE READY OVER THE
AGRICULTURAL SECTOR AND AN
INTENT THAT HAS BEEN EXPRESSED
BY THE AUTHOR. SO FOR THESE
REASONS WE REMAIN OPPOSED UNTIL
THESE MINOR AMENDMENTS ARE
TAKEN AND DO LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS. WITH THE
AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR RETURN- NOW TURN
THE LAW. FOR TAYLOR ROSHEN
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU. A GOOD
MORNING MISTER TURNER MEMBERS
TAYLOR RICHMOND CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU WE ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
OUR COLLEAGUE LENA FROM
CALCHAMBER ON BEHALF OF A
COALITION OF ACTING BUSINESS
LEADERS AS OPPOSED WITH AMENDED
CONCESSION- ARE REQUESTING AN
OFFICIAL CLOVER REFLECTS WHAT
WE UNDERSTAND ANY MYSTERY THIS
IS ATTEMPT- SO THEIR FIRST
ISSUE IS BAD TWO EIGHTY FOUR
FAILED TO DIRECT CARD TO FRAME
A GOAL SETTING ACTION AND
WHAT'S- ECONOMICALLY AND
TECHNOLOGICALLY FEASIBLE FOR
NATURAL LOOKING LAND. YOUR
OFFER TO EVERY OTHER SECTOR OF
OUR ECONOMY WHEN CRAFTING
COMICAL TO RESPECTFULLY WE FEEL
THIS IS A PRETTY FAIR REQUEST-
ADDITIONALLY WE ASKED THAT THE
BILL DIRECT CARB TO DEVELOP
CLIMATE GOALS BASED ON THEIR
EXISTING AUTHORITY. WHICH IS
INTENDED ACTION. THIS IS
GROUNDED IN EXISTING LAW IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE COMMITMENT
OF THIS ADMINISTRATION THE
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION. AND
WITH MYSTERY FOR COMMENT TODAY
ABOUT THE NATURE OF THE SCOPING
PLAN SOMEWHERE BUT I'M CLEAR
WHY THIS REQUEST CAN BE
MANAGED. BOTH OF THESE ITEMS
WERE CALCULATED SB TWENTY SEVEN
A BILL THAT THIS COMMITTEE
PASSED LAST YEAR- YOU KNOW
GENERALLY SPEAKING THE FEMALE
ASKS BUT THEY'RE REALLY
CRITICAL FOR AN AG COMMUNITY IN
CRISIS WE NEED TO TRANSITION.
CLIMATE RESILIENCY AS AN
OPPORTUNITY NOT A REGULATORY
BARRIER AND THAT'S DONE BY
ACCOMPLISHING IT THROUGH
SOLICITING BY AND FROM THOSE
WHO ACTUALLY HAVE TO DO THE
WORK- SO YOU KNOW WE DON'T
WE'RE ASKING FOR COMMUNITY WITH
THESE AMENDMENTS NETWORKING AND
CLIMATE GOALS SHOULD BE BOLD-
BUT THEY SHOULD ALSO BE
PRACTICAL. IN ORDER TO BE
SUSTAINABLE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR THE FEEDBACK-
WE'LL TURN NOW TO A GENERAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM WHICH IS
TESTIFYING. SEEING NONE IN OUR
AUXILIARY ROOM NONE OF THIS
TREND LINES OPERATOR ANYONE
WISHING TESTIFY NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL. FEDERALIST TURNED LINES
IF WE CAN. MY APOLOGIES I WAS
MUTED SORRY. SEVENTY ONE SEVEN
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING DENNIS I'LL BE ON THE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
GRAIN FEED ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA C. DISSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA- GROWERS AND- EGG
FARMERS WE ALIGN OUR COMMENTS
WITH THE CHAMBER AND WITH THE
FARM BUREAU AND APPRECIATE THAT
THE- FACT THAT OF THE AUTHOR
BUT ARE STILL OPPOSED TO THIS
TIME. HIS NAME IN THAT POSITION
AND AFFILIATION THANK YOU SO
MUCH- IN NEXT WITNESS WE'LL GO
TO LINE. THE LINE NUMBER SIXTY
THREE THAT SIX THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING REBECCA
ABOUT THE END OF THE HALF OF
THE AMERICAN TO TAX YOUR
GRAMMAR CALIFORNIA KIND
GENEROUS AND GROWERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA AFFECTS
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION AND
WESTERN AGRICULTURAL PROCESSORS
ASSOCIATION WITH AND- NOT A
MINUTE TO DISTANT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. A LINE NUMBER
SEVENTY TWO THAT SEVEN TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TRICIA
GERINGER WITH AGRICULTURAL
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA. SO
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT. MISTER CHAIR AT THIS TIME
WE HAVE DEPLETED THE QUEUE OF
OPPOSITION. MR ISN'T KNOWN LEFT
IN Q. OKAY VERY GOOD- ONE IS
NOT VERY GOOD WE'LL BRING BACK
TO THE DICE THEN SENT A LETTER-
FIVE THE- MYSTERY OF A SIDE
PROJECT BILL AND SORT OF WAS
INVOLVED. ON BEHALF OF THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION IN
SETTING NATURAL AND WORKING
LANDS AS A GOAL WITHIN THE
CLIMATE PROGRAM THE HARDEST
THING. WAS TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
MEASURE ANY BENEFIT AND WHEN
YOU DEAL WITH THE SCOPE AND
PLAN YOUR TRYING TO TIE
SPECIFIC MEASURES TO LESS
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND-
AND WHEN WE DEVELOPED THE SOLE
PROGRAM THE STATE DOES LAND
CONSERVATION ON AGRICULTURAL
LANDS WE REALLY HAD TO SPARK TO
FIGURE OUT. HOW YOU MEASURED
AND I WONDERED IF YOU COULD
SPEAK TO. I WAS GOING TO ASK
YOU WHAT DIFFERENT STRATEGIES
YOU CONTEMPLATED TO MEET THIS
GOAL ONE OF YOUR WITNESSES SORT
OF LISTED A LOT OF THINGS IF
THOSE THINGS ARE PART OF WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO HOW DO YOU
PROPOSE TO MEASURE THEM AGAINST
WHAT THE SCOPING PLAN WILL
REQUIRE. RIGHT THAT'S A THAT'S
A GREAT QUESTION YOU KNOW I
THINK THAT YOU KNOW STATE
AGENCIES IS AS YOU MENTIONED MR
SENATOR HATCH- THEY HAVE
DISCUSSED THE ROLE OF NATURAL
GLASS FOR OVER TEN YEARS- AND-
YOU KNOW SECTOR STILL HAS BEEN
FULLY INTEGRATED INTO PASCHAL
IMPLANTS- AND OTHER. STATE
EFFORTS AND SO CERTAINLY OUR
GOAL HERE IS- YOU KNOW ALTHOUGH
A. R. B. AS ALREADY STATED
THEIR INTENT TO MAKE THIS A
PART OF THE NECTAR SKULKING
PLANT WE BELIEVE THAT STATUTORY
GUIDANCE IS NEEDED AND THEN YOU
KNOW I THINK THAT. WHAT'S
DIFFERENT ABOUT THIS BUILDING-
THE PREVIOUS EFFORTS AND SOME
OF THE BILL WE HAD LAST YEAR
IS. IN THIS BILL. YOU KNOW IT
GOES A STEP FURTHER BY BY. BY
CALLING ON THE A. R. B. TO
ENSURE THAT THEY ARE PROVIDING
THESE THESE THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR SOME
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
LANDOWNERS- AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT- INTEND TO YOU
KNOW AND- MAKE. THE YOU KNOW
THE IMPLEMENTATION AND
INCENTIVES OF ACTIVITIES THAT
COULD. POTENTIALLY SEQUESTER
CARBON IN THE SECOND PART OF
THAT IS THE BILL CALLS ON THE
A. R. B. TO WORK WITH.
STAKEHOLDERS WITH PARTNERS. TO
DEVELOP STANDARDS AND METHODS
FOR STATE AGENCIES TO TRACK.
THESE GHG EMISSION REDUCTIONS-
AND INDIA CERTAINLY WHETHER
IT'S RELATED YOU KNOW THE
SEQUESTRATION- SO YOU WOULD
DEPEND ON THE A. R. B. TO BE
THE ONE TO DEVELOP THE WAYS TO
MEASURE THE SIZZLE THE NOT
NECESSARILY ARE BASICALLY THE
COORDINATING AGENCY IN THIS
EFFORT- BUT CERTAINLY IT'S
LOOKING TO. OTHER STATE
AGENCIES TO THE RELEVANT STATE
AGENCIES- THAT WORK IN THIS
SPACE ARE BRINGING THESE
EXPERTS ARE IN THE SAME ROOM
AND HAVING THESE DISCUSSIONS IS
CERTAINLY REACHING A POINT
WHERE. WE HAVE THESE MEASURABLE
GOALS IN PLACE. OKAY THE I JUST
FOUND THAT. THE RBA DIDN'T
ALWAYS LISTEN TO THE OTHER
PEOPLE IN THOSE ROOMS WHEN THAT
HAPPENED- BUT- BUT WHAT LET ME-
IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE- I WAS
AROUND MAYBE WAIT TILL YOU'RE
CLOSE BUT LET ME ASK ABOUT SOME
OF THE AGRICULTURAL CONCERNS
BECAUSE IN THE- IN THE PACKET
THEY TALKED ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THIS WOULDN'T TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
THE IMPACT FROM DROUGHTS.
WHETHER MARKETS ARE PASSED AND-
IF FOR EXAMPLE THE LAND
CONSERVATION TO PROTECT I
GLANCE IS ONE OF THE
STRATEGIES. THAT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY GET INTERRUPTED BY
DROUGHT WEATHER MARKETER PASS
THEN ONE OF THE WITNESSES SAID
THEY WERE WORRIED THAT THIS WAS
AN ADMISSIONS EMISSIONS CAP ON
THE AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY. THE
THAT WAS THE FIRST TIME I'D
HEARD THAT. HOW WOULD YOU
RESPOND TO THAT IN TERMS OF. OF
WANTING TO MOVE AHEAD WITH YOUR
BILL WHY IS THAT TRUE OR NOT
TRUE FOR YOU. WELL YOU KNOW THE
BILL DOESN'T SPECIFY THAT WE
INTEND TO IMPOSE EMISSION CAPS
ON ON ON AGRICULTURE IT'S NOT
MY INTENT- YOU KNOW CERTAINLY I
APPRECIATE- THE STATEMENTS-
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED. OR THAT
WERE MADE BY OPPOSITION WHO'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THEM EVERY
STEP O THE WAY- AND YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY I THINK. WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE ANALYSIS- AND-
THEIR CONCERNS ONE OF THE
STATEMENTS THAT I AGREE WITH
THIS IS THAT YOU KNOW- ME
AROUND NATIONAL WORKING LANDS
THAT. THEY DO NOT HAVE A
FINANCIAL RETURN BUT RATHER
REQUIRE A FINANCIAL INVESTMENT
BY THE LANDOWNER WOULD TRY TO
CHANGE THAT EXACTLY WHY WE'RE
DOING THIS. IS TO GENERATE- YOU
KNOW- USE BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER
AND TO IDENTIFY- OPTIONS
POTENTIAL INCENTIVES SOME-
SOME- SOME REQUIRED- SOME
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE BUT TO DO
WHAT WE CAN. TO ADDRESS THIS
EMERGING CLIMATE CRISIS- YOU
KNOW THERE'S A HE WE CAN'T TALK
ABOUT BECAUSE- YOU KNOW-
REGIONAL CLIMATE GOALS ABOUT.
ONE DAY BEING- CARBON NEUTRAL
OR- WE ARE WITHOUT NATURAL
WORKING LANDS IN A PART OF THAT
SOLUTION AND SO IT'S DOING OUR
PART TO LEVERAGE EVERY POSSIBLE
OPTION WE HAVE. TO INSURE THAT
WE ARE DOING WHAT WE CAN. TO
YOU KNOW. RIGHT A DIFFERENT
NARRATIVE AROUND THIS CLIMATE
CRISIS IT REALLY IS- YOU KNOW I
ENCOURAGE I'D BUY. APPRECIATE
THEIR COMMENTS BUT CERTAINLY
MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE. TO
FOSTER A COLLABORATIVE WORKING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AND IN THIS CASE
IS AGRICULTURE- THAT WE ALL
NEED TO DO MORE. TO SHORTEN
THAT- WHERE- YOU KNOW THAT WE
ENSURE THAT AGRICULTURE REMAINS
PRODUCTIVE. THAT'S FULL IN THE
STATE. BUT THAT'S NOT GONNA
HAPPEN IN THE CURRENT TRACK
THAT WE ARE ON. I. THINK YOU
KNOW. OR ARE WE IN THE LEAD.
KNOWS ONE OF THE- WE CO AUTHORS
OF A B. THIRTY TWO AND THE
GENIUS OF HOW THAT BILL WAS
NEGOTIATED. IS THAT IT GAVE
AUTHORITY TO THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD AND IT GAVE MONEY OR THE
ABILITY TO RAISE MONEY TO THE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD. BUT IT
DIDN'T LITIGATE EACH INDIVIDUAL
ITEM IN THE BILL SO IT WAS
DECIDED THAT. IT WOULD BE IN
THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR OR
DIFFERENT THINGS IT WOULD BE
WITHIN THE AUTHORITY OF THE
MONEY. AND THEY ARE BASED TO DO
IT. R. AND THAT WAY WE COULD
pPUT THE DEADLINES IN THE
FORTIES AND THE MONEY IN IT
RATHER THAN LITIGATE FORTY TWO
INDIVIDUAL ISSUES THAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN REALLY HARD. AND SO
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT YOUR
STRUCTURE IS VERY SIMILAR.
BECAUSE YOU ARE TRYING TO SET
THE GOAL AND- EVEN THOUGH
THEY'RE STILL I THINK SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT MEASURING IT-
AND YET THAT MEANS YOU HAVE TO
GIVE SOME ASSURANCE TO THE AG
INDUSTRY THAT STRUCTURE THAT
IT'S NOT THE END OF THE WORLD
FOR THEM. AND WITH IN SETTING
THE GOAL AND WITH AN
EMPOWERING- AGENCIES OR PEOPLE
TO MEET THE GOAL SEEMS TO ME
THAT THAT YOUR POLITICAL
CHALLENGE HERE IT IS YES BAG
HAS TO BE PART OF THE SOLUTION.
BY- YOU KNOW THEY HAVE THE
NATURAL CONCERN THAT. THAT JUST
THINGS ARE GONNA HAPPEN THAT
GET IN THE WAY OF THEIR OWN
BUSINESS AND SO. I SUPPORT THIS
BECAUSE WE SHOULD HAVE THIS AND
I THINK THAT WE STILL NEED TO
DECIDE SOME OF THE STRATEGIES
AND SOME OF THE MEASUREMENTS
BUT- I THINK THE CHALLENGES IS
MAKING SURE AGRICULTURE
UNDERSTANDS THERE'S A WAY THEY
CAN BE PART OF THE SOLUTION AND
IT'S NOT THE END OF THE WORLD
TO THEM SO. IN ANY EVENT SORRY
I DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT IT ABOUT-
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL I
HOPE YOU JUST CONTINUE TO WORK
ON SOME OF THOSE ISSUES WE WILL
DO WHAT WE CAN. VERY GOOD THANK
YOU FOR THE INSIGHT. CENTER
LAYERED ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. I
MAKE A QUICK COMMENT- SHE YOU
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE. ON
THIS MEASURE AND FOR YOUR-
DOGGEDNESS ON THIS ISSUE.
SESSION AFTER SESSION- NOT
GIVING UP ON TRYING TO UP LIT.
NATURAL WORKING LANDS WE SPEND
MOST THE DISCUSSION ON
AGRICULTURE ISSUES. BUT I THINK
IT'S WORTH NOTING THAT THIS THE
BILLS EVEN BROADER THAN THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT. ALL THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CARBON SINKS-
IN CALIFORNIA AND LIMITING
SOURCES- IN OUR FORESTS- IN
OTHER HABITATS IN OTHER.
REGIONS AND WHAT I WOULD JUST
SAY IS. TO SETTLERS POINT. I
THINK IT'S SMART ABOUT THIS
FRAMEWORK IS YOU'RE NOT. YOU'RE
NOT PLUCKING AN ARBITRARY GOAL
OUT. JUST FOR THIS SECTOR.
YOU'RE GIVING DISCRETION ON
THOSE TARGETS AND EXACTLY WHAT
GOALS WERE GONNA SET. WITHIN
NATURAL WORKING LANDS. AND SOME
OF THE AMENDMENTS THAT. THAT
BEING ADDED FOR INSTANCE
MENTIONED THINGS LIKE-
BIODIVERSITY SO YOU'RE NOT JUST.
HUNTING FOR CARBON BLINDLY- AND
THEN YOU'RE STILL AWARE OF SORT
OF OTHER OTHER GOALS IN MIND-
YOUR YOU WERE STILL STAYING
AWARE OF- THE PURPOSES OF THESE
LANDS TO GROW FOOD. SO IT'S NOT
JUST A SORT OF A BLIND MISSION
ON CARBON- OVER EVERYTHING ELSE
BUT IT'S INTEGRATED WITHIN THAT
BROADER CONTEXT WHICH I HOPE
RING SOME COMFORT AND A SENSE
OF BALANCE ALTHOUGH I REALIZE.
A LOT OF THIS WILL SHAKE OUT
THE REGULATORY PROCESS AND- I
FRANKLY THINK IT'S TOO MUCH FOR
US TO TRY TO SOLVE ALL THAT
HERE ALSO WHICH IS GOING TO ADD
ONE MORE POINT WHICH IS TO THE
TO THE CONCERNS RAISED ABOUT
MEASUREMENT I THINK SOME OF
THOSE AMENDMENTS. WE ADDED
BRINGING IN CDFA AND C. N. R.
AB THE NATURIST HERS AGENCY
INTO THE CONSULTATION PROCESS
AND HAVING THEM BRING THAT
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE SO IT'S NOT
JUST AIRBOARD MATH. BUT IT'S
REALLY BEING DRIVEN BY CDFA AND
SCENERY HOPEFULLY WILL ADD-
SOME MORE- FIRMNESS TO
EXPECTATIONS HERE SO I THINK
THIS IS THE YEAR TO GET IT DONE
AND I THINK IT IT TRULY MAKES
SENSE. IN A MUCH BROADER
CONTEXT WE'RE ACTUALLY GOING TO
PUSH BEYOND IN LOOKING AT THE
GOVERNOR'S RECOMMENDATIONS ON
LOOKING AT CARBON NEUTRALITY BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE- THE
GOVERNOR PUT THAT OUT THERE ON
FRIDAY. I THINK THE AIRPORT'S
GONNA BE TRYING TO COME UP WITH
SOMETHING AMBITIOUS IN THIS
SCOPING PLAN AND I THINK THIS
IS GOING TO BE A CRITICAL PIECE
OF THE EQUATION SO. I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE MEASURE
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON IF
THEREARE NO OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS- SLIGHTLY CLOSER. BUT
THAT'S WHAT I. THOUGHT OKAY
VERY GOOD- FOR ME MAKE SURE WE
GET MOTION- I ACTUALLY. I WOULD
ENTERTAIN A MOTION FIRST.
PAYMENT CENTER ADMIN SO MOVED-
THE MOTION. DO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST A MEN IN RE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SHOULD CONSULT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FOLLOWED
HIM FOR A B. TWO EIGHT FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS STERN. STERN ALL
RIGHT JONES. JONES NOEL ALLEN.
ALLEN ALL RIGHT EGGMAN. EGGMAN
ALL RIGHT GROOVE HEARD'S
BURGER. BOYS SO LAYERED HI
LIZARD ISLAND LOAN. OKAY THAT
MEASURES FOUR VOTES WE WILL
LEAVE IT ON CALL FOR THE ABS
AND MEMBERS- AMERICA YOUR
CAREER I KEEP LOOKING TO BUT-
SOME AREN'T WE'RE GONNA STAY
FILE ORDER WITH ALL THE DUE
RESPECT AT. SUMMER GALLAGHER
YOU WANNA COME UP YOUR FILE
ITEM FIVE EIGHTY THREE SEVENTY
NINE. WELCOME. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN. SENATORS GLAD TO
PRESENT THIS MORNING IN EIGHTY
THREE SEVENTY NINE- EIGHTY
THREE SEVENTY NINE WOULD
CORRECT AN OVERSIGHT IN THE
CALIFORNIA CODE THAT PREVENTS
THEACQUISITION OF CONSERVATION
LANDS BY CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBES. UNDER CURRENT
LAW STATE AGENCY MAY ONLY SELL
OR DEED CONSERVATION LANDS TO
PUBLIC AGENCIES OR NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS BUT NOT TO NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBS- THIS WOULD
SEEM TO BE- YEAH PRETTY
UNREASONABLE OVERSIGHT
CONSIDERING THAT ARE NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBES ARE- THE
ORIGINAL STEWARDS. OF OUR
LANDS- THIS CAME TO MY
ATTENTION IS- THE MID SHIP TO
TRIBE IN MY DAY IN MY DISTRICT
WHO HAS ANCESTRAL LANDS. AROUND
THE CHICO- AREA. SOUGHT TO.
WIRE AN EASEMENT THAT IS
OPERATED BY A CHICO STATE
FOUNDATION ON RIGHT PARIAN
CORRIDOR- AND IN IN IN GOING
THROUGH THAT PROCESS FOUND THAT
UNDER THE CURRENT RULES IN THE
IN LAW WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
TAKE OVER- THAT CONSERVATION.
EASEMENT SO THROUGH THIS BILL
WE SEEK TO REMEDY THAT AND
ALLOW FOR TRIBES TO- OBVIOUSLY
TAKE PART IN CONSERVATION
PRACTICES AND ALSO OTHER-
PRACTICES THROUGH THE RESOURCE
AGENCIES- THAT PROVIDE FOR
CONSERVATION OF LANDS THIS
BILLS HAD UNANIMOUS SUPPORT.
THROUGH ITS THROUGH HIS JOURNEY
AND I AM JOINED TODAY BY VICE
CHAIR SANDRA KNIGHT OF THE
METRIC TO TRIBE- AND SAM
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE SANTA
YNEZ BAND OF CHUMASH INDIANS.
THANK YOU SIR MEMBER- WE WILL
TURN IT TO OUR FIRST LEAD
WITNESS- IS IT VICE CHAIR NIGHT.
WELCOME TO THANK YOU FOR
HONORING AS HE PRESENTS IN
MORNING THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO BE HERE THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMAN GALLAGHER SO MUCH
FOR HIM SPONSORING THIS BILL-
IT MEANS A LOT TO OUR TRIBE SO
I AM THE VICE CHAIR OF THE
MACHINE IN A TRACT THE BEEN THE
VICE CHAIR FOR OVER TWENTY
YEARS WHICH IS SEEMS VERY CRAZY
BUT- ABSOLUTELY THIS CODE WILL
RIGHT A WRONG FOR CALIFORNIA
TRIBES- IT'S JUST A CORRECTION
PERIOD- AS ASSEMBLYMAN SAID
THAT THIS LAW CURRENTLY LEADS
OUT PREVENTS TRIBES FROM.
PARTICIPATING IN. ACCEPTING
LAND FOR WILDLIFE AND
CONSERVATION AND FOR ANY
PROGRAMS FOR GRANT PROGRAMS
UNDER THE WILDLIFE CONSERVATION
BOARD. SO WE DON'T WHAT TYPES
ARE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN ANY
PROGRAM FOR THE STATE AGENCY-
IT IS. ONLY A CORRECTION. IT IS
A NECESSARY CODE THAT WILL
INCLUDE TRIBES CALIFORNIA
TRIBES HAVE BEEN LEADERS IN
ENVIRONMENTAL CONSERVATION
RESOURCES MANAGEMENT THROUGH
OUR OUR HISTORIES. WE ARE THE
FIRST LANCE TOURS AND HAVE
WORKED TIRELESSLY TO PROVE TO
PROTECT SALMON PRACTICE
TRADITIONAL BURNING PROVIDE
CULTURE RESOURCE PROTECTION AND
ENVIRONMENTAL RESTORATION. THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS MAKE
MADE GREAT PROGRESS TECHNOLOGY
STARKEL VIOLENCE EXPLOITATION
DISPOSITION AND ATTEMPTED
DESTRUCTION OF TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES AND DISLOCATED
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICANS
FROM ANCESTRAL LAND AND SACRED
PRACTICES TODAY WE SEE MANY
EXAMPLES OF TRIBES. AND THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA PARTNERING
ON IMPORTANT PROJECTS SUCH AS
RIVER RESTORATION PROJECTS
WATERSHED RESTORATION PROJECTS
ALL TO SAVE CRITICAL WILDLIFE
HABITAT. THE POOL OF EIGHTY
THREE SEVENTY NINE IS THE RIGHT
DECISION FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND CALIFORNIA
NATIVE TRIBES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MA'AM VICE CHAIR-
NEXT UP I THINK WE'VE SAM COHN
FROM SENDING AS JEWISH. WELCOME
MR COHN. THANK YOU SURE STERN
I'M SAM CALLING ON THE
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS AND LEGAL
OFFICER FOR THE SANTA YNEZ BAND
OF CHUMASH INDIANS I'M A
CORPORATE LAWYER I'M A TAX
LAWYER AND I'VE BEEN A TRIBAL
ATTORNEY SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
SIX SO I'M A PRETTY WEIRD DUCK
MOST OF THE TIME I JUST WANT TO
MAKE FIVE POINTS- THE CURRENT
LAW. IT WOULD ALLOW THE WILDER
WRITTEN BY LIFE CONSERVATION
BOARD TO APPROVE THE TRANSFER
TO ANY LOCAL GOVERNMENT OR ANY
NON PROFIT ORGANIZATION. THE
SECOND POINT IS THE TRIBE COULD
JUST ESTABLISH A NON PROFIT
ORGANIZATION. ALL RIGHT A TWO
MATCH WE HAVE THREE. RIGHT I
EVEN LOAN ONE TO MID SHIP DUCK
FAT LIKE AND ONCE THE NONPROFIT
TOOK TITLE TO THE LAND THEY
COULD RE TRANSFERRED TO THE
TRIBE. ALL RIGHT AND WE
WOULDN'T HAVE AN ISSUE. THE
THIRD S EVERYONE EXPECTS THE
WILDERNESS CONSERVATION BOARD
TO PUT. CONDITIONS ON THIS
TRANSFER BUT CURRENTLY THEY
CAN'T EVEN CONSIDER IT. YOU
KNOW WE WOULD EXPECT
CONSERVATION EASEMENTS WE WOULD
RESPECT EXPECT DEED
RESTRICTIONS WE COULD EVEN
EXPECT REVERSIONARY
CONTINGENCIES IF THE LAND IS
NOT USED AS IT WAS PROPOSED.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
WILLIAMSON ACT HERE FOR THE
LAST HOUR. I TRIED TO TAKE THE
LAND INTO TRUST SUBJECT TO
WILLIAMSON AXE CONSERVATION
EASEMENTS ALL THE TIME. RIGHT
THE FOURTH POINT I WANT TO MAKE
IS ABOUT THE FEE TO TRUST
PROCESS. YOU KNOW YOU ALL ARE
FAMILIAR WITH LASKO ANNEXATIONS
WHERE CITIES ANNEX LAND FROM
COUNTIES. WHAT ABOUT TRIBAL
ANNEXATION PROCESS IS CALLED
FOR YOU TO TRUST. ME TO TRUST
TAKES THE LAND SUBJECT TO ALL.
MY INCOME PRINCES OF RECORD. SO
IF THE WIND WILL BLOW THE W. C.
B. FILES A CONSERVATION
EASEMENT THE TRIBE MUST HONOR
THE CONSERVATION EASEMENT EVEN
IF THE LAND GOES INTO A TRUST.
AND THEN FIFTH WORK I'M HAPPY
TO WORK WITH YOUR STAFF AND THE
WILDERNESS CONSERVATION BOARD
ON ANY LANGUAGE. THAT YOU THINK
MIGHT BE APPROPRIATE. HERE WE
HAVE A UNIVERSITY AND A TRIBE
THAT WANT TO WORK TOGETHER THEY
NEED YOUR HELP TO MEND THE FISH
AND WILDLIFE CODE TO ALLOW THE
W. C. B. TO APPROVE. THE
TRANSFER OF CONSERVATION LAND
AMENDING THE FISH WILDLIFE CODE
WILL ALLOW THE WILDERNESS
CONSERVATION BOARD TO APPROVE.
THE TRANSFER WITH APPROPRIATE
CAN ADDITIONS TO MAINTAIN THE
LAND AS CON. LAND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR THAT
VERY INSIGHTFUL OPENING REMARKS
TO VERY HELPFUL- WE'LL GO TO A
GENERAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
NOW. ANY IN OUR HEARING ROOM
SEEING ONE. WELCOME VISITOR
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE FRANK
MOVING ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
MANUEL BAND OF MISSION INDIANS
IN THE SENATE IS MANISHA
MISSION ISN'T STRONG SUPPORT
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH
I'VE SEEN NO OTHERS HEARING
SUPPORT ANY IN UR- AUXILIARY
ROOM SEEING NONE WILL TURN TO
THE LINES. DO YOU WANT TO CHECK
THE LINES FOR ANYONE WOULD
WISHING TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF
A. B. THREE SEVEN NINE. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB THREE SEVEN NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE WILL START WITH
LINE NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN THAT'S
FIVE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING NATALIE MAX MUMBY
HAPPENED MID TEMPO REGIONAL TO
FACE DISTRICT THE COURT. THANK
YOU. GROWING NUMBER EIGHTY ONE
AT EIGHT ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI TO BE MOCKED ON BEHALF OF
COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY
FARMERS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANKS. MY NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN
THAT'S THREE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE THIRTY SEVEN YOU MAY
HAVE SELF MUTED. TO CARRY
BRIDAL DESCENDED COUNTY
WILDLIFE FEDERATION AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MR KERRY HOW HAVE
EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME VERY GOOD OKAY THAT MEANS
WE'LL TURN INTO ANY WITNESSES
WISHING TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
WE DON'T HAVE ANY LIST ON FILE
BUT ANY WISHING TESTIFIED IN
THE HEARING ROOM NONE.
AUXILIARY ROOM SEEING NONE WILL
TURN THE LINES BRIEFLY ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB. THREE SEVEN
NINE. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO A. B. THREE
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIR THERE'S NO ONE SHOWING UP
IN OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME.
OKAY VERY GOOD- WILL BRING THE
MEASURE BACK TO THE DIES THEN-
GO TO CENTER LAYERED. MMHM IT
THEN LET ME ASK A QUESTION
FIRST MAYBE OF THE CHAIR OR
THEIR AMENDMENTS TAKEN. IN THIS
COMMITTEE ALREADY THOUGH- WHAT
WHAT WE'RE GONNA BE DOING TODAY
WE'RE GONNA BE AMENDING THE
BILL- SO THERE THERE AREN'T ANY
AMENDMENTS YET TAKEN BUT THERE
WILL BE AMENDMENTS TODAY AND
YOU SHOULD HAVE IN YOUR- IN A
PRINTER OUT. THERE- DENNIS DO
THEY HAVE A- A COPY OKAY I'LL
READ IT THEN. IT IT BASICALLY
GOES TO THE SUPPORTS-
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THAT THERE'S NO
INTENT HERE TO OVER RIDE FOR
INSTANCE THE TERMS OF A
APPLICABLE CONSERVATION
EASEMENT OR UNDER ANY
UNDERLYING ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS
SO THAT. THE LANGUAGE WE
DISCUSS WITH THE AUTHORS TO
AMEND A B. THREE SEVENTY NINE
TO INSURE. THAT TRANSFERRED
CONSERVATION LANDS- AS
DESCRIBED IN IN THE LEGISLATION
THE SITE IS FIFTEEN NINETY SIX
POINT FIVE ONE SIXTY THREE. ARE
MANAGED FOR THE PURPOSES FOR
WHICH THE LAND WAS TRANSFERRED.
AND CONTINUE TO BE SUBJECT TO
APPLICABLE ENVIRONMENTAL AND%
LAND USE LAWS AND REGULATIONS.
OR OTHERWISE SUBJECT TO THE
APPLICABLE CONSERVATION
EASEMENT- IF WE NEED TO MAKE
ANY FURTHER REFINEMENTS OR IF
YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS ON THAT
HAPPY TO TAKE HIM BUT THAT THAT
SEEM TO ADDRESS- THIS
OUTSTANDING CONCERN THAT
SOMEHOW. BY GOING FROM A FEE TO
TRUST YOU LOSE ALL THE ANY OF
THE SORT OF UNDERLYING TERMS
AND CONDITIONS OR SOMEHOW IF
YOU TRANSFERRED LAND UNDER
CONSERVATION EASEMENT THAT THAT
WOULD CERTAINLY BE. SWEPT AWAY
AND YOU COULD. DO A LARGE SCALE
RETAIL DEVELOPMENT WHERE IT
OTHERWISE IT'S JUST TO BE HAPPY
AS HABITAT IN THE IN THE IN THE
EXAMPLE THAT THE SUMMER GAVE
FOR IF THEY WERE OUTSTANDING
REQUIREMENTS TO- THE APPLE I
YOU KNOW- COASTAL. COASTAL ACT
APPLICATIONS FOR ENVIRONMENT
SENSE OF HABITAT OR- OR CLEANUP
PROVISIONS- THAT THOSE WOULDN'T
SUDDENLY BE SWEPT AWAY BY THAT
TRANSFERS SO WE'RE HOPING THAT
THAT LANGUAGE- THE- SORT OF FOR
A- OCT THIRTY. AN EVEN THOUGH
WE HEAR THE CLEAR INTENT OF THE
LAW I MEAN THE SPONSORS MAKE MY
COMMENTS YES SIR IS IT MIGHT.
ADDRESS THAT AND I THINK. OF
THE WITNESS SAID- THIS WAS ONLY
A CORRECTION. BUT IT'S A
MONUMENTAL CORRECTION BECAUSE
OF THE- RE DRESSES ARE AMAZING
GRIEVANCE. IN OUR HISTORY- AND
BECAUSE OF- LAND THAT WAS
REMOVED AND BEING ABLE TO
RETURN. TO OUR LAND AT SEA
OPTION BUT THE DIFFERENCE IS
THAT IT MIGHT BE A APPEAR TO BE
A MINOR CORRECTION. IT GOES TO
A SOVEREIGN NATION. ARE NONE OF
THE OTHER GRANTS GO TO
SOVEREIGN NATIONS AND SO THAT
SETS UP. A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT. SITUATION FOR. THE
TRANSFER AND THE ULTIMATE
MANAGEMENT AND- A WHAT I'M NOT
SURE ABOUT ABOUT THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE JUST. MENTIONED IS
THAT IN- WHEN LAND IS ACQUIRED.
BY THE WILDLIFE CONSERVATION
BOARD RATHER SHORT OR MAKE A
GRANT TO ACQUIRE TRANSFER
LANGUAGE. IT IS ALWAYS FOR
STATE PURPOSES IN THE STATE
PURPOSE IS THAT. IT BE FOR
EXAMPLE A WETLANDS WITH NO
DEVELOPMENT. AND YET IT MIGHT
NOT NECESSARILY HAVE A FULL
FLEDGED CONSERVATION EASEMENT
ON IT EVEN THOUGH IT WAS
ACQUIRED FOR THAT PURPOSE. AND
SO TO ME. WHAT THE AMENDMENTS
APPEAR TO DO ONE. IS THEY DO
THEIR BEST TO PROTECT MOST
SITUATIONS BUT THEY DO THEIR
BEST TO PROTECT WHERE THERE'S
ALREADY AN EASEMENT BERARDI
SOMETHING THERE AND YET IT
MIGHT HAVE BEEN PURCHASED WITH
THAT INFERENCE BUT THOUGHT.
THERE THEN SO IT IT SEEMS THAT.
THE BEST PROTECTION WOULD BE.
TO GUARANTEE THE TRAIN LINE.
THAT AIR MISTER COLLAGEN OUR
GAVE GOOD COMMENTS THESE ARE
CONSISTENT WITH HIS COMMENTS.
THAT IF THERE IS AN ISSUE ABOUT
PUTTING AN EASEMENT ON. FOR A
REVERSION OR OTHER THINGS TO
TEND TO BE PART OF THE TRANSFER
LANGUAGE AND THAT WAY YOU DON'T
RELY ON WHETHER THERE'S AN EVEN
APPLICATION OF WHETHER THERE
ARE CONSERVATION EASEMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN GIVEN. YOU'RE GETTING
THE PROTECTION IN THE LANGUAGE
IN THE TRANSFER IT AND SO FOR
ME. THAT WOULD BE THE IMPORTANT
THING TO HAVE IT IN THE
AMENDMENTS IS THAT WE JUST KNOW
THAT EVERY PARCEL THAT IS
TRANSFERRED IS GOING TO BE
CLEAR TO THE PURPOSES FOR WHICH
IT WAS DESIGNATED REQUIRED AND
THAT WAY. EVEN THOUGH- MAYBE
THE REST OF THESE AMENDMENTS
ARE FINE. YOU YOU'RE NOT
GETTING INTO AN ARGUMENT ABOUT
TRUST OR SOVEREIGNTY ATION
YOU'RE TRANSFERRING THE LANDS
WITH REQUIREMENTS ON IT THAT
WERE RELATED TO THE RECENT THAT
THE LAND WAS ACQUIRED IN THE
FIRST PLACE. AND IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT WOULD BE. THE BEST WAY TO
PROTECT AGAINST ANYTHING HERE
AND IT SOUNDS LIKE IT'S
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT MR KHAN
SAID YOU JUST PUT IT IN THE
AMENDMENT UP FRONT. AND YOU DO
THAT AND SO FOR ME THAT'S WHAT
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE AND THEN
YOU KNOW I'M COMFORTABLE
BECAUSE- TO BE HONEST AND IT
MIGHT BE A DICEY COMMENT TO
MAKE IT PUBLIC. THERE WAS A
SIMILAR. OUR THING DONE WITH
THE PUBLIC. COMMISSION AND P.
JEANNIE LANCE. AND IT BASICALLY
GIVES A FIRST RIGHT OF REFUSAL.
TO TRIBES AND IT GOT IN THE
MIDDLE OF SOME PROCESSES THAT
WERE ALREADY ADVANCED. AND IN A
WAY THAT. YOU WANT TO PROTECT
AGAINST DEVELOPMENT ON THOSE
PARCELS THAT ARE INVOLVED WITH
P. GENIE LAMP YOU WANT TO HONOR
THE ARCHAEOLOGICAL SITES THE
SACRED SITES IN THE HISTORIC
SITES AND ALLOW FOR MANAGEMENT
AND THOSE THINGS BROUGHT UP
AGAINST EACH OTHER AND WE HAVE
THE SAME PRINCIPLE HERE SO. A
HIGH WOULD SUPPORT. AN
AMENDMENT THAT'S THAT'S
INVOLVED IN THE TRANSFER AND
THEN YOU DON'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT THE SOVEREIGN NATION OR
THE TRUST YOU'RE JUST PUTTING
IT ON THE LAND AS SHE
TRANSFERRED AS A CONDITION SO.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE THAT IS IN
THE PROCESS OR WHETHER THAT'S
SOMETHING WE COULD
REALISTICALLY DO BUT- BUT I
THINK THAT WOULD ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE REALLY STRONG. IN AND MY
SUGGESTION THERE CERTAINLY ARE
THE LANGUAGE THAT THAT I READ.
THIS IS TO AMEND A B. THREE
SEVEN NINE TO INSURE
TRANSFERRED CONSERVATION LANDS.
ARE MANAGED FOR THE PURPOSES.
FOR WHICH THE LANDS WERE
TRANSFERRED. AND CONTINUED
SUBJECT TO APPLICABLE IN
ENVIRONMENTAL AND LAND USE LAWS
AND REGULATIONS. BUT RATHER
THAN SAYING SURE TRANSFERRED
CONSERVATION LANDS WE COULD
JUST CLARIFY I THINK THAT IT'S
IN THE TRANSFER OF THAT PLANT.
SO IT'S IT COULD BE IN THAT.
THAT THAT WOULD BE- RECOGNIZED
OR PROVIDED FOR IN THE TRANSFER
ITSELF THAT FEEDER TRUST
TRANSFER AND IT SEEMS THERE'S
SOME LANGUAGE HERE IT MIGHT
STILL NEED TO BE TWEAKED A
BECAUSE IT SAYS FOR THE
PURPOSES FOR WHICH THE LAND WAS
TRANSFERRED AND THAT'S RATHER
OPEN AHA I THINK IT'S FOR THE
PURPOSES FOR WHICH THE LAND WAS
ACQUIRED BEFORE TRANSFERRING
THAT. THAT MIGHT BE AN ISSUE.
HI R. E. THE CONSULTANT SET OFF
MARKET DEPENDS ON THE TYPE OF
PLANT AND I THINK THAT'S
CORRECT IN THE REAL PROBLEM IS
WE'RE TRYING TO DO BILL THE
REPLACED EVERYTHING HERE AND SO
HOW IN DOING THAT DO WE MAKE
SURE THERE'S NO INFECTION SO
FAR IN ANY EVENT- THE- WELCOME
ANSWER QUESTION WOULD YOU BE
COMFORTABLE WITH SUCH AN
AMENDMENT THAT SORT OF. TIES
THIS DOWN IN THE TRANSFER YES I
MEAN I'M AGREEABLE TO LANGUAGE
THAT HAS BEEN PROPOSED AND- IN
TALKING WITH THE CHAIRMAN I
THINK WE CAN WORK HASH OUT WHAT
THE EXACT LANGUAGE IS YOU GUYS
ARE JUST KIND OF TALKING ABOUT.
YOU KNOW SHOULD BE ACQUIRED I
THINK WE CAN WORK THAT OUT AND
FIGURE OUT WHAT THE EXACT
LANGUAGES BUT IN GENERAL WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO SAY HERE IN THE
INTENT IS. THAT WHATEVER THE
LAMB WAS ACQUIRED FOR THE
CONSERVATION PURPOSE AT THAT
WOULD CONTINUE- YOU KNOW AFTER
THE TRANSFER. IN THE END ANY
RESTRICTIONS THAT WOULD. YOU
KNOW PUT IN PLACE. BY THAT- ANY
APPLICABLE LAWS THAT WOULD BE-
THAT THAT LAND WOULD BE SUBJECT
TO WITHSTAND PLACE I THINK
THAT'S THE INTENT AND- I DON'T
THINK ANYBODY'S WANTING TO. YOU
KNOW MESSED WITH THAT ANYHOW I
THINK THAT'S A VERY GOOD
RESPONSE AMONG CLEAR ON THE
PROCESS BECAUSE WE'RE STILL
GOING TO REFINE THE AMENDMENTS
AFTER WE MOVE OUT OF THIS
HEARING. HOW DOES THAT HAPPEN
SO I THINK WE THE OTHER WILL
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENT TODAY WITH
THE UNDERSTANDING THAT- WE CAN.
REFINE THAT PROVISION IN
DRAFTING UP AROUND. ENSURING
THAT IT'S IN THE TRANSFER-
ITSELF AND THAT IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY JUST THE PURPOSES
FOR WHICHIT WAS TRANSFERRED
BUT ALSO- TO AND- WHICH WAS
ACQUIRED. AND I HAVE A FEELING
THE CONSULTANT WANTS TO CONSULT.
IN COLLABORATION WITH COMMITTEE
STAFF. OKAY THEN THAT SEEMS
LIKE A GOOD OUTCOME TO MAKE IT
BECAUSE YOU ARE FAVORABLE TO
DRESSING THAT WAY YOU'RE OPEN
TO ADDRESSING AT THAT POINT YET
AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF WILL BE
AT THE TABLE IF WE CAN DO THAT
WE COULD GET THERE OKAY OKAY I
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR WORKING
WITH US AND PROVIDING THAT
CLARITY AND THEN MAYBE ONE
THING BECAUSE WE PLUNGE
DIRECTLY INTO THE WEEDS- LET ME
JUST SAY AT THE HIGHER LEVELS
THIS IS A NOBLE PURPOSE. AND
THIS REALLY DOES A REDRESS
HISTORICAL GRIEVANCES IN A GOOD
WAY AND ALLOWS PEOPLE TO DO IT
AND I THINK ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES AND IT'S THE
CHALLENGE WE'RE FACING IN THE.
DIABLO CANYON LANDS AND OTHER
PLACES. THE IT ANSWER TRY. SOME
OF THEM THAT MR KHAN REPRESENTS
ARE PROBABLY MUCH MORE ADVANCED
BUT THEY'LL BE A CAPACITY
ISSUE. AND TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE HAVE THE CAPACITY
TO DO THE MANAGEMENT THE- WHAT.
I THINK WE SHOULD GIVE THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO REDRESS THE
HISTORIC AGREEMENT SO. AT THE
RIGHT TIME I WOULD MOVE
WHATEVER MOTION IS CONSISTENT
WITH THIS CONVERSATION. THANK
YOU FOR THAT WILL LET THE
CONSULTANT ITERATE THE MOTION-
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS HERE.
WE VERY GOOD THAT'S A- ETHEREAL
SECOND- DISSENT AROUND I'M JUST
GOING TO. THINK CENTRE LAYERED
AGAIN FOR- I I'VE DONE JUST
ABOUT SAYS IT MYSELF WITH THE
COMMENTS OF PHONES EARLIER IN
THE CHAIR I APPRECIATE THE WORK
THAT'S GONE ON TO GET THIS TO A
GOOD PLACE. FOR IT OKAY THANKS
FOR THAT- NO FURTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS LATER CLOSER THANK
YOU SENATOR AND I WOULD JUST
ASK FOR YOUR I. HAVE A OKAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH. MISTER CHAIR
I WOULD MOVE THE MOTION THAT-
CONSULTANTS ABOUT TO HELP MARK
VERY GOOD THAT'S A MOTION FROM
CENTER EARLIER. CHIEF
CONSULTANT OKAY. LET ME READ
THE AMENDMENT ONE MORE TIME
JUST TO MAKE SURE EVERYONE'S
CLEAR ON WHAT THE AMENDMENT IS.
AMANDA AB THREE SEVEN NINE TO
INSURE TRANSFERRED CONSERVATION
LANDS AS DESCRIBED IN SECTION
FIFTY NINE NINETY SIX POINT
FIVE ONE SIX. SUBSEA PARAGRAPH
THREE. ARE MANAGED FOR THE
PURPOSES FOR WHICH THE LAND WAS
PER. TRANSFERRED AND CONTINUE
TO BE SUBJECT TO APPLICABLE
ENVIRONMENTAL AND LAND USE LAWS
AND REGULATIONS. OR OTHERWISE
SUBJECT TO ANY APPLICABLE
CONSERVATION EASEMENT. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS- TO
APPROPRIATIONS STERN CAN'T JUST
BEFORE YOU DO THAT CAN I
CLARIFY THE MOTION I MADE YES-
AND THEY'LL BE CONTINUED WORK
ON REFINEMENT OF FAT THAT
INVOLVES THE CONSULTANT. THE
AUTHOR AND A CHAIR. YES TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONTESTANTS
IN THIS MESS. RIGHT ARE VERY
GOOD. THANK YOU THANKS FOR THAT
THAT'S VERY HELPFUL. WHILE I
DON'T FIVE A. B. THREE SEVEN
NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
STERN HI. JONES HI. ALAN ALL
RIGHT LRA AIKMAN FIGMENT HI
HERZBERG GROW I'M SIR GROVE
HERZBERG QUITE SO LAYERED
LAYERED HI. LOAN OKAY MEASURES
FIVE VOTES TO LEAVE IT ON CALL
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
EFFORTS HERE INTO THE SPONSORS
AND SUPPORTERS APPRECIATED-
THIS AGUILAR CURRY- SCENE THE
NIGHT OKAY YOU'RE UP. ASIAN.
YES IN DURING- YES SHE EARNED
IT NO I APPRECIATE-
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SIR. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMANMEMBERS THANK YOU TO
THE CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH ME IN MY
OFFICE SINCE LAST YEAR ON A B.
TWENTY ONE OH SIX. HERE WE ARE
A. B. SIX FOURTEEN IT GENERATES
FUNDING FOR THE EXISTING
NESTING BIRD HABITAT INCENTIVE
PROGRAM TO ENCOURAGE FARMERS.
AND LANDOWNERS TO CULTIVATE A
PLANT COVER CROPS. OR NATURAL
BIT OF AGITATION ON IDLE LANDS
TO PROVIDE WATERFOWL AND UPLAND
GAME BIRDS. WITH WILDLIFE
HABITAT. THE MEASURE ADOPTS A
TEN DOLLAR SURCHARGE ON THE
STATE DUCK AND UPLAND GAME BIRD
STAMP IS REQUIRED TO HUNT
WATERFOWL AND UPLAND GAME BIRDS.
EIGHTY SIX FOURTEEN ALSO
REQUIRES GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY
IMPROVE TRANSPARENCY OVER THE
SPENDING OF FUNDS COLLECTED BY
THE UP GLAND A GAME BIRD STAMP.
IN LINE WITH CURRENT PRACTICES
FOR THE STATE DUCK STAMP. LACK
OF AVAILABLE NESTING COVER
ESPECIALLY IN AGRICULTURAL
AREAS LIKE THE SACRAMENTO
VALLEY RICE GROWING REGION IS A
SIGNIFICANT LIMITING FACTOR FOR
BREEDING WATERFOWL AND OTHER
GROUND NESTING BIRDS. THE
NESTING BIRD PROGRAM IS
FLEXIBLE ENOUGH TO MEET
CALIFORNIA'S GROWERS NEEDS AS
FUNDS CAN BE USED TO PLANT
COVER CROPS. ENHANCE EXISTING
NESTING BIRDHABITAT AND
ESTABLISHED NESTING COVER ON
LANDS THAT ARE FOLLOWED UNDER
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS. A. B. SIX
FOURTEEN IS A NAP AS A RESOURCE
GENERATING CONSERVATION
MEASURES THAT WILL COMPLEMENT
OUR STATEWIDE GOALS OF CARBON
SEQUESTRATION. IMPROVING AIR
QUALITY AND PROTECTION OF OUR
WATER FILL SPECIES. THIS BILL
HAS RECEIVED NO OPPOSITION
ENJOYS A WIDESPREAD SUPPORT
FROM A DIVERSE COALITION
SPORTSMEN'S GROUPS CONSERVATION
ORGANIZATIONS AND PRIVATE
LANDOWNERS AND AGRICULTURAL
REPRESENTATIVES. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR OUR VOTE WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS MARKEDLY
FROM THE CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL
ASSOCIATION AND LOUIS BROWN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA RICE
COMMISSION. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SOME MEMBER- WILL TURN TO LEAD
SUPPORT THEN LOOKS LIKE THEY
WILL BE ON THE LINE SO MR CAN
ONLY MISTER BROWN. PLEASE JOIN
US. THERE MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MARKEDLY WITH
CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL
ASSOCIATION- THERE IS A
PRESSING NEED TO FUND THE
EXISTING NESTING BIRD HABITAT
INCENTIVE PROGRAM AS A B. X.
FOURTEEN PROPOSES TO DO. OUR
LOCAL WATERFOWL BREEDING
POPULATIONS HAVE DECLINED 36%
STATEWIDE IN NINETEEN NINETY
TWO WALL RING NECKED PHEASANT
POPULATIONS HAVE BEEN REDUCED
BY 90% IN SOME AREAS THANK. YOU
THOUSAND. IT ALSO BE NOTED THAT
THERE WAS A DIE OFF OF OVER
SIXTY THOUSAND WATER QUALITY
PLYMOUTH REFUGES LAST YEAR YOU
DOING AVIAN BOTULISM OUTBREAK.
MANY OF THE BIRDS AFFECTED ONE
WATERFALL THAT BREED THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA BUT USE THE KLAMATH
REFUGES PROMOTING PURPOSES. THE
CURRENT DROUGHT IS ALSO PUTTING
EVEN MORE STRESS ON THEIR
POPULATION. THESE ARE SHOWN-
AND DEMONSTRATED THAT PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL NOTHING COVERED
THROUGH THE BREEDING SEASON CAN
GREATLY BENEFIT LOCAL WATER
FOUNTAINS AND OTHER BIRDS.
SAMPLE THE RESULTS OF A TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN RIGHTS COVER
CROP ROTATION PILOT PROJECT.
FOUND THAT ANNUAL COVER CROPS
LOCATED ADJACENT TO WRITE ALL
DIVISION PRODUCED ESPECIALLY
HIGH NET THAT RATE. SHARE WITH
OTHER HABITAT BUT THE SCIENCE
REALLY SUPPORTS WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE. IN ADDITION
TO HELPING GAMEBIRDS THE
PROGRAM WOULD BENEFIT OTHER
GRASSLAND SPECIES LIKE NASTY
KONG BIRD AND POLLINATOR
SPECIES LIKE MONARCH
BUTTERFLIES. IT WOULD ALSO HELP
WITH THE QUESTER CARBON IMPROVE
SOIL HEALTH AND PROVIDE AIR
QUALITY BENEFITS. THESE
REASONS- PLEASE SUPPORT AB SIX
FOURTEEN THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. SURE THE FLOOR
BROWN ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA RICE
COMMISSION. MY COMMENT WITH
BOTH MCKINLEY HIGH IN REGARDS
TO THE TESTING PROGRAM BUT THEN
ALSO EXPRESSED SOME SUPPORT
AND- ADDITIONAL COMMENTS ON THE
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL THAT WOULD
HELP- CREASE PARTICIPATION IN
THE WINTER RIGHT HABITAT
INCIDENT PROGRAM PROGRAM. THAT
WAS CREATED JUST A COUPLE YEARS
AGO BY PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITY FOR LANDOWNERS- AS
MANY OF YOU KNOW HE RICE
INDUSTRY I PLAYED A CRITICAL
ROLE IN THE PACIFIC FLYWAY AND
WINTER FLOODING IS ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL- TO THAT ROLE THAT WE
PLAY. AND WE'VE SEEN OVER THE
YEARS THAT OUR PROGRAM IS
BENEFICIAL- BUT ADDED GOES WITH
ANY PROGRAM LIKE THIS HI AREAS
WHERE IT CAN BE IMPROVED WANT
TO TEMPLE MINUTES AND THAT'S
THE LANGUAGE THAT YOU FIND IN
EIGHTY SIX ONE FOUR WE ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- WILL NOW TURN TO
GENERAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
SEEING NONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
ANY IN THE ANNEX NINE WILL TURN
TO THE LINES WITNESSES WISHING
TEST FIND SUPPORT ON A. B. SIX
ONE FOUR. TWITTER PUSH THE
SUPPORT OF A B. SIX ONE FOUR
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN IF ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ABOUT FOUR
THEY'VE QUEUED UP SO FAR WE'LL
START WITH LINE NUMBER
SEVENTEEN THAT'S ONE SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I THINK ONE OF
THEM YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
OTHER ONE CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
YOU WILL GET A LINE NUMBER
EIGHTY FIVE EIGHT FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MARK SMITH ON BEHALF OF
THE GRASSLAND WATER DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THAT'S FINE THANK YOU NEXT IN
LINE NUMBER FIFTY EIGHT THAT'S
FIVE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MR SHARON SENATORS
BECAUSE PARKS ON BEHALF OF THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY SIX ONE FOUR THANK
YOU. ADULT LAST ONE OF THE KEY
WE HAVE AT THIS TIME IS LINE
NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN THAT'S
THREE SEVEN. MR CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MY NAME'S KERRY
BRENNAN WITH PRESIDENT OF
SENEGAL COUNTY WILDLIFE
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
FOURTEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OKAY WE HAVE NO OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT- WE DO NOT HAVE ANY.
OPPOSITION LISTED ON FILE HERE
BUT ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE.
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM SEEING
NONE. ANY PANIC SEEING NONE
TURN THE LINES IN WHICH
TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION TO SIX
ONE FOUR. IF YOU WISH YOUR
VOICE OF OPPOSITION TO AB SIX
ONE FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MR SURE
THERE'S NO ONE SHOWING UP IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME OKAY
VERY GOOD WE'LL BRING IT BACK
INTO THE DYESS. MEMBERS
QUESTIONS COMMENTS EMOTION. THE
KNOWLEDGE MEANT. A MOMENT AGO
THE MOTION FROM SENATOR ALLEN-
SEEING OTHER COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS APPRECIATE YOUR-
CONTINUED DILIGENCE ON THIS
MEASURE I KNOW WE'RE GOING TO.
A KEEP WORKING ON IT AS THE
YEAR GOES ON AND- HOPEFULLY GET
ACROSS THE FINISH LINE THIS
YEAR- SHE IS LOOKING AT- ALL
THE ISSUES NOT JUST FOR THE-
FOR DUCKS BUT FOR THE UPLAND
BIRDS AND FOR THE DOVES OUT
THERE AND ALL THE DIVERSITY IN
THIS IN THIS RANGE WE'VE GOT-
pIMPROVE HABITAT CONSERVATION.
AS YOU MENTIONED EVEN. IN B.
MAKE CARBON CARBON STORAGE BUT
ALSO JUST TO PROMOTE- WILDLIFE
IN. AN APPROPRIATE CONSERVATION
SO THANKS AND- THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. LA
CLIPPERS- RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. FILE ITEM SEVEN AV SIX
ONE FOR THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS STERN STERN
ALL RIGHT JONES ALAN AT ALAN
ALL RIGHT EGGMAN EGGMAN ONLINE
GROWTH HURTS BIRD WAY SO
LAYERED ON LITTERED ALL RIGHT
LET ALONE. WE HAVE FOUR VOTES
ONLY THE MEASURE ON CALL THANK
YOU TO THE PATIENT AND
DEFERENTIAL MR CHU A. B. FIVE
TWENTY FIVE OFFSHORE WIND
WELCOME THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AB FIVE TWENTY FIVE WILL JUMP
STARTING NEW CLEAN ENERGY
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA BY
DIRECTING OR STATE TO PREPARE A
STRATEGIC PLAN TO HARNESS THE
POWER OF OFFSHORE WIND DON'T
WANNA THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
YOUR ENGAGEMENT AND ARTWORK ON
THIS BILL AND ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENT TO INCLUDE BIO
DIVERSITY IS PART OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL ASSESSMENT. AFTER
YEARS WAVES WILDFIRES ROLLING
BLACKOUTS AND LOSS OF OVER A
MILLION JOBS WE HAVE A ONCE IN
A. GENERATION OPPORTUNITY JUST
TWENTY TO THIRTY MILES OFF OUR
COAST TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE. AND PUT PEOPLE BACK TO
WORK. CALIFORNIA'S ACCESS TO
ONE OF OUR WORLD'S GREATEST
UNTAPPED SOURCES OF RENEWABLE
ENERGY. OFFSHORE WIND WITH THE
POTENTIAL TO COMBAT CLIMATE
CHANGE MEET CLEAN ENERGY GOALS
AND PROVIDE GOOD PAYING JOBS.
IN EUROPE AND ASIA MANY
COUNTRIES ARE FAR AHEAD OF THE
UNITED STATES. FORTUNATELY THE
BY DEMONSTRATION HAS RECENTLY
ANNOUNCED BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OF INVESTMENT IN OFFSHORE WIND.
WELL EAST COAST STATES HAVE
ALREADY SET TWENTY NINE
GIGAWATTS OF TARGETS IN THIS
AREA. CALIFORNIA HAS
ESTABLISHED NONE AND WE MUST
ENSURE WE'RE NOT LEFT BEHIND.
THIS BILL GIVES US A CHANCE TO
CATCH UP PARTICULARLY WITH THE
RECENT ANNOUNCEMENT BY THE
WHITE HOUSE IN OUR GOVERNOR. TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH LEASE
AUCTIONS OFF OUR COAST.
OFFSHORE WIND CAN ENSURE A
DIVERSE RELIABLE PORTFOLIO OF
CLEAN POWER. COMPLEMENTING
SOLAR WITH WIND ENERGY AT NIGHT
WHEN THE SUN IS DOWN. IT WILL
ADD THOUSANDS OF HIGH SKILLED
JOBS IN THE SUPPLY CHAIN
DEVELOPMENT CONSTRUCTION
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE. THE
S. P. ONE HUNDRED JOINT AGENCY
REPORTED SHOWN THAT WITHOUT
OFFSHORE WIND. TOTAL ENERGY
COSTS BECOME A BILLION DOLLARS
MORE EXPENSIVE BY TWENTY FORTY
FIVE. BECAUSE I SURE WOULD
ALLOWS RENEWABLES TO MEET
ENERGY DEMAND DURING ALL HOURS
YEAR ROUND. THIS BILL WILL MAKE
SURE THAT WE TAP INTO ALL OF
THE BENEFITS OF OFFSHORE WIND
WHILE GIVING DUE CONSIDERATION
TO OUR STATE'S MARINE AND
COASTAL ECOSYSTEMS. AND
PRIORITIZING DEVELOPMENT IN
AREAS OF EAST CONFLICT. BY STOP
MOTION A PLAN TO HARNESS THE
POWER OF OFFSHORE WIND THIS
BILL ALLOWS TO JUMP START A NEW
INDUSTRY IN OUR STATE. AND MEET
OUR CLEAN ENERGY CALLS AT THIS
TIME LIKE TO TURN IT OVER TO
OUR WITNESSES. LAURA TO HAN
WITH ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA AND
JEREMY SMITH WITH STATE
BUILDING TRADES. A GOOD WILL
POOR WITNESSES- WHY DON'T WE GO
IN PERSON AND THEN TO THE LINE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH TERRIBLY
HALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL-
PROUD CO SPONSORS HAS BEEN
PARTIES LEGISLATION. WE'RE
PLEASED TO PARTNER WITH OUR
ALLIES IN ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA- ON THIS BILL WHICH
WILL PAVE THE WAY FOR UTILITY
SCALE OFFSHORE WIND ENERGY
CONSTRUCTION COLLECTIVELY OUR
UNIONS REPRESENT NEARLY HALF A
MILLION HARD WORKING MEN AND
WOMEN UP AND DOWN THE STATE.
ACROSS THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY INCLUDING MORE THAN
SIXTY THOUSAND FURNACES. WE'RE
EXCITED TO BE HERE TODAY. PRESS
CO SPONSORS OF A BILL THAT WILL
NOT ONLY PROVIDE JOBS AND JOB
TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES. FOR MEN
AND WOMEN IN THE NORTHERN PART
OF THE STATE AND EVENTUALLY
HOPEFULLY. UP AND DOWN THE
COAST BUT ALLOWED ANOTHER MUCH
NEEDED GREEN ENERGY TOOL
CALIFORNIA'S GREEN ENERGY TOOL
KIT. THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
TRADES HAVE BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT OF RENEWABLE ENERGY
PRODUCTION IN CALIFORNIA
BUILDING A PORTFOLIO OF GREEN
AND ENERGY THAT SETS THE BAR.
FOR THE REST OF THE NATION OUR
JOURNEYMEN JOURNEYMEN AND
APPRENTICES OF BUILT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF GIVE UP
CALIFORNIA'S UTILITY SCALE
ONSHORE WIND SOLAR HYDRO. AND
GEOTHERMAL PROJECTS ACROSS THE
STATE. OUR HANDS ON KNOWLEDGE
OF POWER PRODUCTION IN
CALIFORNIA MAKES US KEENLY
AWARE OF THE STRAINS ON OUR
EXISTING GRID. THE NEED TO ADD
MORE FORMS OF ENERGY TO IT AS
THE NUMBER SHE WAS RIGHTFULLY
FOCUSING ON HOW TO INCREASE
POWER PRODUCTION BY HARNESSING
CALIFORNIA'S INFINITE WIND
RESOURCE. HIGHLY TRAINED
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS IN THE
PRINCE'S PLAY PIVOTAL ROLE IN
BALANCING ENERGY ENERGY NEEDS
OF CALIFORNIA. BY MAINTAINING
INSTALLING ALL TYPES OF POWER
INFRASTRUCTURE HE'S BLUE COLLAR
JOBS BY TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
OUR MEMBERS FAMILY SUSTAINING
WAGES AND A MIDDLE CLASS
EXISTENCE. WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO SEEING OUR MEMBERS
AND APPRENTICES WORK ON OFFER
ONE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WILL
ENABLE CALIFORNIA TO
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE ITS
RENEWABLE POWER PORTFOLIO
MAKING OUR STATE EVEN MORE
GREEN AND ARE GETTING MORE
RELIABLE THIS BILL IS IT REALLY
A WIN WIN AND WE URGE OUR IDOL
TODAY. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
TURN THE LINES THE OTHER LEAD
SPORT WITNESS- MISTY HAD. THANK
YOU SENATOR STAR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'M ALREADY HADN'T
STATE DIRECTOR AT ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE EXCITED
TO WORK WITH THE FAMILY MEMBER
HERE AND BUT THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES OKAY
BECAUSE WHEN THEY'RE A. B. BY
TWO FIVE- THIS. IS HE- AND THE
DRIVER AND THE WORSENING
WILDFIRES ARE ALL ALARMS AT THE
GLOBAL WARMING IS HAPPENING.
AND WE STILL HAVE TIME TO
CHANGE OUR WORSENING TRAJECTORY
IF WE ACT NOW AS- WE MOVE TO A
CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE. I'M ONE OF
THE MOST INCREDIBLE NATURAL
RESOURCES ADD THAT WE HAVE IS
THE WIND BLOWING OFF OUR COAST
pTHE HOT SPOT FOR OFFSHORE WIND
AND THE WIND BLOWS. FASTER AND
HARDER THAN ANYWHERE ELSE IN
THE U. S. SH IN A RECENT REPORT
AFTER A WIN FOR AMERICA WE FIND
THAT WE HAVE THAT TECHNICAL
POTENTIAL. TO MEET MORE THAN
ONE AND A HALF HI IN. LAST
YEAR'S ENTIRE ELECTRICITY NEED
JACK PROBLEM OFF SHORE WHEN SHE
WHEN EIGHTY FIVE TO FIVE WILL
COME TO LIFE CALIFORNIA'S
OFFSHORE WIND ENERGY
PRODUCTION. DIRECTING THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION TO
COORDINATE WITH THE AGENCIES TO
THAT GOAL AND CREATE A PLAN. TO
GO BACK ON OFFSHORE WIND WHILE
PROTECTING OUR CRITICAL MARINE
ECOSYSTEMS. AND OUR STATE
BIODIVERSITY AND FASTER WE CAN
SUPPLY CLEAN ENERGY. THE DOCTOR
CAN WE ALL HAVE FOR THE FUTURE
SO WE. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND
I BOTH. VERY GOOD THANK YOU
MISS AND WILL TURN- X. TURNED
TO THE HEARING ROOM FOR.
WEAKNESS IN. OF WELL. A GOOD
MORNING MR MEMBERS OUT WELL I
WE'RE GONNA JUST WAIT ONE
SECOND ON THE LINES WE'RE GONNA
COME BACK TO YOU AND WE'LL
WE'RE GONNA START IN HEARING
ROOM. MY APOLOGIES THOSE
WAITING ON THE LINE WELCOME IS
WRONG IN HERE MEMBERS LIKE
MONEY GOING TO BE HALF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS. AND THE
COALITION OF CALIFORNIA UTILITY
EMPLOYEES A GREAT BILL GOOD
JOBS CLEAN POWER. YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS MAC CRIMMINS HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA NEVADA
CONFERENCE OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS HERE TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF MAYBE FIVE TO FIVE
THANK YOU MR GRAHAM'S. ANY
OTHERS IN SUPPORTING HEARING
ROOM SEEING NONE WILL TURN TO
THE- PEN THE- SERVER ROOM NONE.
NOW WILL TURN THE LINES THANKS
FOR YOUR PATIENCE ALL. NAME A
POSITION AND SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL. LIKE TO VOICE SUPPORT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE ABOUT- A DOZEN
ENTERING Q. AND GROW AND
GROWING WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER
SEVENTEEN TO START LET'S LINE
ONE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BIASES ONE WITHOUT ABOUT
CALIFORNIA AND WITH YOUR
SUPPORT AND. THE LINE NUMBER
THIRTY SIX THAT'S THREE SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MELISSA CORTEZ REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA WIND ENERGY
ASSOCIATION OF STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR CALLING NUMBER
NINETY THAT'S NINE ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
BRITAIN MCKAY SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF SERIES OF TRAINABLE
NONPROFIT THAT RUNS THE BICEP
NETWORK A COALITION OF MORE
THAN SEVENTY MAJOR BUSINESSES
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES. MANY
OF WHOM HAVE SUBSTANTIAL
OPERATIONS ARE HEADQUARTERED IN
CALIFORNIA. AND OUR MEMBERS
SUPPORT A B. FIVE TWO FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BY NUMBER FIFTY TWO FIVE TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS LEAH BARROWS ON BEHALF
OF THE INDEPENDENT ENERGY
PRODUCERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. GROWING
NUMBER SEVENTY SEVEN SEVEN
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
THIS IS BRIAN CAMPBELL OF
CENTRICA'S COMMUNITY ENERGY'S
VERY STRONGLY SUPPORTING AB
FIVE TWENTY FIVE. THANK YOU.
NINE TWENTY TWO TWO TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
GENESIS GONZALEZ CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE OFFICE OF THE
TENET GOVERNOR ELENI COULD
UNLOCK IT SO TENDER GOVERNOR
THAT PROUD CO SPONSOR OF AB
FIVE TO FIVE AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR IDOL TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. FIND FORTY EIGHT
FOUR EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MICHELLE OR ROCK ON
BEHALF OF B. P. AMERICA IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE TO FIVE.
THANK YOU. FIND SIXTY NINE SIX
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING TURN MEMBERS THIS IS
CATHERINE DOT ON BEHALF OF THE
ALLIANCE OF NURSES FOR HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENTS AND WE SUPPORT
THIS. THANK YOU. THANKS. NINE
FORTY FOUR ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE FORTY WOULD YOU
CHECK YOURSELF FOR SELF MUTE WE
CANNOT HEAR YOU. DURING THE
AUDIO WILL MOVE ONLINE NUMBER
NINETY TWO THAT'S NINE TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIRMAN VERS KAREN
LAYING ON TOP OF THE HUMBOLDT
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
EXCITED SUPPORT TODAY ON THE
STOCK THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ONE FORTY TWO FOR TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE FORTY
TWO CAN YOU CHECK YOURSELF FOR
MUTE. HELLO THIS IS STEPHEN
ROSENBAUM- PRESENTED THREE
FIFTY SPOKANE VALLEY- STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY
FIVE THANKS SO MUCH. NINE FORTY
FIVE FOUR FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
BILLY UNDERCUT THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS
IN SUPPORT OF FIVE TWENTY FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
THIRTY THREE ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU SENATOR STERN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
DANIELLE MILLS OF THE AMERICAN
CLEAN POWER CALIFORNIA WERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE
TWENTY FIVE AND ALL OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL ECONOMIC AND
ENERGY BENEFITS THAT OFFSHORE
WIND CAN PROVIDE THE CALIFORNIA
AND THROUGHOUT THE WEST. I'D
ALSO LIKE TO CONVEY SUPPORT FOR
OUR INDUSTRY PARTNERS- WE HAVE
AKHIR OFFSHORE WIND- ADDED
JEEZ. BUSINESS NETWORK FOR
OFFSHORE WIND CASTLE WHEN EDF
RENEWABLE. ACT WHEN OUR
MAGELLAN WHEN MAINSTREAM
RENEWABLE POWER. OCEAN WIND
OFFSHORE WIND CALIFORNIA OR
INSTEAD THE PACIFIC OCEAN
ENERGY TRUST. PRINTABLE POWER
AND R. W. E. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. NEXT MISTER
CHAIR JUST AS A NOTE YOU DO
HAVE EIGHT MORE REMAINING IN Q.
AND SUPPORT WILL NEXT GO TO
LINE NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN THAT'S
TWO SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AARON RODRIGUEZ THE
UNION OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BY NUMBER FIFTY EIGHT THAT'S
FIVE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE FIFTY EIGHT IF YOU COULD
CHECK YOURSELF FOR MUTE. DURING
A RESPONSIBLE MOVE TIELINE
NUMBER SIXTY FOUR THAT SIX FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BRING WHITE
WITH KATIE PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON
BEHALF OF OFFSHORE WIND
CALIFORNIA A COALITION OF
OFFSHORE WIND DEVELOPERS WHO
ARE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF A.
P. FIVE TWO FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. BUT I NUMBER EIGHTY
EIGHT THAT'S DOUBLE EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. KAYNETTE GAILLARD
FOR THREE FIFTY SACRAMENTO AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
EIGHTY FOUR THAT'S EIGHT FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MANY MEMBERS BODYGUARDS WERE
ALSO ON BEHALF OF OFFSHORE WIND
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. MY NUMBER NINETY
ONE THAT'S NINE ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THE JD TANGO ON BEHALF
OF THE BLUE GREEN ALLIANCE
FORTY FIVE TO FIVE. THANK YOU.
NINE SEVENTY THREE SEVEN THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN BURZYNSKI TO KARATE
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL CALLING
EXPORTED EIGHTY FIVE TWO FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND
FINALLY WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER
NINETY THREE THAT'S NINE THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS SARAH SHE WORKED AS
AN INVITE ON DEFENSE AND
SHOCKED BY THE FACT. THANKS SO
MUCH OKAY I THINK THAT'S OUR
LAST. WITNESS TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT. I WILL TURN INTO ANY
OPPOSITION WE DON'T HAVE ANY
LISTED ON FILE BUT ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. SEEING NONE THE JURY ROOM
SAYING NINE OR ON THE LINES NO
NOTION TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
WHICH IS THAT'S FINE OPPOSITION
TO AB FIVE TWO FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN IF ZERO AT THIS
TIME. POLITE NUMBER FIFTY EIGHT
FIVE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE FIFTY EIGHT YOU APPEAR TO
BE MUTED. APOLOGIES MISTER
CHAIR WE ARE RECEIVING AUDIO
FROM THAT LINE OKAY. MANY
OTHERS. THERE ARE NO OTHERS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME SIR OKAY
VERY GOOD WILL BRING BACK TO
THE DICE THAN COMMENTS
QUESTIONS. MOTION SAID EARLIER.
RBS I KNOW- TENDER AIKMAN IS A
I THINK PRINCIPAL. CO AUTHOR OF
THIS BILL ON MACARTHUR AND THIS
IS ACTUALLY VERY MUCH A
DISTRICT ISSUE AS WELL BECAUSE
WITH TABLEAU CANYON. PHASING
OUT THERE'S TRANSMISSION
AVAILABLE AND ONE OF THE TWO
PRIORITY SITES OFF THE COAST I
HEARD HUMBLED BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS PERSON TESTIFY IS
OFF OF SAN LUIS OBISPO COUNTY
AND THE TRANSMISSION IS THERE.
AND THIS IS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY
NOT REALLY SALUTE YOU FOR DOING
THIS BILL BECAUSE I THINK IT
REALLY PUT FOCUS ON IT SO I'M
PLEASED TO MOVE THE BILL. VERY
GOOD- THAT'S A MOTION AND I
HAVE A BIT OF PHONE- FROM ALL
MY FELLOW CO AUTHORS HERE SO
APPROPRIATE AND LOVE TO BE
ADDED ON. AS A CO AUTHOR AS
WELL- UPON AMENDMENTS- FROM
THIS COMMITTEE. I'M VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THIS WORK
ESPECIALLY AS THE YOU KNOW WE
WATCH THE PACIFIC INTERTITLE OR
NORTH OF THAT POWER SOURCE COME
UNDER THREAT FROM THESE
WILDFIRES NEXT TO BE SWITCHED
OFF- WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
START TO GET CREATIVE ABOUT
FINDING BALANCE IN OUR SYSTEM I
THINK THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT.
MEETING CLEAN ENERGY AND
CLIMATE BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
ACTUALLY ABOUT STABILIZING AND
MAKING THE GRID MORE RESILIENT
ITSELF TOO SO- WE GOTTA GO.
FAST THOUGH- STAKES ARE HIGH
AND THE TURBINES ARE LARGE- SO-
PLUG YOUR WORK ON THIS AND
ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE. I WANT TO
THANK THE GOOD CENTER FROM
STOCKTON AND FROM SANTA CRUZ
FOR EARLY CO AUTHORSHIP OF THIS
BILL AND OF COURSE. I'M SO
SORRY SORRY MAN I DO NOT SEE
YOU- YEAH IF YOU DON'T MIND.
THIS TIME JUST A BRIEF- I JUST
WANT TO AGAIN REALLY
CONGRATULATE YOU ON ON TAKING
THE LEAD ON THIS. A CLEARLY A
FEDERAL MOVED IN THE SAME
DIRECTION THIS IS IMPERATIVE AS
SOMEBODY WHO'S BEEN LIVING IN A
HUNDRED AND 11 DEGREES HEAT-
AND WE ARE AFRAID EVERY MOMENT
THAT THE GRIDS GOING TO GO AND
WE'RE ALL GOING TO BE HOT AND-
IT IS. IT IS VERY FRIGHTENING
AND I'M VERY EXCITED ABOUT
THIS. STAPLERS ARE GREAT AS
THAT AS THE- CHAIR SAID TO
DECARBONISING AND ALSO JUST AS
A THING THAT I THINK WE DON'T
THINK ABOUT ENOUGH IS OUR PORTS
OUR PORTS ARE UP AND DOWN OUR
COAST LINES. THAT ARE HUGE-
USERS OF POWER AND AS WE KNOW
WHEN TIMES ARE BUT WE REALLY
NEED TO THEM TO GO I THINK THEY
CAN GO OFF LINE- AND USE LOCAL
THINGS BUT THE MORE. I THINK
OFFSHORE POWER THE MORE WE CAN
GREEN UP OUR PORTS WHICH IS OUR
GOODS TRANSMISSION AROUND THE
WORLD WHICH IS I THINK
CONTINUES TO- TO CREATE THIS
PATHWAYS. TO A- CARBON FREE
FUTURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
THAT ENTERTAINMENT AND FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AS WELL ON THIS
MATTER- WE TAKE THAT AS YOUR
CLOTHES. SURE AGAIN I JUST
WANTED WANNA THANK GOOD CENTERS
FOR YOUR SUPPORT HABITAT THE
CHEER. AS A CO AUTHOR AND- ALSO
WHICH- AS WE TALK ABOUT A JUST
TRANSITION JUST REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COALITION OF.
ENVIRONMENTAL LABOR AND CLEAN
ENERGY ORGANIZATIONS IN A MOVE
FORWARD ON THIS. AS WELL AS A
BI PARTISAN SUPPORT FOR THIS-
THIS SHOULD BE A NO BRAINER-
BUT IT HAS BEEN A CONVERSATION
LONG IN THE MAKING. WE HAVE A
LOT OF WORK TO DO BUT IT'S GOT
TO START WITH. A STRATEGIC PLAN
TO MOVE THIS FORWARD. WE DON'T
HAVE MUCH TIME WE NEED TO DO
THIS- AND FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
YOU KNOW WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITIES TO WORK ON THINGS
THAT. WILL HOPEFULLY MAKE A
HUGE DIFFERENCE WHEN WE'RE GONE
AND THIS IS I BELIEVE ONE OF
THEM SO WITH THAT. VERY MUCH
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT.
A GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH-
THERE'S A MOTION FROM SENATOR
LAYERED- AND THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED. BUT FIRST A
MINUTE RE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHIEF CAN SOMEONE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. PILOT M. SIX AB FIVE
TO FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS. DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
STERN. HI HI JONES. ALAN
BATEMAN. BATEMAN I'D GROW.
HERBS FOR. WEIGHT SO FLARED BY
LAYERED ALL RIGHT LET ALONE.
OKAY THREE VOTES EMILY THAT
MEASURE ON CALL THANK YOU SOME
MEMBER- CINEMA CHECK OUT
WELCOME. FINALLY THE NUMBER
EIGHT A. B. SIX NINE SEVEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER
CHAIR AND SENATORS SO FIRST OF
ALL I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
FIRST AMENDMENT ON PAGE NINE OF
THE ANALYSIS RELATED TO MULTI
BENEFITS SOLUTIONS AND WE ARE
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH YOUR
COMMITTEE. ON THE SECOND
AMENDMENT TO IRON OUT THE
LANGUAGE RELATE RELATED TO
PREVENTING TYPE CONVERSION EVEN
IF IT MEANS- WORKING OVER THE
SUMMER RECESS AND WE ARE VERY
CLOSE. EIGHTY SIX NINETY SEVEN
WOULD CREATE A PROGRAM FOR THE
STATE TO PLAN MANAGE AND
IMPLEMENT FOREST RESTORATION
PROJECTS ON U. S. FOREST
SERVICE LANDS THROUGH AN
EXPANDED AND FORMALIZED GOOD
NEIGHBOR AUTHORITY OR G. N. A.
WILDFIRES ARE A CONTINUING AND
GROWING PROBLEM IN CALIFORNIA.
THE FREQUENCY SIZE AND
INTENSITY OF THE WILDFIRES ARE
INCREASING EVERY YEAR IN FACT
THE TOP SEVEN LARGEST WILDFIRES
HAVE ALL OCCURRED SINCE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. FIVE OF THE TOP SIX
OCCURRED IN TWENTY TWENTY ALONG
WHICH RESULTED IN MORE THAN
FOUR POINT ONE MILLION ACRES
BURNED. MANY MAJOR WILDFIRES
START ON THE 57% OF CALIFORNIA
FOREST LNDS OWNED AND MANAGED
BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AND
THEN SPREAD TO END DAMAGE
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE IN TWENTY TWENTY OVER ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION ACRES BURNED
ON FEDERAL LAND IN CALIFORNIA.
IT IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FOR
THE STATE AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO WORK TOGETHER. TO
ADDRESS FOREST HEALTH AND
REDUCE WILDFIRE RISKS. THE G.
N. A. IS A FEDERAL AUTHORITY
ALLOWING STATES TO CONTRIBUTE
FUNDING AND STAFFING TO ADVANCE
FOREST AND WATERSHED
RESTORATION ON FOREST SERVICE
LANDS. EIGHTY SIX NINETY SEVEN
FORMALIZES AND EXPANDS THE G.
N. A. IN ALIFORNIA. IT IS
DOUBTLESS HIS PRIORITIES FOR
WHICH TYPES OF PROJECTS SHOULD
BE FUNDED. IT ALSO LISTS
ELIGIBLE ACTIVITIES AND
PROVIDES GREATER DETAIL FOR THE
ELIGIBLE ACTIVITIES INCLUDING
ALLOWING STATE WORKERS. TO HELP
PREPARE NI PA AND SEQUEL
WRITTEN REQUIREMENT DOCUMENTS
AND ENGAGE IN PROJECT PLANNING
LIKE THE PREPARATION OF
RESOURCE SURVEYS. ANALYSES AND
REPORTS. THESE ARE CURRENTLY
ACTIVITIES NOT SPECIFICALLY
AUTHORIZED IN STATUTE EIGHTY
SIX NINETY SEVEN WILL
ACCELERATE THE PACE AND SCALE
OF ECOLOGICALLY BASED FOREST
MANAGEMENT. AND REDUCE STATE
WILDFIRE RISK. I HAVE TWO IN
THIS IS ELIZABETH FORSBERG ON
BEHALF OF MY SPONSOR THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY AND ALSO JULIA
HALL. ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
WATER AGENCIES AVAILABLE TO
TESTIFY. VERY GOOD THANK YOU
SEPTEMBER AND- I'LL ULTRABOOK
TURNED TO LINES FOR LEAD
SUPPORT I WOULD SAY MAYBE MAYBE
TNC CAN CLARIFY BUT I THINK ON
THE SECOND AMENDMENT. WE DO
HAVE- AT LEAST AN AGREEMENT FOR
A CURRENT AMENDMENT TO TAKE
FORWARD AND THEN WE CAN WORK ON
FURTHER REFINING IT BUT LET'S
TURN TO THE LINES AND TRY TO
GET SOME CLARIFICATION ON THAT
I THINK STAFF AND- THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY WE'RE TALKING
LEADING RIGHT UP TO THIS
HEARING SO- S. FORSBERG. THANK
YOU TURN NUMBER WAS FOUR FOUR
KIND OF MUSICAL THEATER ACTOR
POLICIES THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
WE ARE SPONSORING A B. SIX
NINETY SEVEN. CALIFORNIA
RESTORATION NEEDS TO BE
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE GIVEN
THE MAGNITUDE OF CALIFORNIA BOB
BACKLUND. ONE KEY BARRIERS AND
PROFICIENT BACKING AND
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO ACTUALLY
RESTORE FORESTED LANDSCAPE
SCALE. TALKING ABOUT THE
DOCTORS. ONLY ON THE PRODUCTS
TO IMPROVE FOREST HEALTH THAT
COVERS ALL OWNERSHIP IN
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL. EIGHTY SI
NINETY SEVEN IT PROVIDED WHAT
THIS APPROACH. BARBER'S DON'T
STOP AT YOUR SEXUAL BOUNDARIES
THE BILL WILL EXPAND THE
COORDINATION BETWEEN STATE AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO HELP
PROTECT COMMUNITIES AND RESTORE
WATERSHEDS ACROSS ALL
CALIFORNIA. RECOGNIZING THE
NEED FOR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
STATES TO WORK TOGETHER TO
ADDRESS FORESTALL ALMOST
COMPLETED THE GOOD NEIGHBOR
AUTHORITY IN THE TWO THOUSAND
AND FOURTEEN FARGO. AUTHORIZING
THE STATE AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO SIGN AGREEMENTS
THAT ENABLE THE SHARING OF.
STAFF AND OTHER RESOURCES
ACROSS JURISDICTIONAL
BOUNDARIES. EIGHTY SIX NINETY
SEVEN WHAT EXPANDED NEIGHBOR
ACCORDING CALIFORNIA BY
LAUNCHING A FORMAL PROGRAM. AND
HELPING BUILDCAPACITY THE
STATE TO ASSIST WITH THE
PROJECT PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION ON NATIONAL
FOREST LAND. THE AWFUL HIGHLY
THE IMPORTANCE OF WINTER KILL
COLLABORATIVE FORCE PROJECT
WHERE TRADITIONAL FUNDING AND
RESOURCES ARE LIKELY TO PROVIDE
THE GREATEST RETURN ON
INVESTMENT WITH RESPECT TO
WILDFIRE RESILIENCY. ONE
EXAMPLE OF THE NORTH YOU
BROUGHT FORTH PARTNERSHIP OR
PARTNERS ARE WORKING TO QUICKLY
PLAN FINANCE AND EMPLOYMENT
FORCE RESTORATION ACROSS TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND ACRES. THE SHARES
GEORGIA CALIFORNIA'S FOURTH
IT'S CRITICAL TO REDUCE THE
RISK OF WILDFIRES WE APPRECIATE
IT THE NUMBER TWO HOUSE
LEADERSHIP ON THIS. ISSUE WERE
STACKED WITH REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT. VERY GOOD- AND THAT
DIDN'T PROVIDE CLARITY ON WHAT
I WAS ASKING ABOUT BUT THAT'S
ALL RIGHT WE'LL GET INTO IT
AFTERWARDS WE'LL GET TO THE
NEXT TO. LEAD WITNESS- JULIE
BISHOP HALL I BELIEVE. WITH
AQUA THAT'S WE HAVE LISTED HERE.
YES GOOD MORNING KERR- MY NAME
IS JULIA HALL AT THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
WATER. DECEMBER HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SIX POINT
SEVEN. OVER HALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S FORESTS AND
HEADWATERS ARE ON FEDERAL LAND
AND FOREST MANAGEMENT IN THESE
AREAS HAVE BECOME AN URGENT
ISSUE DUE TO INCREASINGLY
SEVERE WILDFIRES CAUSED IN PART
BY OVERGROWN UNDER MANAGED FOR
A- DIFFERENT THE HEADWATERS OF
THE ENTIRE STATE AS WILDCARDS
FOR WATER QUALITY AND- CLIENT.
AND DAMAGE CRITICAL WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE. FEDERAL AND
STATE AGENCIES HAVE SOMETIMES
STRUGGLED TO DEVELOP A COHESIVE
RESPONSE IN THEIR EFFORTS. TO
MANAGE MORE THAN A TRUCK PILED
BY RED. BUT LAW CURRENT GRANTS
THE U. S. FOREST SERVICE AND
BUREAU OF LAND MANAGEMENT THE
GOOD NEIGHBOR AUTHORITY AN
EFFORT TO ALLOW THE STATE AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS TO WORK
TOGETHER MORE EASILY ON THE
FOREST MANAGEMENT PROJECTS. SO
WITH MEREDITH EFFORT BY
CREATING A DEDICATED PROGRAM AT
THE STATE LEVEL. IN ADDITION A.
B. SIX NINE SEVEN WOULD ALLOW
THE STATE TO CONTRACT OUT OTHER
LOCAL COVER LOCAL AGENCIES
INCLUDING WATER AGENCIES AND
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION. WHICH
CREATES MORE INCENTIVES FOR
COLLABORATION THEY CALL THEIR
INPUT NOT PERTAINING TO
COORDINATE ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT. THE FRENCH MEADOWS
PROJECT IN VANCOUVER PROJECT
THAT COULD BENEFIT FROM THAT
BILL. IN THIS PROJECT CARTER
COUNTY WATER AGENCY WORKED WITH
THE COUNTY THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY AND OTHERS TO
RESTORE THE LAND AND REDUCE
FUEL THE HEADWATERS OF THE
MIDDLE FORK OF THE AMERICAN
RECORD. EACH ENTITY BROUGHT
DIFFERENT TOOLS. TO THE TABLE
TO WORK TOWARD COMPLETION.
IMPROVING STATE FEDERAL ABILITY
TO MANAGE CALIFORNIA'S FOURTH
AND HAD WATER. AT BOTH THEIR
ABILITY TO COORDINATE WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WILL IMPROVE
FOREST HEALTH REDUCE THE RISK
OF CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES.
WILDFIRES AND LEAD TO HELP YOUR
HEADQUARTERS. FOR THESE REASONS
ARCO RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
I. K. THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE'LL TURN OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT- THERE ARE NONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM- SEEING ANY IN
THE- AUXILIARY ROOM NONE. WILL
TURN THE LINES ANYONE WITNESSED
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF. A. B. SIX NINE SEVEN. BE
SURE TO AVOID VOICE SUPPORT FOR
A. B. SIX NINE SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER FIFTY NINE THAT'S FIVE
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MARK BENCHER MAKER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS
AS WELL AS THE WATERSHED
RESEARCH AND TRAINING CENTER
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WE HAVE ONE MORE THAT JUST
POPPED IN THE QUEUE JUST
WAITING TO GET RECEIVE A LINE
NUMBER.
ALL RIGHT- MOVEON
DEPOSITORS IF THERE IS A DELAY
I DO APOLOGIZE THAT'S OKAY
WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER NINETY
SIX THAT'S NINE SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MR MEMBERS
TENEMENT THING ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COUNCIL OF ENGINEERING
COMPANIES CALIFORNIA IN
TRANSPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AT THIS TIME
YOU'VE EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE.
OKAY VERY GOOD THE QUEUE HAS
BEEN EXHAUSTED THE MEMBERS ARE
GETTING CLOSE. WE WILL TURN TO
OPPOSITION WE DON'T HAVE ANY
LISTED ON FILE. ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WISHING TESTIFIED
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE UNTIL
ROOM SEEING NONE WILL TURN THE
LINES. ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. IF YOU
WISH TO VOICE OPPOSITION YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MISTER CHAIR AT THIS TIME
THERE'S NO ONE DOING A
PROPOSITION. OKAY SO NO
OPPOSITION WILL BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE OF BEFORE I GO TO
MEMBERS THOUGH- I WAS HOPING TO
GET SOME CLARITY I THOUGHT WE
HAD AT LEAST LANDED ON- AN
AMENDMENT- THAT WE CAN WORK TO
FURTHER REFINE FOR AMENDMENT
NUMBER TWO TO PREVENT TYPE
CONVERSION- DO WE WANT TO TRY
TO GET SOME CLARITY ON THAT.
I'M SURE OR WE CAN ASK THE
SPONSOR JUST FOR REFERENCE FOR
THE RECORD NUMBERS AND LIKE ALL
ALL SPELL IT OUT JUST SO THAT
IT'S CLEARLY READ INTO THE
RECORD. I THINK WE HAVE
LANGUAGE- BUT THIS WAS ABOUT.
AVOIDING TYPE CONVERSION WHEN
YOU'RE APPLYING THESE- FORSTER
LANDSCAPE TREATMENTS SO- IT'S
LISTED ON PAGE NINE OF THE
ANALYSIS IT'S SIMPLY A BOLD IT
SAYS ADD LANGUAGE TO PREVENT
TYPE CONVERSION. THIS IS OUR-
SORT OF CURRENT WORKING DRAFT
IS PROJECT SHALL BE DESIGNED TO
PREVENT TYPE CONVERSION AND THE
SPREAD OF INVASIVE PLANTS AND
GRASSES. AND BASED ON THE BEST
AVAILABLE SCIENCE PROVIDE FOR
ECOLOGICAL RESTORATION AND FIRE
RESILIENCY PROJECTS APPROPRIATE
TO THE LANDSCAPE. AND
VEGETATION BEING TREATED NATIVE
SHRUB LANDS SUCH AS CHAPARRAL
AND COASTAL SAGE SCRUB SHELL OF
ECOLOGICALLY APPROPRIATE
TREATMENT INCLUDING THE REMOVAL
OF FLAMMABLE NON NATIVE SPECIES
AND THE RESTORATION OF NATIVE
SPECIES WHERE APPROPRIATE- IF
THERE'S ANY FURTHER NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL REFINEMENT WERE VERY
MUCH OPEN TO THAT BUT- WE'LL
MAKE SURE THAT'S ACCEPTABLE TO
YOU IS. THE AUTHOR OF FREE FOR
PRESENT PURPOSES. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN THAT IS TOTALLY
ACCEPTABLETO ME BUT IF I COULD
ALSO ASK THE SPONSOR TO MAKE
SURE THAT IS THE EXACT PRECISE
LANGUAGE THAT THE WORLD VERY
GOOD YES LET'S LET'S GO LET'S
GO TO THE LINES BACKED- TO MISS
FORSBERG NOT TO PUT YOU ON THE
SPOT AGAIN HERE BUT- WE'RE
PUTTING ONIONS. YOU WILL PUT
YOU ON THE SPOT. THANK
CHARACTER WASN'T SURE WHEN YOU
WANT TO DISCUSS THE MOMENTS
THAT THAT SOUNDS LIKE THAT'S
THE AGREEMENT AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU TO
REFINE THE LANGUAGE- OVER THE
SUMMER TOO. OKAY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR HELP. OKAY GREAT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR YOUR LATE
STAGE WORK HERE TO TRY TO GIVE
MEMBERS SOMETHING CLEAR TO VOTE
ON HIS PUSH JUST DOUBLE THAT I
WANTED TO. TRY TO LAND SOME
LANGUAGE SO RELEASE HEADED
DIRECTIONAL FOCUS HERE- NOW WE
GO TO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM. THE DIE S. SERIGNE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I DIED SIMPLY
WANTED TO THINK IT'S A MEMBER
FOR THE BILL AND- ANYTIME A
BILL. IS GOING TO REQUIRE A
CODE SECTION TO REQUIRE THE
NATIONAL RESOURCES SECRETARY TO
ESTABLISH SOMETHING. I SIMPLY
WANTED TURNED OVER FROM THE
GOOD SENATOR AND FORMER
SECRETARY. ONE SINCE. IT IS NO
I'M INDIFFERENT TO THAT NOW. I
HAD A QUICK QUESTION AND THEN A
COMET THE QUESTION IS I READ
THE ANALYSIS IT IT IT DOESN'T
SEEM TO MEASURE THE OUTCOMES OF
THE AGREEMENTS WHAT WILL THAT
BE PART OF SOME EXISTING
MEASURING PROCESS TO DETERMINE
WHAT ACTUALLY IS DONE OUT OF
THESE AGREEMENTS THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION IF I MAY TURN TO THE
WITNESS- FOR THAT- POLICE IN
THE MIST YES. PLEASE GREAT
THANKS. YES WE WOULD LIKE TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO CONNECT IT
INTO US BEFORE FIFTY SIX AND-
YOUR BILL TO HELP ESTABLISH A-
ACTION PLAN WITH MEASURABLE
GOAL. I OBVIOUSLY HAVE TO SAY
GREAT TO THAT SO. THAT'S GOOD
AND THEN I THINK THE EXISTING
FRAMEWORK WOULD ALLOW FOR THAT
BUT IT IS IT SOMETHING WE
SHOULD JUST CHECK OVER THE
BREAK TO IF WE HAVE TO
INTEGRATE SOMETHING FROM THE
COMMENT I WAS GOING TO MAKE. I
REALLY APPRECIATED THE ANALYSIS
FOR POINTING OUT- THAT 57% OF
THE FORCE TO THE LANDS ARE
UNDER FEDERAL JURISDICTION AND
3% UNDER STATE AND LOCAL IN
CALIFORNIA. AND IT MADE ME
CRAZY DURING THE LAST NATIONAL
MINISTRATION BUT SOMEHOW WE
WEREN'T DOING ANYTHING WHEN.
THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY WAS
OF FORCE LAND WAS UNDER FEDERAL
CONTROL. AND THE GOOD NEIGHBOR
AGREEMENTS HAVE HISTORICALLY
BEEN DESIGNED. ONE ONE SIDE IS
UP FISCALLY AND THE OTHER IS IT
PROPER TO MOVE IN AND SORT OF
DO THINGS FOR THE OTHER SIDE
WHEN THEY CAN'T DO IT AND- AT
THE TIME I THINK. GOVERNOR
NEWSOM TOOK OFFICE- SOMETHING
LIKE FORTY FIVE OR FORTY SEVEN
PERCENT. OF THE GREENHOUSE GAS
MONEY FOR FOREST. MANAGEMENT OR
FUELS MANAGEMENT WANT FEDERAL
LANDS UNDER THE GOOD NEIGHBOR
AGREEMENT BECAUSE WE WERE
REACHING AN WHERE THEY WORKED A
STEPPING UP. THEN SO THESE
AGREEMENTS WERE THERE TO DO
THAT IN THIS BILL JUST PROVIDE
STRUCTURE THAT DIDN'T EXIST
STRUCTURE AND GOALS AND ALLOWS
TRIBES TO BE INVOLVED. WHICH IS
GREAT SO I'M GOING TO. BE HAPPY
TO SUPPORTED IMPLANT THE
STRUCTURES THERE. AND I THINK
IT CALLS ATTENTION TO SOMETHING
THAT I'M NOT SURE THE PUBLIC
UNDERSTANDS CLEARLY THAT THERE
ARE THESE GOOD NEIGHBOR
AGREEMENTS AND THAT. IT IS A
WAY FOR DIFFERENT AGENCIES TO
WORK TO DO IT SO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THE BILL. THAT AT THE.
RIGHT MOMENT- POWER MOVEMENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- SENATORS
FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT- SEVERAL
STATES HAVE TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF
THIS PROGRAM TO GOOD NEIGHBOR
AUTHORITY PROGRAM. AND THEY'VE
PROVEN- A LOT OF SUCCESS SO
IT'S TIME FOR US IN CALIFORNIA
TO DO THE SAME SO IN ORDER FOR
IT TO WORK WITH YOU AWESOME
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND WE'LL
RECOGNIZE THAT IS A MOTION AND-
AND I WOULD JUST. THE ONLY
OTHER THING I WOULD ADD IS- AS
THE STATE. PROPOSED TO INVEST
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES IN. AND
TAKE CARE OF ITS LANDS ALSO
HOPING THAT OUR GOOD NEIGHBORS.
TO THE EAST THAT WE GET SOME
KIND OF PARTNERSHIP- FROM A
FUNDING PERSPECTIVE TOO BUT I
THINK THESE FRAMEWORKS GONNA
REALLY ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN SO.
PROCEDURE WORK HERE AND WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE ON. ON THE
ON SOME OF THE PROTECTIONS WE
NEED WE NOTED HERE IN- NO OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COME TO LIGHT A
CLOSE- I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIMPLY MEMBER-
SO THE MOTION. IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMENDED AND
RE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL CHIEF CONSULTANT. PILOT M.
EIGHT A. B. SIX NINE SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS STERN. HI BURN
ALL RIGHT JONES ALAN. ALAN ON
EIGHT EIGHT WOMEN EIGHT MEN ALL
RIGHT GROOVE HERZBERG BOYS SO
LAYERED HI LIZARD ALL RIGHT LET
ALONE. OKAY FOR VOTES WILL
LEAVE THAT MEASURE ON CALL
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
SENATORS. VERY GOOD- I THINK
LAST. NIGHT LAST UPLOAD FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINE. MR MATHIS YOU
ARE HERE. WELCOME SIR. MEMBERS
THIS IS A B. SEVEN FIVE FOUR
FIVE ITEM NUMBER NINE. THANK
YOU A SIMILAR PROCEDURE IF YOUR
DESCRIPTION HERE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR. GOOD MORNING.
SOON TO BE AFTERNOON STILL IN
THE MORNING GOOD DAY CHAIR AND
SENATORS. ABC SEVEN FIFTY FOUR.
ALLOWS A LOCAL AGENCY OR
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCY TO REQUEST A ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY DAYS EXTENSION FROM THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES WHEN SUBMITTING
A GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
PLAN. AS THE SERGEANTS HAVE
HANDED OUT. I HAVE LANGUAGE
DRAFTED TO CLARIFY THAT THE
DIRECTOR MAY. GRANT AN
EXTENSION ONLY IF AN AGENCY CAN
DEMONSTRATE THAT THE SIGNUP
PROCESS WAS DELAYED DUE TO
COVERT NINETEEN. YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT THAT I WILL SUBMIT
THIS AMENDMENTS. SHOULD THE
BILL PASS OUT OF THE COMMITTEE.
THE CENTERS I FEEL THAT IS
IMPORTANT TO DO SOME
CLARIFICATIONS ON THIS BILL.
THERE APPEARS TO BE SOME
CONFUSION REGARDING THE INTENT
OF THE BILL SO LET ME
CATEGORICALLY CLARIFY SEVERAL
POINTS. THE DIRECTOR. OF D. W.
R. DOES SENT HALF THE GRANT THE
EXTENSION. THE DIRECTOR CAN
REFUSE THE EXTENSION. ONCE
AGAIN THE EXTENSION IS OPTIONAL
AND IS SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED TO
HELP THOSE IN NEED. ONLY FOR
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO
COMPLETE THEIR PLANS DUE TO
COVERT NINETEEN. THIS BILL IS
NOT FOR EVERYONE. THIS BILL
DOES NOT CHANGE ANY SIGMAR
REQUIREMENTS IN ANY WAY. IN THE
LONG TERM. THIS WILL STRENGTHEN
SIGMA GIVING AGENCIES A BRIEF
PERIOD TO OVERCOME THE BARRIERS
OF CODE NINETEEN AND ALLOW.
THOSE AGENCIES TO DEVELOP A
MORE ACCURATE. THOUGHT OUT
THOROUGH AND EFFECTIVE PLANT.
MY OFFICE REACHED OUT TO THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES.
WHO SAID AN EXTENSION CANNOT BE
DONE ADMINISTRATIVELY. AS YOU
CAN SEE FROM THE EMAIL AND THE
IN YOUR BRIEF. WHICH IS DRESSED.
TO CONSULTANT AND AS WELL IN
REGARD TO LETTER DIRECTOR ERIN
HAS INQUIRED ABOUT D. W. O.
OURS FORTY TWO ADMINISTRATIVELY
PROVIDE AN EXTENSION. THE DUE
DATE IN STATUTE PERIOD WE
CANNOT PERIOD AN EXTENSION
WOULD REQUIRE A CHANGE TO
EXISTING LAW PERIOD HOPE THIS
IS USEFUL TO YOU BOTH. FROM
CASEY SMACKED DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES. RIGHT NOW THE SIGNAL
REQUIRES PUBLIC OUTRAGE THIS IS
A PROBLEM IN RURAL AREAS AS WE
ALL KNOW THIS WE ADDRESSED THE
STATE'S RURAL BROADBAND
PROBLEMS. PUBLIC COMMUNICATION
AND OUTREACH IS KEY TO SICK
MUST PROCESS. NOW. IN THE WATER
CODE. UNDER SECTION. ONE THREE
THIS TWENTY THREE CAL CODE RED
X. THREE FIVE FOUR POINT ONE
ZERO NOTICING COMMUNICATIONS.
IF YOU ADD A SECTION B. WITHIN
THE CODE. WHEN IT DISCUSSES
WHAT EACH PLAN. I SHALL INCLUDE
IN THEIR SUMMARY THAT THEY
PROVIDE. BE A LIST OF PUBLIC
MEETINGS AT WHICH THE PLAN WAS
DISCUSSED. AND CONSIDERED BY
THE AGENCY. NOTE THE WORD
PUBLIC MEETINGS IT ALSO GOES
DOWN INTO SECTION TWO OF THAT
IDENTIFICATION OF OPPORTUNITIES
FOR PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT AND A
DISCUSSION OF HOW PUBLIC INPUT
AND RESPONSES WILL BE USED.
CENTERS DO A COLD READ. THESE
PUBLIC MEETINGS HAVE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO HAPPEN. FOR OUR FOLKS
IN DISADVANTAGED RURAL AREAS
WHO LACK ACCESS TO INTERNET
THIS IS NOT BEEN FEASIBLE OR
POSSIBLE. NOW SOME DATA ON. OUR
DISADVANTAGE RURAL AREAS IN THE
FACT THAT THEY CANNOT SIMPLY
CAN DOCTOR ZOOM MEETING LIKE
MANY OF US WOULD HOPE. THE DATA
SHOWS MODOC COUNTY ONLY A FOUR
POINT 9% OF PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS
TO SPEEDS. OF TWENTY FIVE
MEGABYTES SIERRA COUNTY TWO
POINT 3% OF THE PUBLIC- MY
COUNTY TWELVE POINT 5% ALPINE
COUNTY EIGHTEEN POINT 5% WHAT
OPTIONS DO THESE RURAL
DISADVANTAGES COMMUNITIES HAVE.
THE STATE HAS TOLD THEM THAT
THEY CANNOT HAVE PUBLIC
MEETINGS. BUT THEY SIMPLY DO
NOT HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO
CONDUCT ONLINE MEETINGS. COVERT
IS STILL LIMITING THESE
AGENCIES AND THEIR COMMUNITIES
AGENCIES ARE STILL UNABLE TO
COMPLETE PUBLIC OUTRAGE. REAL
COUNTIES ARE STRUGGLING TO GET
THEIR RESIDENTS FULLY
VACCINATED WHILE URBAN CENTERS
ARE RECEIVING THE LION'S SHARE
OF VACCINE ALLOTMENTS RURAL
AREAS THE MORE CHALLENGING TIME
IN GETTING THE VACCINES OUT TO
THE PUBLIC. OR THE PUBLIC HAS
TO TRAVEL GREATER DISTANCES TO
GET VACCINATED SENATORS WE KNOW
THIS. WE'VE HAD DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT THIS WE ARE PUSHING
EFFORTS TO GET VACCINES OUT TO
THESE AREAS. UNFORTUNATELY IN
ALMOST AREAS IT'S A PROBLEM AND
IT'S IS TODAY AND THEY SAID
CANNOT HAVE THESE HERE. THAT
ARE NOT FOR THEIR SIGNAL PLANS.
OUR RURAL AREAS MAKE UP HALF.
OF THE FAXING RATES IN THE
ENTIRE STATE. SENATORS. OTHER
BILLS HAVE BEEN INTRODUCED DUE
TO COVER NINETEEN. FRANKLY I'VE
GOT SIXTEEN PAGES OF BILLS AND
I'LL SPARE YOU THE TIME AND
READING THROUGH ALL OF THEM THE
GRANT EXTENSIONS SIMILAR TO
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE
FOR EVERYTHING ACROSS THE
GAMBIT IN STATE LAW BECAUSE WE
KNOW COVE IT HAS IMPACTED.
EVERYONE. NOW WHAT. WHAT'S THE
ALTERNATIVE. BEFORE TO DO
NOTHING AS SUGGESTED. WELCOME
IF WE DO NOTHING. WHAT HAPPENS.
IS THE GSA'S GET PUT ON
PROBATION. ACCORDING TO WATER
CODE. ONE ZERO SEVEN THREE
FIVE. THROUGH ONE ZERO SEVEN
THREE SIX POINT SIX. THE ENTIRE
SECTION GRANTS THE STATE
JURISDICTION OVER A PATIENT IF
THEY DETERMINE THE PLAN IS TO
BE AN ADEQUATE WHICH WE KNOW
THEY ARE BECAUSE THEY HAVEN'T
HAD THEIR PUBLIC HEARINGS. THIS
DEFINITION IS VAGUE AND ALLOWS
FOR TOTAL INTERPRETATION BY THE
DEPARTMENT. THIS THEN ALLOWS
THE DEPARTMENT TO HIRE A
MEDIATOR. IDENTIFY SPECIFIC
DEFICIENCIES AND POTENTIAL
ACTIONS TO ADDRESS DEFICIENCIES
AND THEN DEVELOP AN INTERIM
PLAN. FOR THE BASIN TO OPERATE
UNDER. THE INTERIM PLAN MUST DO
A NUMBER OF THINGS INCLUDING
ESTABLISHING A TIME SCHEDULE.
FOR THE ACTIONS TO BE TAKEN.
I'M CURIOUS TO WHAT THE TIME
SCHEDULE WOULD BE BECAUSE OF.
NOT BEING ABLE TO HAVE A LOOK
MEETINGS. THEY HAVE TO DESCRIBE
A MODERN SYSTEM AND ULTIMATELY
RESTRICT GROUNDWATER
EXTRACTIONS. AS OF THIS SIMPLY
UNNECESSARY IF MY BILL WAS TO
MOVE FORWARD. ALL OF THIS
GOVERNMENT INVOLVEMENT IS
INCREDIBLY EXPENSIVE AND
REDUNDANT IT THE GSA APPLYING
FOR THIS EXTENSION OF MY BILL
SIMPLY WOULD LIKE TO GATHER
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THEIR PLANS. AS REQUIRED BY
THIS WATER COATS.
SIR THERE'S A
LOT OF CODE SECTIONS LOST MY
PLACE HERE FOR SECOND. AND. SO
BACK. TO THE ALTERNATIVES AGAIN
PROBATION IS NOT AN ACCEPTABLE
ALTERNATIVE. THE STATE WATER
BOARD TAKES CONTROL IT COSTS
MORE MONEY MORE TIME IN IS AN
UNNECESSARY WASTE. A LOSS OF
LOCAL CONTROL. AND IT'S GOING
TO TAKE THE SAME AMOUNT OF TIME
IF NOT LONGER. TO GET THE PLANS
COMPLETED IF THE AGENCIES OR ON
PROBATION OR IF THE STATE
INTERVENES AS IF D. DEPARTMENT
OF WATER RESOURCES GRANTS THE
EXTENSION PROVIDED IN THIS BILL.
WE DO NOT NEED TO DOUBLE THE
WORK FLOW. SENATORS MY TEAM AND
I HAVE WORKED. WITH CONSULTANTS
AND MULTIPLE COMMITTEES
THROUGHOUT THIS ENTIRE PROCESS
WE STARTED WITH ANY ORIGINAL
VERSION. THE LAST FOUR STRAIGHT
ONE YEAR EXTENSIONS ON THE
SIGNAL PLANS TO RECOVER IT.
THEN AMENDED THE BILL TO THE
NEXT VERSION WHICH THEN IT
GRANTED AND WOULD GRANT AN
OPTIONAL ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
DAYS EXTENSION AT THE DIRECTION
OF THE RECTOR OF DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES. AS YOU SEEN IN
YOUR FOLDERS SENATORS WE HAVE.
ANOTHER AMENDMENT. THAT REFINES
US EVEN FARTHER MAKING THE
GSA'S PROOF THAT IT WAS COVERED
RELATED IN ORDER TO BE ELIGIBLE.
TO POSSIBLY GET THE EXTENSION
IF THE DIRECTOR SO CHOOSES. TO
GIVE IT. HOWEVER AS YOU CAN SEE
IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THE
ARGUMENT IS MADE THAT THE BILL
IS NOT NECESSARY. SENATORS
AGAIN I POINT YOU TO THE
PREVIOUS EMAIL FOR THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR SAYS THAT. THE
CHANGING EXISTING LAW WOULD BE
NECESSARY. AND TO THE ARGUMENTS
THAT I'VE JUST MADE. SENATORS
OUR LOCAL IN SMALL DISTRICTS
AND AGENCIES SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THIS ISN'T A CART LAUNCH FOR
ALL AGENCIES. THIS IS JUST FOR
THE AGENCIES IMPACTED BY
COVERED NINETEEN AND WHICH THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES DEEMS AN
EXTENSION IS NECESSARY. IS FOR
GOOD FAITH ACTORS. THE SIMPLE
FACT IS THAT THE GSA'S WHAT TO
DO RIGHT BY THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND ENSURE ADEQUATE PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION. PLEASE DO NOT
DEPRIVE THEM OF THIS
OPPORTUNITY. ANY QUESTIONS CAN
BE DIRECTED AT OUR LEAD WITNESS
GERRY BYRNE SUPERVISOR FIFTH
DISTRICT MODOC COUNTY WHO
SHOULD BE ON THE LINE AS WILLIS
SAID NAWG. FROM RC RC THANK YOU
VERY GOOD WILL TURN TO YOUR-
THE SPORT WITNESSES ON THE LINE
PLEASE PROCEED. HELLO THIS IS
GERRY BYRNE AND A THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY.
AGAINST THE BUYING TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. SEVEN FIFTY
FOUR I'M HERE REPRESENTING NOT
ONLY BOTOX AND LASSEN BUT OTHER
COUNTIES THAT ARE IN THE SAME
SITUATION THAT THAT. WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING HARD TO PREPARE
THE REQUIRED YES HE'S BEEN
HAMPERED BY OUR ABILITIES TO BE
SEEN MEETING FOR PUBLIC INPUT
IS REQUIRED BY THE LAW SHE
DIDN'T COPE WITH ENVIRONMENT
VERY POOR INTERNET. OR CELL
SERVICE ARE REQUESTED NOT
BECAUSE WE WON'T HAVE THE PLAN
DONE IN TIME WE'RE ALREADY TWO
CHAPTERS ELEVEN AND TWELVE I
REQUESTED BECAUSE WE WANT A
PLAN THAT PROVIDES THE BEST
SOLUTION FOR ALL PARTIES
INVOLVED. AND TO BUILD THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE LAW.
BIDDING IN SOCCER. IT MAY BE
HARD TO FATHOM HOW THERE CAN BE
NO AVAILABLE BROADBAND AND
PORTED NONEXISTENT SELF SERVICE
IN MAJOR PARTS OF OUR COUNTY.
THAT IS THE CASE. I HAVE A
QUICK ANSWER TO THE ARGUMENT
PUT FORTH BY THE OPPONENTS. ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTY FOURTH ALL
THE EFFORTS. LOOKING AT THE
TIME AND MONEY ALREADY INVESTED
IN THE TIME FRAME TO REACH AN
pIS NOT. UNREASONABLE TO ASK FOR
TO GET THE BEST PRODUCT
POSSIBLE. YOU ALLOWING FOR AN
EXTENSION WAS OPEN INCREASE
COSTS. NO GSA WOULD BE FORCED
TO ASK FOR AN EXTENSION. TO THE
CONTRARY COSTS AND BENEFITS TO
THE PUBLIC WOULD BE HEAVILY
WEIGHED BEFORE SUCH A REQUEST
WAS MADE. THREE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD CAN
ALREADY GRANT A HUNDRED NINETY
DAY EXTENSION THAT REALLY IS AN
ACCURATE. PUTTING A BASIN
PROBATIONARY STATUS IS NOT THE
SAME THING AS AN EXTENSION. NO
ONE WANTS THE PROBLEMS THAT
COME ALONG WITH PROBATIONARY
STATUS. AT THE DERBY ARE REP
TOLD ME THAT WOULD BE A
TERRIBLE SOLUTION FOR ALL
PARTIES INVOLVED. FOUR WE NO
LONGER NEED THIS BILL TO GET A
STATUS OPEN. ALTHOUGH COVERED
RESTRICTIONS ARE LESSENING IN
MANY PARTS OF THE STATE THIS IS
NOT THE CASE DURING MOST OF THE
PLANNED DEVELOPMENT. ALSO ROLL
POPULATION VACCINE RATES LAG
BEHIND URBAN AREAS MAKING
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION THE BIGGER
CHALLENGE. PAPER REQUIRES THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ACTIVE
INVOLVEMENT OF DIVERSE GROUPS
DURING THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
PLAN NOT JUST FOR THE LAST TWO
CHAPTERS. IF A DOCTOR THIS
LEGISLATION WILL NOT A COMPLETE
SOLUTION WOULD PROVIDE A SAFETY
NET FOR COUNTIES. IF WHEN WE GO
TO ADOPT THE PLAN. WE HAVE OUR
BOARDROOMS FULL OF DISGRUNTLED
RESIDENTS WHO RIGHTLY SAY THEY
WERE NOT PROVIDED THE
OPPORTUNITY. SET IN LINE TO
PROVIDE MEANINGFUL PUBLIC INPUT.
THANK YOU FOR TAKING OUR
CONCERNS UNDER CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SUPERVISOR.
NEXT. THANK YOU KAREN SENATORS
SPECIFIC DOG WITH RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
THE TESTIMONY OF SUPERVISOR
BURN IS REPRESENTATIVE OF OTHER
RURAL COUNTIES WHO ARE IN
SIMILAR POSITIONS TRYING TO
MAKE UP FOR LOST TIME IT OVER
THE DEVELOPING THE GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY PLANS AS EARLY
AS LAST FALL THESE BRKEN HE'S
REACHED OUT TO THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
DEPARTMENT IN OFFICIAL
COMMUNICATIONS INFORMING THEM
OF ONGOING CHALLENGES AND
SEEKING POTENTIAL EMERGENCY
RELIEF THEN. HOWEVER THE
LIMITATIONS ARE COUNTING SPACES
ULTIMATELY WANTED TO WALK AND
WE THANK YOU FAMILY MEMBERS
TARGETED AND REASONABLE WELL
ALLOWED TO W. OR THE DISCRETION
EXTEND THE DEADLINE FOR A
LIMITED PERIOD IT IS NOT
PRESIDENTIAL STANCE IT HAS BEEN
A LEARNING PROCESS FOR GSA FROM
COUNTIES BUT THE BLUEPRINT
BEING DRAWN IN REAL TIME OUR
MEMBER COMPANIES ARE TRYING TO
INTEREST ABOUT THE BEST PLANS
POSSIBLE NOT TO JUST MEET THE
LETTER OF THE LAW BUT TO GET
THE LOCAL POLITICAL BY NEAR
DALTON WE MAKE THESE PLANS
WORK. AT THE JUNCTION OF WE
BELIEVE SOME EXTRA MONTHS TO
COMPLETE ROBUST PLANS WITH
MEANINGFUL PUBLIC PROCESS
PREFERABLE TO COMPLICATED
COSTLY DUPLICATIVE AND
POTENTIALLY PUNITIVE
ALTERNATIVES SHOULD KNOW WAS
WIDELY WRITTEN WITH AN AMPLE
IMPLEMENTATION HORIZONS AND RC
RC BELIEVES THIS BILL ALLOWS
FOR A MERITED ADJUSTMENT IN THE
FACE OF AGAIN UNPRECEDENTED.
CIRCUMSTANCE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR THANK YOU FOR YOUR-
OTHER INSTEAD OF THE- THE TO
THE COMMITTEE ROOM SEE NO.
LOOKING TO THE AUXILIARY ROOMS
SEEING NONE WILL TURN TO THE
LINES ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT NAME POSITION. TITLE.
IF YOU WISH TO VOICE SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND I DO NOT SHOW
ANYONE SHOWING UP IN SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME. OKAY WILL THEN TURN
THE OPPOSITION- LET'S SEE DO WE
HAVE ANY LEAD OPPOSITION HERE-
I DON'T THINK WE HAVE LEAD
OPPOSITION BUT IF ANYONE WISHES
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS MEASURE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. UP SORRY. GERMAN I'M
SORRY WE DO HAVE LEADERSHIP
POSITION ON THE LINE IS THAT IS
IT ROGER DICKINSON WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMISSION. A FORMER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DICKINSON. AND
A CO AUTHOR SEGMENT SHOULD
MENTION. YES. YEAH PLEASE
PROCEED YOU CAN YOU CAN PROCEED
AS IT IS AS LEAD OPPOSITION MY
APOLOGIES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOOD
MORNING I'M ROGER DICKINSON
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMISSION. L. G. C.
SUPPORTS LOCAL POLICYMAKERS ON
ISSUES SUCH AS CLIMATE CHANGE
WATER ENERGY AND COMMUNITY
DESIGN THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. AS NOTED
I HAVE SOME FAMILIARITY WITH
THAT MUCH AS DOES THE CHAIR AND
A NUMBER OF YOU. AND OUT OF THE
YEAR CHIEF CONSULTANT. AND HIS
ANALYSIS GET THAT EXACTLY RIGHT.
FIRST IT WAS THE DROUGHT WE
EXPERIENCE FROM TWENTY ELEVEN
TO TWENTY SIXTEEN AT MAINE
THANK MY POSSIBLE NOW WE FACE
ANOTHER DEVASTATING DROUGHT
IT'S NOW TIME TO BACK THAT'LL
SECOND SEGMENT GAVE MEDIUM
PRIORITY BASIN SEVEN YEARS TO
THE MET THEIR GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY PLAN TWO MORE
YEARS THAN HIGH PRIORITY
BASINS. THAT'S MORE THAN A
REASONABLE AMOUNT OF TIME THIRD
SHOULD A GSA NOT SUBMIT ITS
PLAN ON TIME CIGNA GIVE
DISCRETION TO THE STATE TO WORK
WITH THE LOCAL AGENCY TO GET
ITS PLANNED DONE WITHIN A
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS OF THE
DEADLINE OF JANUARY ONE. TWENTY
TWENTY TWO IN OTHER WORDS UP
HERE VIRTUALLY FROM NOW THE
STATUTE ALREADY INCORPORATES
THE FLEXIBILITY SOUGHT BY THE
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL AND IT
DOESN'T REQUIRE THE STATE TO
PUT A GSA ON PROBATION. FOR AND
PERHAPS MOST IMPORTANTLY SHOULD
THIS BILL BECOME LAW WHAT'S
NEXT REQUEST FOR DELAYS IN
IMPLEMENTING BROWN WATER
PLANNED DELAYS IN GETTING TO
SUSTAINABILITY OTHER EXCEPTIONS
AND EXEMPTIONS WE CAN'T AFFORD
TO EVEN HINT THAT WE MIGHT GO
DOWN SUCH A PATH WITH THE
FUTURE OF WATER CHALLENGES IN.
CLIMATE CHANGE IMPACTS WE PAY.
BUT SUGGESTED A MAN CHAIN
NOTHING IT WILL ONLY CREATE
MORE CONFUSION AND DISTRACT
ATTENTION FROM GETTING GSP IS
DONE AND- THERE'S NO REASON AND
NO JUSTIFICATION FOR THE BILL.
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST I
KNOW ABOUT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY- WILL TURN
TO OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- I DIDN'T SEE ANY IN
THE HEARING ROOM OR IN THE
AUXILIARY ROOM SO WE WILL TURN
THE LINES. LIKE TO VOICE
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
TO IN Q. WILL FIRST GO TO LINE
NUMBER SEVENTEEN ONE SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WHAT I MEAN I
KNOW WITHOUT A LOT OF TELEPHONE
AND OPPOSITION OF THIS STUFF.
THANK YOU. PUT A LINE NUMBER
TWELVE POINT TWELVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN SENATOR THE SILENT
SILENT PARTNER WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN OPPOSITION TO
EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTY FOUR AND WE
WOULD ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH
THOSE MADE BY AMERICA THE
NUMBER. YOU CAN CALL THANK YOU
OKAY THANKS SO MUCH ANY OTHERS
IN OPPOSITION. WE DO HAVE SOME
MORE- THAT HAVE CUED UP WILL
GET A LINE NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN
TO SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
BIRDS ERIN RODRIGUEZ WITH UNION
OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS AND
CHONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. YES WHAT A LINE
NUMBER NINETY SEVEN NINE SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS NOT THE EQUIVALENT CO
WITH LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY CAL
CALLING IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
EIGHTY SEVEN FIVE FOUR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THE LINE NUMBER
NINETY FOUR NINE FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
ALWAYS CONDUCT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE ONE
MORE WITH A LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED ONE HUNDRED EURO. THE
MORNING AFTER TEARING SENATORS
I RAN ACROSS- ELLIOT CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
GROUNDWATER COALITION IN
OPPOSITION WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SURE THERE ARE NO
MORE INTO AT THIS TIME. OKAY
WILL BRING BACK TO THE DAYS I
WOULD JUST SAY THE OUTSET- I
SINCERELY. APPRECIATE THE
AUTHENTICITY OF THE AUTHOR'S
POSITION AND THE COUNTIES THAT
HE'S FIGHTING FOR HERE AND- ANY
EFFORTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE IN
THE INTERIM TO TRY TO FIND-
WHAT I WAS HOPING TO BE AN
ADMINISTRATIVE SOLUTION I THINK
WE THERE'S A DIFFERENCE OF
OPINION ON. HOW THE EXISTING
LAW WORKS- I DO RECOGNIZE THAT
THAT- IN THE PACKET YOU
PROVIDED THAT- D. W. R. AND
EVEN THE STAFF ANALYSIS POINTS
OUT THAT THERE THERE ARE
DEADLINES IN LOS- BUT- THERE
ARE ALSO DISCRETIONARY.
AUTHORITIES PROVIDED TO THE
STATE WATER BOARD- THAT DO NOT
REQUIRE A DATA BASE TO BE PUT
IN PROBATIONARY STATUS. TO GIVE
THEM DISCRETION TO- TO GO PAST
THAT STATUTORY DEADLINE SO YOU
DON'T ACTUALLY HAVE TO BE
PLACED ON PROBATIONARY STATUS.
TO MEET THAT DEADLINE I BELIEVE
THE ANALYSIS STATES- IT'S THAT
THIS THIS SPECIFICALLY STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
AFTER NOTICING A PUBLIC
HEARING- MAY DESIGNATE A HIGHER
MEDIUM PRIORITY BASIN AS A
PROBATIONARY BASIN IF THE BOARD
FINDS CERTAIN CONDITIONS A
CERTAIN SITUATIONS APPLIED TO
THE BASIN- AND BUT IF THE IF
THAT BASIN HAS BEEN WORKING IN
GOOD FAITH- AND PROVIDES A PLAN
AFTER THE DEADLINE SO YOU ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS AS YOU'RE
PROPOSING NOTHING IN LAW
REQUIRES THEM TO PUT ON
PROBATIONARY STATUS. TO ACCEPT
THAT AND THERE'S- THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT ACTUALLY IS
BROADCASTED BUT THERE'S
ACTUALLY NOT A- AND- VIOLATION
PROVISION IN STATUTE WHERE
THERE'S A FIFTY OR SOME OTHER
KIND OF PENALTY- AUTOMATICALLY
IMPOSE THIS IS ALL LEFT IN THE
DISK THE DISCRETION OF THE
BOARD. I WOULD ALSO JUST SAY
YOU KNOW THEY'RE WITHIN THE
MEDIUM BASINS I THINK THERE ARE
ABOUT SIXTY THREE BASINS WITH
THEIR PLANS DO IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWO- WE'VE TALKED ABOUT A FEW
OF THOSE TODAY. ABOUT NINETY
PLANS ARE ON THEIR WAY AND
AFTER A MULTI YEAR PERIOD VERY
TENSE IN THIS IS COMPLEX STUFF
TO LAND- ONE OF THESE PLANS ARE
WITHIN THE BASIN OR MULTIPLE
PLANS WITHIN THE BASIN UNDER
SIGMA. AND I RECOGNIZE THE
TENSION AND- THAT THAT THAT-
ELEVATES BUT- THE DROUGHT
NECESSITATES US TO ACTUALLY TRY
TO GET TO SOME SUSTAINABILITY
WHICH IS THE ENTIRE DESIGN OF
SIGMUND THE FIRST PLACE. SO MY
CONCERN ABOUT THE LEGISLATION
AT THIS POINT IS THAT IT FOR RE
OPENING SIGMA. FOR JUST A
HANDFUL OF MEDIUM BASINS- THAT
ALREADY HAVE ADMINISTRATIVE
RECORDS WITH STATE WATER BOARD-
AND THEN AS THE GREAT
CALIFORNIA GROUNDWATER
ASSOCIATION NOTES- THAT THE
DEADLINE HAS BEEN IN PLACE
SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN AND ALL
THESE OTHER GSA'S BEEN WORKING
TOWARDS THE EXISTING DEADLINES
FOR FIVE YEARS. IT'S NOT THE
TIME TO POSTPONE OR DELAY THIS
THIS NECESSARY WORK SO-
APPRECIATE YOU WORKING HARD AT
IT I DO NOT WANT- I KNOW YOU
WANT THIS BILL TO GO UP FOR A
VOTE I WON'T BE SUPPORTING IT.
TODAY BUT I DON'T WANT THIS TO
BIAS IN ANY WAY- THE
APPLICATIONS OR THE CONDITIONS
IS THAT YOUR- PARTICULAR.
REGIONS OF GONE THROUGH ANY OF
THESE COUNTIES WE DO WE DON'T
WANT THIS HEARING TO ANYWAY
BUYS THAT APPLICATION AND I
DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
IMPLICATION OF BAD FAITH ON
THEIR PART. I TAKE THEM AT
THEIR WORD THAT THEY'VE HAD
HUGE CHALLENGES AND WE ALL KNOW
RURAL BROADBAND'S AN ISSUE AND-
SO. NO NO DISPUTE ON THE
HARDSHIPS THEY'VE GONE THROUGH
I JUST I THINK THERE'S WE HAVE
TO BE. INCREDIBLY CAREFUL
ABOUT. RE OPENING SIGNAL WHEN
YOU ENTER THIS BILL DOES NOT
REOPEN SIGMA I UNDERSTOOD
EARLIER I GET THAT I MEAN. I'M
JUST STATING MY RATIONALE FOR
RE OPENED SIGMA GRANTS
UNDERSTOOD. OUR MAN. DIRECTOR
YOU TOO COLD. TO GRANT THE
EXTENSION VERSUS DOING
PROBATION. UNDERSTOOD THAT
THERE'S NOT A CODE SECTION.
THAT SAYS THEY WON'T PUT THEM
IN PROBATION IT IS IT'S ALL UP
IN THE AIR. SO WHY WOULD WE NOT
DO OUR DUE DILIGENCE RIGHT LIKE
WE'VE DONE. AND HUNDREDS OF
OTHER BILLS THIS YEAR DUE TO
COPE ED. TWO VERY SPECIFICALLY
CLARIFY WHAT OUR INTENTIONS AS
A LEGISLATIVE BODY ARE. RIGHT
BECAUSE WITHOUT THIS WEREALLY
EVEN IN THE AIR SENATOR. SEE
THAT- THERE ARE A LOT OF OTHER
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE WE HAVE NOT
CHANGED AT LINES- THE CLEAN AIR
ACT OUTLINES OF NOT CHANGED.
THE CLEAN WATER DEADLINES HAVE
NOT CHANGED. THE SCOPING PLAN
DEADLINES HAVE NOT CHANGED I
RECOGNIZE THERE ARE OTHER
CIRCUMSTANCES AND EIGHT AND I
SAW YOUR FILE. BUT WHAT I'M
SAYING HERE IS THAT I THINK
THERE'S ADMINISTRATIVE
RECOURSE. TO A TAXI THAT
DEADLINE IF THEY'RE WORKING IN
GOOD FAITH AND I WOULD HIGHLY
ENCOURAGE THEM TO KEEP DOING SO
AND HAVING THAT OPEN DIALOGUE
AND BRINGING THAT WORK FOR. THE
STATE WATER BOARD ANYMORE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE OR OTHER
ASSISTANCE IS NECESSARY WE CAN
ALSO LOOK AT THAT- THROUGH D.
W. ARE IN SOME OF THE OTHER
PROGRAMS OUT THERE- SO. I KNOW
WE'VE GOT A WE'VE SORT OF HIT
AN IMPASSE ON THIS ONE AND I DO
COMPLETELY RESPECT YOUR YOUR
POINT OF VIEW BUT- THAT'S JUST
WHERE I'M- GONNA BE AT TODAY
SO- CANNOT BE RECOMMENDING
SUPPORT AT THIS POINT AND- WILL
BE OPPOSING LEGISLATION AND- AS
IT'S BEEN PUT BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE BUT- MORE THAN
WILLING TO. ACCEPT OTHER.
COMMENTS QUESTIONS- AS
NECESSARY. MANY OTHERS YES MY
STRUCTURE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN OF THE FROM THE
MEMBERS HAVE COMMON SENSE- YOU
KNOW I CAN HOLD OFF ON MAKING A
MOTION THAT YOU KNOW JUST BASED
ON. THE WITNESS TESTIMONY AND-
YOU KNOW I THINK THE REASONABLE
NOUS OF A HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS
IN THE GRAND SCHEME OF THINGS
YOU KNOW SEEMS LIKE A- PRETTY
MINOR. THING FOR THE COMMITTEE
TO OFFER- TO THESE
ORGANIZATIONS SO I'D BE WILLING
TO MAKE THE MOTION FOR SUPPORT.
THANKS FOR THAT ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. OR MAKE
A BRIEF COMMENT AND THAT IS
THAT- IF THE- I AGREE WITH THE
CHAIR THAT THERE ARE REMEDIES
DID EXIST WITHOUT DOING THIS
BILL THE THING THAT I SAID IN A
PRIVATE CONVERSATION WITH THE
AUTHOR GIVEN ANOTHER BILL I'M
DOING WITH SIMILAR DEADLINES IS
IN THAT BILL I'M NOT MOVING THE
DEADLINES I AM OVER ONLY
DEALING WITH THE ENFORCEMENT
THAT EXISTS FOR A BRIEF PERIOD
DUE TO SOME OF THE SIMILAR
FACTORS THAT AND THAT THAT
MIGHT HAVE BEEN THE ROUTE TO GO
HERE. BECAUSE I THINK- MR
DICKINSON- NAILED IT IN HIS-
TESTIMONIES THERE'S BEEN SEVEN
YEARS UP TO THIS FOR FIVE YEARS
AND IT DEPENDING ON THE STATUS
OF THE BASE AND- HE PIANO WE
JUST NEED TO AS I SAID IN AN
EARLIER BLL TODAY- I THOUGHT
THE COMPROMISES THAT WERE MADE
IN SEGMENT THE TIME MOVED IT
OUT FARTHER THAN IT SHOULD HAVE
BEEN. IN ORDER TO DEAL WITH
THAT SO IF THE MOTION IS MADE I
WILL VOTE NO I WOULD HAVE
PREFERRED THAT OTHER
ALTERNATIVE I DON'T THINK
THERE'S- A NEED TO MOVE THE
DEADLINES OF SEGMENT SELF. SO I
GUESS I'LL DEFER TO THE AUTHOR
WHETHER YOU DO IT THERE'S A
WILLINGNESS TO MAKE A MOTION I
THINK YOU'VE HEARD FROM SOME OF
THE COMMITTEE AT LEAST NOT THE
ENTIRE COMMITTEE BUT- LEAVES
YOUR DISCRETION MR CHAIRMAN AS
I TOLD YOU PREVIOUSLY I WAS.
COMPLETELY HAPPY AND OPEN TO
MAKING ANY ME ANY AMENDMENTS
NECESSARY. TO MOVE THIS FORWARD
IF THE ROUTE AS CENTER LAYERED
SAID WAS TO CHANGE IT TO A
DIFFERENT PART OF THAT I'M
ALWAYS OPEN TO THAT. AS I
STATED IN MY TESTIMONY WE'VE
AMENDED THIS BILL MULTIPLE
TIMES. AND IF THE BILL IS
UNABLE TO GET OUT TODAY I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
RECONSIDERATION SO WE CAN
ACTUALLY LOOK. AT A DIFFERENT
ROUTE OF AMENDMENTS. MY NUMBER
ONE THING IS THAT THESE RURAL
COMMUNITIES. THAT DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO INTERNET THAT HAVE
BEEN HIT BY COVE IT DO NOT
DESERVE TO GET PUNISHED.
BECAUSE OF THINGS THAT WERE
COMPLETELY OUT OF THEIR CONTROL
THAT IS MY GOAL HERE. IT'S NOT
TO GIVE MORE MORE EXTENSIONS
AND ALL THESE OTHER THINGS AND
MAKE AN UNFAIR OR ANYTHING LIKE
THAT. WHAT'S UNFAIR IS THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS. THAT
THEY'VE BEEN HIT HARDER THAN
ANY OTHER AREAS THAT ARE NOT
RECEIVING THE SAME RESOURCES.
SO IT'S MY GOAL THAT THIS BODY.
REALIZES THAT IN GIVES THEM THE
HELP. THEY NEED WE'VE WRITTEN
THIS IN SUCH A WAY THAT THEY
HAVE TO PROVE. THAT THEY'RE
WORTHY OF IT AND THAT THEY ARE
GOOD ACTORS IN THE DISCRETION
IS STILL OPEN TO THE DEPARTMENT
THAT'S CURRENT LAW ALREADY
STATES. I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT THEY ARE GOING INTO A
PROBATION APPROVED WE SHOULDN'T
PUNISH THEM BECAUSE THEY LACK
ACCESS. THAT'S AN EQUITY ISSUE
THAT WE'RE ALL BETTER THAN I
UNDERSTOOD SEARCH- YES SO I'M
SOME HEARING A WILL. OF A
PREFERENCE TO HAVE A MOTION
MADE IF IT DOES IF IT FAILS S.
RECONSIDERATION OF THAT WE CAN
KEEP WORKING ON THE ISSUES THAT
SEEM LIKE THE- IDEAL OKAY I
JUST WANT ONE IDEAL IDEAL I
JUST WANT TO CLARIFY WITH US
COLLEAGUES ON THE DIETS THAT.
IF MR LAYERED WAS CONSIDERING A
MOTION DIFFERENT THAN MINE I'M-
I DIDN'T BUT I DIDN'T PICK THAT
UP BUT THAT DIDN'T SOUND LIKE
IT TO ME. NO I THINK THAT WAS
THE DIRECTION I WAS HOPING THE
AUTHOR WOULD'VE TAKEN BEFORE
GETTING HERE. AND HE DID MAYBE
IF THIS IS DEFEATED. R.
RECONSIDERATION IS NOTICED THAT
HE'LL CONSIDER THAT. WITH
REGARD TO MY SUGGESTION THAT
WOULD BE THE PROPER. PROCESS TO
FOLLOW OKAY RATHER THAN MAKING
IT AND WRITES IT TO MOTION
BRIDE OKAY. ENVY AGAIN SOONER
OR LATER TO YOUR POINT SIR- WE
DID ASK. FOR ANY AMENDMENTS ANY
CHANGES. TALK THROUGH THE BILL-
WE WENT THROUGH A TWO WEEK
PROCESS OF THAT AND THAT'S WHAT
MY STAFF REACHED OUT WHICH IS
WHERE WE HAVE THE EMAIL-
TALKING ABOUT MY STAFF MEMBER
MY LEISURE ACTOR BENJAMIN. OKAY
SO DID YOU WANT TO MAKE A
MOTION FOR FILLING THE MOTION
FOR APPROVAL AS AS IS PRESENT
TODAY OKAY UNLESS THE NUMBER
ONE CHENNAI WITHDRAWALS YOU CAN
MAKE A DIFFERENCE. OKAY WHAT. I
THINK WE'RE GOOD OKAY SO JUST
TO CATCH YOU UP- THE AUTHOR
WISHES AT THE BUILDING COULD BE
UP FOR A VOTE SO THERE'S GONNA
BE A WITCH WITH OR WITHOUT THE
MENACE ON THE BILL. FIGURE FOR
US IN THE COMMITTEE NOT NOT
WHAT YOU'VE BEEN HANDED BY THE
AUTHOR. MISTER MISTER CHAIR.
BUT JUST JUST THE BILL AS IS
PRESENTED THE COMMITTEE WILL BE
PROPOSED I'LL BE VOTING NO HI
OKAY- AND- BUT IT. ENDED UP
UPON RECONSIDERATION YEAH HE
HE'S GONNA SEE THAT'S
RECONSIDERATION. CAN I ASK FOR
RULES CLARIFICATION ON THE
DOOR. I'M SORRY YES- IF WE VOTE
AND IT FAILS AND IT'S OFFERED
RECONSIDERATION THIS IS THE
LAST HEARING THAT WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE IS THAT CORRECT WE'RE
IN A REAL WAY THAT WOULD BE
REQUIRED ALREADY REVIEWED.
WOULD IT BE BETTER FOR THE
AUTHOR TO OFFER TWO. TWO YEAR
THE BILL. RATHER THAN TAKE THE
VOTE TODAY AND- WE CAN'T TO
YOUR THE BILL BECAUSE THE
DEADLINE FOR SIGMA'S JANUARY.
OKAY ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. I
SUPPOSE IS AN URGENCY MEASURE
THAT WOULD BE THE ONLY THING
THAT. WOULD DEFY THE COMMITTEE
RIGHT A LINE PROCESS OF IT
THANK YOU TO MAYBE ONE CHANGE
THEY CAN MAKE A RECONSIDERATION
BUT- PENSION WE TAKE THAT AS A
MOTION YES. OKAY SO IT'S A
MOTION FROM THE VICE CHAIR- YOU
WANT TO TREAT YOUR LAST COMMENT
YOUR CLOTHES OR DO YOU WANT TO.
DO BUT ONE MORE. AGAIN SENATORS
IS THIS IS. YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT EXTREMELY RURAL AREAS
THAT HAVE BEEN HAVE I COPE WITH
THAT DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
BROADBAND THAT HAVE NOT. BEEN
ABLE TO MEET. THE REQUIREMENTS.
FOR THEIR GS FEES AS LABELED.
INK IN THE WATER BECAUSE THE WI
FOR FORWARD. THEY THEY SIMPLY
DO NOT HAVE THE ACCESS TO DO SO.
AND I DO NOT BELIEVE THE DO
NOTHING APPROACH HERE TODAY TO
ALLOW THEM TO GO TO A
PROBATIONARY PERIOD AND I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S A
DISAGREEMENT ON WHAT THAT MEANS
BUT- IN A WATER CODE AS WATER
CODE AND WHEN IT SAYS PROBATION
NIGHT I TAKE THAT AS TO MEAN.
PROBATION SO WE CAN EITHER GIVE
THEM THIS ABILITY. TO WORK WITH
THE DEPARTMENT TO SHOW GOOD
FAITH TO SHOW THAT THEY WERE
AFFECTED BY COLD IT. OR WE PUT
HIM ON PROBATION CENTERS THE
CHOICE IS YOURS THANK YOU. OKAY
WE'VE BEEN THROUGH SOME
CLARIFICATION ON THAT WE HAVE A
DIFFERENCE OF OPINION ABOUT HOW
THE LAW WORKS BUT APPRECIATE
THAT WILL ACCEPT THAT AS YOUR
CLOTHES- CHIEF CONCERN PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. PILOT ON NINE A.
B. SEVEN FIFTY FOR THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
STERN. NO BURN NODE JONES JONES
HI ALAN. ALAN NO EGGMAN FIGMA
NO GROVE HURTS BERG. OKAY SO
LAYERED NO NO WHERE DOES IT
LIVE ON. OKAY WE'LL LEAVE THAT
MEASURE ON CALL FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND SHOULD IT FAIL WE
WILL- WE WILL LOOK FOR A MOTION
FOR RECONSIDERATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LET'S OKAY. RIGHT
THE. RIGHT YOU CAN NOTICE
RECONSIDERATION RIGHT SO WILL
NOTE THAT THE COMMITTEE WILL
UNDERTAKE A MOTION FOR
RECONSIDERATION. ON RETURN- THE
LAST ITEM UP IN HEARING HERE- I
NUMBER TEN. SENATOR MOLAN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AB EIGHT
NINE SEVEN WELCOME. THANK YOU
MR CHAIR MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE
TO START OFF BY THANKING YOU
AND YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF WE
THOUGHT FOR WORK THAT HAS BEEN
DONE TO APPROVE THE BILL LIKE
GRATEFULLY ACCEPT THE OMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AS YOU KNOW CLIMATE
CHANGE IS ALREADY AFFECTING
CALIFORNIANS ESTIMATED TO DO SO
WELL INTO THE FORESEEABLE
FUTURE. CURRENT AND PROJECTED
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
INCLUDING CREASE TEMPERATURE
SEA LEVEL RISE INCREASED
WILDFIRES ALTERED PRECIPITATION
PATTERNS EXCESSIVE FLOODING IN
MORE MANY IMPACTS WILL VARY
BASED ON THE COMMITTEE'S
COMMUNITIES PHYSICAL SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC CHARACTERISTICS WHICH
TEND TO EXTEND BEYOND CITY OR
COUNTY BOUNDARIES. THIS MAKES
REGIONAL COORDINATION BETWEEN
AND AMONG LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
NONPROFITS AND PRIVATE SECTOR
ORGANIZATIONS A VITAL COMPONENT
OF THOROUGH RESILIENCY PLANNING
SOME LOCAL ENTITIES ACROSS THE
STATE A BEGUN THE PROCESS OF
PREPARING FOR THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE HOWEVER MANY
ENTITIES HAVE NOT BEGUN
COORDINATING THEIR EFFORTS AND
THEIR PREPAREDNESS WITH
ADJACENT ENTITIES IN THE REGION
AND SOME OF. NOT BEGUN PLANNING
AT ALL DUE TO THE LACK OF
COORDINATED PLANNING THE
STATE'S CURRENT MECHANISM FOR
FUNDING ADAPTATION PROJECTS HAS
BEEN PRIMARILY PIECEMEAL WITH
NO COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY FOR
COORDINATING ITS INVESTMENTS TO
ENSURE THE MOST EFFECTIVE.
RESILIENCY RETURN. THE EIGHT
NINETY SEVEN SO TO FILL THIS
GAP BY ENCOURAGING AND
SUPPORTING REGIONAL CLIMATE
ADAPTATION PLANNING THAT BUILDS
UPON AND ENHANCES LOCAL
ADAPTATION ACTIONS TO REDUCE
CLIMATE RISKS. FOSTERING
COLLABORATION AMONG LOCAL
REGIONAL AND STATE ENTITIES ON
ADAPTATION SOLUTIONS AND
FINALLY DEVELOPING GUIDANCE FOR
POTENTIAL STATE FEDERAL OR
PRIVATE INVESTMENT AND FUNDING
REGIONAL PRIORITY ADAPTATION
PROJECTS ACROSS THE STATE.
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY
VIA FOUND BRUCE RIORDAN WITH
THE BAY AREA CLIMATE ADAPTATION
NETWORK. IN THE AFOREMENTIONED
AND HEARD FROM FORMER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ROGER DICKINSON WITH THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMISSION.
GOOD THANK YOU SOME NUMBER MR
REARDON FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER
DICKINSON. YOU CAN PROCEED.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING RICHARD
STERN AND COMMITTEE MEMBER
CONGRESSMAN LINE THE RECTOR OF
THE PRAIRIE CLIMATE ADAPTATION
OF WHAT THEY CAN I ALSO MANAGE
THE CLIMATE READY NOT INSTITUTE
UC BERKELEY AND I SPEAK THIS
MORNING IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
NINE SEVEN YOU KNOW AS YOU'RE
VERY AWARE WERE NOW FACE TO
FACE TO CALIFORNIA WITH
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT. BROADER
GLOBAL CLIMATE AND GREEN PLAN
FORTUNATELY ARE CHANGING VERY
QUICKLY RECORD WILDFIRES RECORD
DROUGHT RECORD HEAT WAVES
LIKELY COMING SOON. SOME POINT
RECORD KILO RICE YOU KNOW NOT
TOO LONG AGO WE TALKED ABOUT
ALL THESE TERRIBLE THINGS THAT
MIGHT HAPPEN IN TWENTY FIFTY OR
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED WELL SUMMER
HERE ALREADY- HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND ELSEWHERE IN THE.
IMPACTS ARE AND WILL BE.
FINANCIAL IMPACT ON HOW ON
NATURAL. ON AGRIC. GROWING
CRITICAL AND- MORE. IMPORTANT
EFFECTIVELY WITH ALL OF THIS IS
COMING OUT OF WE NEED A TRULY
INTEGRATED AND WELL FUNDED
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE AFTER
ADAPTATION PROGRAM. WE NEED A
STRUCTURE- THE CREAMERY
TOGETHER SIGNIFICANT STATE
REGIONAL AND LOCAL RESOURCES IN
THE MOST EQUITABLE AND COST
EFFECTIVE MANNER AND WE NEED
THAT NOW- WE BELIEVE THAT EIGHT
NINETY SEVEN BY FOCUSING ON
REGIONAL ADAPTATION PLANNING IS
AN EXCELLENT STEP. TO CREATING
THAT STRONG CALIFORNIA
ADAPTATION PROGRAM IF YOU LOOK
AROUND THE STATE RIGHT NOW YOU
SEE CITIES COUNTIES WATER
DISTRICTS ARE REALLY BASED
ORGANIZATION TRIBES THEY'RE
ALREADY TAKING ACTION TO BUILD
LOCAL CLIMATE RESILIENCE. EIGHT
NINE SEVEN THE GREAT PROMISE
THAT IT WILL BUILD UPON THESE
PROJECTS. THESE PROJECTS AND
TIE THEM TOGETHER CHINESE
INITIATIVES TOGETHER IF WE CAN
COMBINE. LOCAL ADAPTATION
EFFORTS WITH REAL COLLABORATIVE
REGIONAL PLANNING NOT JUST
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES BUT UNITY
ORGANIZATIONS ACADEMICS ARE
REGIONAL STAKEHOLDER NETWORKS
AND OTHERS IF WE CAN COMBINE
ALL OF THOSE FOLKS. WITH
SUBSTANTIAL STATE FUNDING
SUPPORT AND GUIDANCE WE WILL
BEGIN TO MOVE FORWARD AT THE
SPEED AND THE SCALE REQUIRED WE
BELIEVE IT'S TIME FOR
CALIFORNIA TO BECOME THE GLOBAL
LEADER ON CLIMATE ADAPTATION OR
RESILIENCE WE ARE NOT THAT
GLOBAL LEADER TODAY BUT IF WE
PLANNED. AND START SPENDING
REAL MONEY CORRECTLY IN A FEW
YEARS WE COULD START TO BECOME
THAT MODEL FOR THE WORLD WE
SUPPORT EIGHTY EIGHT NINE SEVEN
IS A VERY IMPORTANT STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION FOR CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU. HE'S GOT LIKE. SO AS A
MEMBER IF YOU COULD TRY TO MAKE
IT AS BRIEF AS- MR RIORDAN WAS
A THOROUGH IN HIS REMARKS. I
WILL I WILL TRY TO DO THAT MISS
MISTER CHAIR NOW GOOD
AFTERNOON- MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS AGAIN ROGER DICKINSON
FROM NIGHT. LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMISSION- LET ME JUST GET- TO
THE ENDPOINT OF THE US- GIVEN
MR REARDON'S TESTIMONY EIGHTY
EIGHT NINETY SEVEN WILL HELP
EACH REGION ACCELERATE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF ADAPTATION
STRATEGIES AND MORE STRATEGIC
AND INCLUSIVE. MANNER WHILE
BUILDING LONGER TERM CAPACITY
AMONG AGENCIES AND
ORGANIZATIONS BY HAVING OPR
SUPPORT AND WORK WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND REGIONS EIGHTY
EIGHT NINETY SEVEN
APPROPRIATELY ADDRESSES THE
NEED FOR COLLABORATIVE APPROACH
BETWEEN. THE LOCAL AND STATE
LEVELS I RESPECTFULLY. URGE
YOUR TIME VOTE THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH SOME WILL GO TO A
GENERAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
NOW- IN THE HEARING ROOM PLEASE
WELCOME. GOOD AFTERNOON- THAT
CHAIR MEMBERS SELL MIKE MATA
GONNA BE HALF OF THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION. IN THE CESSATION OF
BAY AREA GOVERNMENTS IN SUPPORT
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS JOHN MCCLAIN ON BEHALF
OF THE PORT OF SAN DIEGO IN THE
CITY OF ENCINITAS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. I SEE NO OTHERS IN
THE HEARING ROOM GO TO A GYM
ROOM SEEING NONE WILL TURN TO
THE LINES ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
EIGHT NIGHTS AT. IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE'LL G TO LINE NUMBER
NINETY EIGHT SIX NINE EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES BACK
AFTERNOON AGAIN I MISTER
MEMBERS KAREN LAYING ON BEHALF
OF THE SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GROWING NUMBER
FIFTY SEVEN THAT'S FIVE SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BUT AFTER
THEY'RE NOT ONLY THAT BUT WE
HAVEN'T COMMITTED A MAJOR
CONNECTION IN MIDNIGHT THE
REGIONAL OPEN SPACE DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
EIGHTY SIX AT EIGHT SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
SURE MEMBERS DER DALBY
UNHAPPILY TO CALIFORNIA CITIES
FOR AN EIGHTY EIGHT NINETY
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU. BY
NUMBER TWENTY TWO ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR GAVE BLANK OR WITH ADULTS
TEENS OVER ROPES AND SPENT ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
ALSO IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER FORTY TWO FOR TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS
STEPHEN ROSE MOM AGAIN- THREE
FIFTY SILICON VALLEY IN
SUPPORT. OF EIGHTY EIGHT NINETY
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. YEAH AND DOES NOT APPEAR
WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE SECURE AT
THIS TIME OKAY- WILL TURN INTO
A POSITION WE DON'T HAVE ANY
LISTED ON FILE HERE BUT ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM SEEING NONE
OF THE ARTILLERY SEEING NONE.
TURN TO THE PHONE LINES AND WE
SHOULD TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
IF YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE SHOWING
UP IN OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME
OKAY VERY GOOD- WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE DIS I'LL JUST SAY
THE OUTSET AND THEN I'LL TURN
TO MEMBERS- YOU MEMBERS YOU CAN
FIND THE MARKUP OF THE BILL IS
PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED ON PAGE
NINE OF YOUR ANALYSIS IF YOU'RE
CURIOUS. THE TWO CENTRAL ISSUES
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU-
WORKING WITH US TO FALL THIS
CONCEPT. AND YOU'VE BEEN.
DILIGENTLY WORKING ON THIS FOR
YEARS. ONE IS HOW TO GET SMART
ABOUT LEVERAGING HAZARD
MITIGATION DOLLARS IN THIS
SPACE WE KNOW THE PLANNING IS
IMPORTANT BUT WE KNOW THAT THE
SCALE OF THE MONEY THAT'S
NEEDED TO BE INVESTING HERE. IS
STRICTLY OVERWHELMING AND- THE
SCALE OF INVESTMENT TO GET THE
STATE TO PLACE A RESILIENCE. IS
NOT IN THE EIGHTEEN OF SINGLE
DIGIT BILLIONS BUT IS. GOING TO
BE A MULTI HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLAR EFFORT WITH YOU MOVINGA
TRAIN LINE FROM FALLING INTO
THE SEA FOR AN AIRPORT THAT'S
ABOUT TO GO UNDER WATER OR
WHOLE REGION FROM BURNING DOWN
FROM WILDFIRE. IT IS ALL HANDS
ON DECK. I APPRECIATE YOU
INCORPORATING SOME OF THOSE
ELEMENTS AND REFERENCES TO
HAZARD MITIGATION PLANS THE
STATE HAZARD MITIGATION PLAN
ADAPTATION PLANNING GUIDE AND-
AND- YES IS IT AS A- CRITICAL
PARTNER. WITH OPR IN THIS
EFFORT. IF WE CAN LEVERAGE FEMA
DOLLARS AND LOOK FOR OTHER
CREATIVE FEDERAL KIND OF FUNDS
TO FRONT LOAD SOME OF THIS.
PROJECT WORK I THINK WE CAN GET
A LOT DONE AND IF THE PLANNING
IS SORT OF GOING TOWARDS
FINANCING IN MIND. I THINK IT'S
VERY EXCITING- I KNOW IT'S AN
ELEMENT IN OUR BUDGET.
DISCUSSIONS AS WELL HERE TOO.
THE OTHER PIECE IT WAS JUST I
APPRECIATE YOUR RECOGNITION OF.
SO MANY DIFFERENT KINDS OF-
GOVERNMENT STRUCTURES AND
COUNTY SIZES AND- A MULTI YOU
KNOW. SACKED DELTA OR BAY AREA
ELEMENT MAY HAVE NINE COUNTIES
INVOLVED. WHEN YOU HAVE A
COUNTY OF ELEVEN MILLION PEOPLE
IN LOS ANGELES- IT MAY NOT EVEN
BE A MULTI COUNTY EFFORT IT MAY
JUST BE A MATTER OF GETTING LA
ITSELF. TO DO THAT KIND OF-
INTRA REGIONAL PLANNING- SAN
DIEGO FOR INSTANCE WAS NOTED-
IN THE LAST ADAPTATION PLANS
AS- A REGION UNTO ITSELF- SO.
WITH SOME OF THOSE LARGER LAND
MASS IN COUNTIES. I APPRECIATE
YOU YOU WORKING THROUGH THAT
WITH US AND- HOPING TO GET-
MORE THAT SUPPORT ON ONTO YOUR
BILL WITH THIS FRAMEWORK SO.
WANT TO WORK WITH YOU GOING
FORWARD ON THAT AND TRY TO GET.
LOS ANGELES VENTER- THE
RIVERSIDE SAN BERNARD DINO IS
ALL THOSE FOLKS. ENGAGE BECAUSE
I CAN THIS IS A REALLY SMART
KERRY- TO TRY TO GET FOLKS
WORKING TOGETHER AND WE'RE NOT
MOVING FAST ENOUGH SO- THAT'S
MY QUICK TO SENSE. WHAT IS
ENTERTAINMENT AND THEN TO
SENATORS LAYER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I'M A TEACHER AND I JUST A
MONTH SO IT'S NICE TO SEE MY
FRIEND THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
MOVE THIS BILL. VERY GOOD WE
HAVE A MOTION CENTER LATER ON.
I HAVE A COMMENT AND THEN A
QUESTION. EXCUSE ME AND THAT
THAT COMMENT IS OUT THANKS FOR
DOING THIS BECAUSE THE WHOLE
QUESTION IS ABOUT THE NEXT
STEPS. IN RESILIENCY AND
ADAPTATION AND IT'S INTERESTING
BECAUSE THIS BILL. REALLY
DECIDES AT THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH AS IT DID
IN THE PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION
DO EXECUTIVE ORDER PUT IT WITH
THE NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY
COMPLETELY BUT I DON'T HAVE A
DOG IN THAT HUNT ANYMORE. IT
AND SO THERE ARE STILL AS THE
CHAIR NOTED MANY DIFFERENT
AGENCIES THAT ARE DOING
DIFFERENT PIECES OF IT I MEAN.
WE SUPERVISED THE FORCE CLIMATE
ASSESSMENT AND THE SAFEGUARDING
PLANNED SAFEGUARDING PLAN IS
REFERENCED HERE. BUT MY
QUESTION IS NORMALLY THE
ANALYSIS WAS RELATED BILLS THAT
ARE MOVING OR MOVED IN AND THAT
DOESN'T SEEM TO HAVE. BEEN
INCLUDED IN THIS AND THE PRO
TEM HAS A BILL. SENATE BILL ONE
THAT ACTUALLY CONTEMPLATES
REGIONAL COLLABORATIVES OR OR
SOME KIND OF REGIONAL EFFORT
WITH REGARD TO SEA LEVEL RISE
AND SO IT SEEMS LIKE THEY'RE
PARALLEL HERE. ARE YOUR DOING
COLLABORATIVE'S ALL OVER THE
STATE WITH REGARD TO RESILIENCY
AND HER BILL WAS DOING IT- WITH
REGARD TO SEA LEVEL RISE AND I
WONDERED IF YOU. JUST COMMIT
OVER THE BREAK TO WORK TO MAKE
SURE THAT SOMEHOW. THOSE FIFTY.
BECAUSE BECAUSE WE SHOULDN'T BE
JUST MOVING AHEAD WITH TWO
DIFFERENT. STRUCTURES ABOUT A
PIECE OF THE SAME ISSUE.
ABSOLUTELY SENATOR- AND TOTALLY
COMMITTED TO DOING THAT- WE
THINK THIS BILL IS
COMPLEMENTARY TO S. B. Y. AND-
AS IT WILL PROVIDE A STATE-
GUIDANCE FOR THE REGIONAL
ADAPTATION PLANNING ISSUE ONCE
FOCUSING ON PROVIDING THE
RESOURCES TO ASSIST LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. IN THAT REGARD- IN
THE RESPONSE TO C. LEVEL RISE
BUT I SEE IT IS IT AS
COMPLEMENTARY BUT IF THERE ARE
IF THERE IF IT IS COMPLEMENTARY
EXCUSE ME. MISTER CHAIR IT IS
COMPLEMENTARY BUT IT DOES SET
UP TWO STRUCTURES THAT ARE
SOMEWHAT COMPETING AND IT SEEMS
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE TO BE IF
IT'S FIGURED OUT SO I'M JUST
SUGGEST BECAUSE I UNDERSTAND
YOUR BILL UNDERSTAND HER BILL.
I UST THINK YOU SHOULD WORK
TOGETHER SO THAT THERE'S NOT TO
COME PLEASE HAVE SOME
ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED TO THAT
SIR. GREAT THANK YOU- WE DO
HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR EGG
MAN AND I WOULD SAY IN ADDITION
SP ONE. THERE'S A BILL MOVING
ON STATE- THE STATE HAD AT
SAFEGUARDING CALIFORNIA PLAN
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL-
THERE WAS A BILL FROM LAST IT
WAS PASSED ON TO CALTRANS
PLANNING EFFORT TO GET THEM.
THE WAY I SEE THIS IS.
ORGANIZING THE BOTTOM UP SIDE
SO THAT HE CAN LINK WITH. THE
TOP DOWN WORK WORK THAT'S GOING
ON IN S. P. ONES THAT THEY'RE
ABLE TO SAY. LEVERAGE THE
COASTAL COMMISSION OR THE- PC'S
WORKER CALTRANS WORK AND SORT
OF. MEMORY THE TOP DOWN FROM
THE BOTTOM UP AND TRY TO GET
THAT COLLABORATION ESPECIALLY
BRINGING IN. VOICES THAT MAYBE
HAVEN'T BEEN AT THE TABLE AS
WELL I KNOW UNDER RESOURCE IN
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES ARE
CRITICAL THIS EFFORT TO SELL.
THANKS FOR THAT- SEEING NO
OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS A LADY
CLOSER. SO LET ME JUST SAY
AGAIN I THANK YOU MR CHAIR- I
THINK WE'VE EMBEDDED LOCAL
FLEXIBILITY HERE YET WITH THOSE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THIS IN
THIS COMMITTEE. IT'S ABOUT YOU
KNOW ESTABLISHING THESE
NETWORKS WITH FLEXIBILITY- THE
CERTIFICATION OF THE PLANS AND-
GETTING SORT OF THE STRUCTURE
IN PLACE WHEN THE FUNDING%
COMES. OUT WHERE THEY WERE ABLE
TO DEPLOY THOSE RESOURCES
EFFECTIVELY I'M JUST STRUCK BY
THE MAGNITUDE OF THIS CHALLENGE
I THINK I'VE CITED THIS BEFORE
BUT TO YOUR POINT. I JUST IN MY
COUNTY ALONE SAN MATTEO COUNTY
TWENTY FOUR BILLION WITH A B.
AT RISK. WITH THE INUNDATION
ZONE THE PROPERTY VALUES I MEAN
THIS IS AN ENORMOUS CHALLENGE
SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A DOWN
PAYMENT IN THE IN THE CLIMATE
RESILIENCE PACKAGE- WHICH
YOU'VE BEEN INVOLVED. IN THESE
CONVERSATIONS ARE. STILL THIS
IS US ARE THE BUILDING BLOCKS
GETTING IS IN PLACE SO WHEN
THE- WHEN DOLLARS CAN COMMON
YES HOPEFULLY FEDERAL DOLLARS
AS WELL. THEY CAN BE DEPLOYED
EFFECTIVELY IN CALIFORNIA
CANNOT BE LEADING. ON
ADAPTATION AND RESILIENCY MOST
IMPORTANTLY RESILIENCY- GOING
FORWARD SO WITH THAT I ASKED
FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU- SO THE
MOTION IS. TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- CHIEF AND
SOMETHING'S GONE WRONG. BY
LIGHT AND TEN AB EIGHT NINE
SEVEN THE MOTION IS DUE PASSES
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
STERN. STERN ALL RIGHT JONES.
ALAN BATEMAN AIKMAN HI GROVE
HERZBERG ALL RIGHT KIRCH BERG
ALL RIGHT AWAY SO WE SAW ON A
LAYERED HI THERE I LET ALONE.
ALL RIGHT IT HAS SIX SIX. WE
GET SIX VOTES ON THAT BELIEVE
THE MEASURE ON CALL THANK YOU
SO MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER- I.
THINK WE'VE GOT THE ABSENT
MEMBERS HERE. WILL WORK THROUGH
SO MUCH AS WE CAN OUT OF CENTER
ALLEN'S MISSING FROM ONE.
FLIGHT LET'S ROLL THROUGH- YOU
WANNA START THE CONSENT
CALENDAR MEMBERS WERE GOING TO
OPEN THE ROLE IN THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CONSENT CALENDAR FILE
ITEM ONE A. B. NINE FILE ITEM
ELEVEN AB TWELVE NINETY EIGHT
FILE ITEM TWELVE. AV. FOURTEEN
THIRTY ONE THE CURRENT VOTERS
FIVE ZERO. GROVE HERTZBERG BY
HERTZ BIRD ALL RIGHT AWAY SO WE
SAW ON A LOAN. THE MOON HI.
ELLEN OKAY- THAT BILL IS OUT-
WELCOME TO A BEAT SEVENTEEN
WOULD FILE ITEM TO AB EIGHT
SEVENTEEN THE CURRENT VOTE IS
FIVE ZERO GROVE HERZBERG. WITH
THE MEN'S- HERE IS TO DO. PASS
AS YOU PASS AS AMENDED. SORRY
DO DO PASS AS AMENDED. HURTS
BERG ALL RIGHT WAY SO WE SO I
LET ALONE LET ALONE HI THAT HAS
EIGHT OKAY THAT IS A THAT
MEASURES OUT PHONE THREE B. TWO
FIVE TWO- FILERS THREE A BEEF
TWO FIVE TO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON RULES-
GROVE. POKER VOTERS FIVE ZERO
GROVE AS A MAN- WAIT WAIT WITH
AMENDMENTS TO BE TAKEN IN OF
GOOD GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE AND
WITH COMMITMENT TO WORK WITH
COMMITTEE STAFF OF BOTH
COMMITTEES. TO RESOLVE- SERIES
OF OTHER ISSUES THAT I CAN READ
IT IF IT'S THAT GOOD. TESTING
ME- OKAY SO- HERZBERG
PARKERSBURG ALL RIGHT WAY SO WE
SO I LIVE ON THE MOON ALL RIGHT
THAT HAS EIGHT OKAY THAT
MEASURES OUT. FINE FOR YOU B.
TWO EIGHT FOUR REAVIS FOLLOWING
FOR A B. TWO EIGHT FOUR REVERSE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS THE
CURRENT PHONE IS FOUR ONE.
GROVE HURTS BERG. ALL RIGHT WAY
SO. WE I AM. MOAN ALL RIGHT
THAT HAS SEVEN OKAY ONE SEVEN
VOTES THAT MEASURE IS OUT.
FALLON FIVE MAYBE THREE SEVEN
NINE GALLAGHER. PILOT OF FIVE
EIGHTY THREE SEVEN NINE
GALLAGHER- THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THE CURRENT
POTUS FIVE ZERO GROVE HURTS
BERG. BIRDS BIRD ALL RIGHT AWAY
SO WE SO ARE YOU A MOM. OKAY
COOL LEAVE OKAY THE- THE NEXT
IS FILING I'M SIX AB FIVE TO
FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS THE
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE ZERO
JONES I. JONES IRA ALAN GROVE
HERTZBERG HERZBERG ALL RIGHT
AWAY SO WE SO I LIVE ON THE
MOON ALL RIGHT THAT HAS SEVEN
WE WILL LIVE IN MEASURING
COFFEE AS A MEMBER OKAY- FILE
ITEM SEVEN A. B. SIX ONE FOUR
THE KERR- THE MOTIONS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS THE CURRENT
VOTE IS FOUR ZERO JONES JONES
ARI GROVE HERZBERG HURTS BERG
ALL RIGHT WAY SO WE SO I LOAN.
LOAN ALL RIGHT THAT HAS EIGHT
OKAY THAT IS EIGHT THAT
MEASURES OUT IF I LET ME SEE
LET ALONE EAT A. B. SIX NINE
SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS THE
CURRENT VOTE IS. FOUR ZERO
JONES- GROW. I HEARD ARI SO WE
SO ARE YOU A MOAN MOAN ALL
RIGHT THAT HAS SEVEN SEVEN THE
MEASURES OUT FILING A NUMBER
NINE BY A LOT OF MINE A. B.
SEVEN FIFTY FOR THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS THE
CURRENT VOTE IS ONE FOR- GOOD
GROOVE. HERTZBERG WAY SO
LIMONEIRA. THAT MOTION OKAY
THEN MEASURE FAILS- DO WE NEED
A MOTION FOR RECONSIDERATION OR
YOU'VE BEEN WITHOUT OBJECTION
WITHOUT OBJECTION GRANT
RECONSIDERATION ON A. B. SEVEN
FIVE FOUR FROM- FILE ITEM TEN
AB EIGHT NINE SEVEN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THE CURRENT VOTE
IS SIX ZERO JONES JONES NO ALAN.
GROVE. THAT HAS SEVEN SEVEN-
THAT MEASURES OUT WE WILL WAIT
JUST A SEC HERE. ONE LAST VOTE
FROM THE ABSENT MEMBER THANK
YOU TO EVERYONE ELSE HEY BEFORE
WEALTH SHOWS YOUR LEAVE. THIS
WILL BE OUR LAST HEARING OF THE
YEAR SO FOR EVERYONE LISTENING
OUT THERE AND- TV LAND OR ON
THE INTERNET. THE STAFF MAKES
ALL THIS WORK HAPPEN- WE STAND
HERE AT THE END OF THE RESULTS
AND IT LOOKS POLISHED OR SEMI
POLISHED- AT LEAST BUT THEY GET
IT- THEY GET INTO THE WEEDS AND
REALLY MAKE SOME SERIOUS
PROGRESS HERE AND I WANT TO
THANK THEM FOR THEIR HARD WORK-
OUR COMMITTEE ASSISTANT. SANDER
SANDERS WHO'S NEW TO US AND OUR
pWORK- ACCULTURATED HERSELF- TO
THE WAYS OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
DESPITE VERY TRICKY
CIRCUMSTANCES DURING THE
PANDEMIC SO THANK YOU SANDRA-
THIS WAS OUR PRINCIPAL
CONSULTANT CATHERINE MOORE. IS
A LONG STANDING MEMBER THE
COMMITTEE STARTED AS A FELLOW
AND HAS BEEN- SAGE WISDOM IN A
STEADY HAND THROUGHOUT. OUR
NEWEST CONSULTANT CATHERINE
BAXTER- WHO HAS BEEN A HUGE
ADDITION TO THIS COMMITTEE AND
WEIGHING IN ON EVERYTHING FROM
ADAPTATION AND RESILIENCE TO.
PARKS AND FIRE- AND THEN OUR
STEADY HAND ASSAD MOFFETT THE
REPUBLICAN CONSULTANT
APPRECIATE TODD'S WORK HERE-
AND- WITH THAT- WILL BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE TO REOPEN THE
ROLES- BEFORE I THINK THE CHIEF
CONSULTANT- WHO. CLEVERLY LEFT
HIMSELF OUT OF ALL THE
ACKNOWLEDGMENTS BUT FOR THE
TIME BEING- LOOKS OPEN I THINK
IT'S ONLY FIVE ITEM SIX SIX.
SORRY SIX IN TEN WE'RE GONNA RE
OPENS A CERTIFIED. I'M SIXTY
FIVE TO FIVE CHOOSE. WHILE I AM
SIXTY B. FIVE FIVE THE COURT
VOTE IS SEVENS. ALLEN ALLEN ALL
RIGHT THAT HAS EIGHT THAT IS
EIGHT THAT THOSE OUT. FILE IN
TEN EIGHTY EIGHT NINE SEVEN
ONE. FIVE AM TEN EIGHT A. B.
EIGHT NINE SEVEN THE CURRENT
MOVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS THE
CURRENT VOTE IS SIX ONE. ALAN
ALAN HI THAT HAS SEVEN OKAY
THAT MEASURES OUT. WE HAVE
DISPOSED WITH ALL OF OUR WORK
AND I'LL JUST CLOSE BY SAYING I
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF OUR
CHIEF CONSULTANT HERE WHO IS
FAR GONE HIS- SEMIANNUAL HAIR
CUT AND ALL KINDS OF OTHER
MATTERS- BUT HIS WISDOM GROWS
DAILY AND WE WOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO DO THIS WORK WITHOUT HIMSELF
THANK YOU MR O'CONNOR FOR YOUR
WORK- AND WITH THAT THE SENATE
NATURAL RESOURCE IN WATER
COMMITTEES HEREBY ADJOURNED.